Man that PRP,
platelet rich plasma with stem cells is that Shit Dude in Vegas?
Yeah.
One week later,
my elbows feeling great.
It's the Brian counts show,
ladies.
Gentlemen.
We are live.
They Brian Callen MMA kaolin spectacular.
That's right.
Fresh off a Christmas.
Everybody had a bit of the flu.
Touch the flu.
Put me on my back for a couple hours every day.
Did you get that rally shirt?
Did you get the flu shots?
Nope.
Did Not.
I should.
Who gets the shot?
I don't get those.
I should lose up 70%.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Well apparently it's a very complicated thing to try to nail which flu virus is
going to hit people and they don't get it.
They don't get it.
Right.
A lot.
Yeah.
The CDC will sometimes be like,
listen,
we just checked this flu's coming in.
It's a bitch.
But here's the problem.
A lot of times I'll even admit when you get the flu shot,
it doesn't take,
it doesn't,
it helps a little bit.
Um,
it will make the film.
You get less,
you can get the flu.
That's what they're injecting the flu and the flu shot.
It's like the sickest,
it's the dengue virus,
but it has,
there's a reaction that some people have to do it right?
Yeah.
You can never know.
You can have a,
when you're sick,
if you're about to get sick or you're feeling sick,
don't get the flu shot.
They say,
yeah.
They say don't get it when your immune system's compromised,
but sometimes they can give you the flu shot and everybody will get the flu and
you won't.
So it does work.
Yes,
sometimes.
Yeah,
but I don't do it.
I need to.
I just don't,
you know,
it's like,
do I want to go in there and get a shot?
I'm a pussy.
I'm like,
ah,
I'll just get sick for 10 minutes.
I just don't want to do it.
I'll tell you what,
if I'm Francis or if I'm steep,
am trying to give fucking Francis the flu.
A little segue lotion.
Fucking poisonous.
Some North Korean just,
Oh yeah.
Something.
They found that North Korean soldier that defected.
He had been vaccinated against anthrax.
What?
Yeah.
And they're like,
wait,
what?
Yeah.
He's the second guy that defected in a month.
Oh yeah.
What did that guy,
oh yeah,
cause I,
the first guy,
they found like crazy parasites in his,
in his thing and he was eating raw like everything.
They're starving to death over there.
And North Korea.
Well communism works especially,
it doesn't turn into,
it's a monarchy.
It's not,
communism was asked all you fucking freaks out there.
All you young millennials were beads.
Just getting into Korea.
Look,
I'm not your history,
a history major,
but I know enough about history to know about Marxism law.
Especially after talking to Jordan Peterson about her.
I dove deep and do it.
It just great.
It was like,
what?
What is the history of this stuff?
It's all terrible.
Of course it doesn't work.
No,
it's like,
it's not human nature.
You need,
you need a central power.
You need someone to keep the ones that are getting,
I talked to an academic the other day,
I said,
so what are you saying?
He just kept talking about the,
the,
um,
and he's talking about the Scandinavian system of government and how great it
was.
I go.
When was the last time you bought something made in Scandinavia?
I like Scandinavia,
like sobs,
sobs and Ikea is kind sobs,
a good call.
There are certain things we're talking about an iPad right now are the ones that
you know that everything was made in the marketplace.
Fuck.
Well
it's definitely a smaller place too,
right?
You know,
you're not dealing with it.
It's called [inaudible] and Sweden.
What's the last good thing Russia made?
It's a good point.
Not,
not the Kalashnikov.
Yeah,
the Kalashnikov and they made some good rifles and they made,
so they had some good strides they made in rocketry.
You know,
there were the first guy to put a guy into orbit,
although the absolutely did fake the video footage that they released of Eureka
Garr off.
Is that his name?
Yuri Gagarin.
Yuri Gagarin in space.
They've proven that there's no way you could get the kind of camera that you
would need to record that.
Which film in that small capsule that he was floating around in space and,
and then there's light coming from two dogs.
So they have like lights on these dump Fox.
They have lights on him,
he's going to cabin and he's faking that.
He's like,
I think he really did do it,
but they didn't really get footage of him doing so.
They fixed the footage,
get that footage that the Russians have bumping into because Russia has just
propaganda.
They all did it.
The Russians are amazing at anything.
They put their mind to like that.
The culture itself,
they work so hard.
Like when if you look at them,
they're like,
we want to be great.
Powerlifters great,
great wrestlers.
Anything that [inaudible] doing steroids even that really?
Did you watch that movie?
[inaudible] Fogel Movie Chris?
Yeah.
How fucking crazy so that everybody doing everybody,
everybody,
everybody banned.
They banned them.
But here's what's really squirrely band.
One of the things they did,
they took a metals away from a couple of people,
but the people,
they take metals away,
like they say,
you can't compete in this sport and now they've pulled them out of a couple
sports that nobody gives a fuck about.
And here's the other problem,
the IOC and Wada,
the world antidoping agency,
they're completely interconnected.
People work for both of them.
They go back and forth in between each other.
They have an incestuous relationship and that was all exposed by Bryan Fogel in
that movie.
It's a fucking great movie and Chris,
if you haven't seen it,
you want to know like the depths of doping.
I love that guy.
I love that Russia Russian guy was fascinating to me and he,
he had been an athlete and then he's in a witness protection program,
right?
I mean he's basically afraid for his life.
Yes.
Russia is banned from the 2018 Olympics and the athletes are told to compete
under the Olympic flag.
You're not representing a company,
so a country rather.
So now the Olympics are a country.
Olympics.
Got to get their own country.
That's going to be the new America elliptical there.
The concert dad state,
most of these states,
it's state sponsored and the antibiotics were coming out of China I think,
and not all over crazy.
If you think rushes is the only one crazy,
you're crazy.
China did the same thing.
Bryan Fogel pointed out the China did the exact same thing in Beijing.
They want all these fucking gold metals like crazy.
They were winning gold medals and when there's a disproportionate amount of gold
medals that are being one in your home country.
Yeah,
got an old car.
Okay.
I'm skeptical.
Hip Off.
Oh,
why?
why am I a little,
uh,
why am I a little concerned here that the financial gains of making that many
Olympic gold medals are so fucking irresistible,
dude,
look what it did for Jamaica.
Oh yeah.
You don't make
it on how the fast burners in the world,
Brandon,
they're not known for that kind of,
that kind of national or
international sports now.
Right.
But there's no denying that there is an extreme and rampant abuse of performance
nursing drive,
but up,
up,
up.
No,
they haven't been causing for k one guys,
they took the relay gold medal after call the beast and he might've been,
I think they're all called the beast.
Well,
when I was talking to victor contact,
who is,
by the way,
as balls deep into that world as possible,
the ultimate snitch of snitches,
snitches,
first team,
all snitch.
It's the guy who was the head of Balco who made that clear shit.
It was undetectable for a little while until they figured out how to detect it,
which is what they always do.
He said all the track and field's dirty.
Of course,
all of it.
Yeah.
So if you get some dudes coming out of Jamaica or France or Spain or whatever,
and they just burst onto the scene,
they start fucking running fascinated.
But who else?
They're doing some shit that no one knows about it.
I know a woman is going to compete for our country.
How bigs or did it happen that she had it?
She had a dick on it,
but the steroids didn't him.
But she was at trend to be a triathlete and she was quite,
she was American,
but she was going to represent the country of her art.
And I started training and she was phenomenal athlete and everything else.
And her coach said,
so,
uh,
now of course we got to talk about getting to the next level.
Whoa.
And she goes,
I'm a triathlete,
which I wanted.
I said,
we gotta,
we gotta start talking about messing with your endocrine system because you're
not gonna,
you're not gonna get these times until we,
it came,
we compete.
And He,
and she,
and then when she saw that everybody,
and he's like,
well,
none of them,
he's famous coach.
He's like this,
this is just a reality.
She was like,
God,
that's what she's doing.
She didn't do it.
I would the Lance Armstrong story,
like Lance Armstrong realized when he was young that everybody is doing drugs,
all of them.
And so he who competed clean when he was young until he got to a certain level
and he's like,
fuck,
like this is just how this goddamn thing works.
It's just this week,
three card Monte game of hiding your dirty piss.
And he was better than everybody has that a bad guy state sponsored?
Yeah.
It's just part of the game.
What,
what do you think?
Like,
so,
so my feeling is,
uh,
like so,
so if weightlifters are gonna move world record weights,
it's really exciting to see them do that.
And obviously it power lifters and stuff like that are,
are not going to be lifting as much with testosterone.
My question is,
are we ever going to be beat like the inexorable advance of technology.
Are we ever going to really be able to start as we are able to gene dope and all
that stuff.
Like where are we going with this and and is always going can be a cat and
mouse.
Can we gonna yeah.
Are we going to police this?
Know everyone's always going to look for an edge always.
But in powerlifting,
yeah.
I don't give a fuck what they do cause the power lifting,
you know?
So when it comes to fighting,
fighting football,
number one.
Yeah,
those are the two.
Number one fuck f for sure.
Football and fighting because you're hitting on is too.
Yeah.
Football's a combat sport.
It's just got rigid rules when you're running full clip at each other and
literally like knocking each other unconscious cause your head butting each
other.
Yeah.
I mean which is baseball.
You don't,
a big part of football was until they stop people doing that.
Yeah.
It's a combat sport.
100% it just doesn't have kicks or punches.
But the juice is worth the squeeze and football.
It's worth the squeeze financially,
financially,
educationally.
There's the same.
There's,
how about baseball where your bat speed stays the same?
No,
I don't give a fuck.
Hit all the home runs you want baseball.
Baseball is,
it's a good argument for steroids because it's a boring fucking game too.
And then you're awesome.
It's fun was when someone hits that ball.
When was it fun?
When Jose can say,
come on Barry Bonds and mark McGwire that cracking them out of the park.
That's when it's fun.
And I don't like that.
You get there,
you're playing 160 games and you break down to the season.
Peeps.
You too many gay Siri.
Too many games.
Simply too many games.
Yeah.
If you're sprinting full out all the time like that,
trying to get to third base.
Yeah.
There's so many times where you're doing damage to your body and you're not
going to have a chance to recover.
Yeah.
But if you're on the Jews who couldn't run faster,
you can keep go.
So what do you think?
But it's weird with the MLB how they cracked down on it,
right?
They're killing it now,
but the same with UFC,
like they cracked down on it,
so now you have Usada but then you're not getting as good as the product that I
don't think there's anything wrong with the product right there on the UFC.
I think it's as good as it's ever been.
But how dare you?
I did a few fighters have dropped off the map,
but I think that's probably a good thing because I think those guys are probably
agregious.
I'd see.
I think it's a combination.
I think the skill level's going up just naturally,
you know,
through evolution skill is going up,
but when you have such strict testing,
then we're missing out on certain guys like John Jones and these other guys.
Well,
the John John's wants is very unfortunate because John is just
just one of the most talented guys of all time,
if not the most talented.
He's number one and also the biggest disaster in terms of the big mistakes that
he's made.
Like,
dude,
we've never had a fighter that did a hit and run on a pregnant woman and broke
her arm and then took off and then test positive for drugs because he's on Dick
Pills and then test positive again after his comeback after a spectacular went
over Daniel Cormier.
And he's so disappointed in that regard.
So exceptional in his physical abilities,
but the dis,
the choices he makes and the decisions that come out of those choices.
So just fucking terrible.
But a lot of it's because of the strict testing that the UFC hired you guys
decide to do with the car accident.
That has nothing to do with the car accident,
but so like Klaxon yes,
but yeah,
now,
yes,
he'd be,
he'd be cleared,
he'd be all good.
Yes.
But it's,
there's a symptom is a symptom of something else going on.
You know,
and people don't like to discuss this,
but one of the things that easily could be is that John has impulse control
because he's been sparring and fighting and at the highest level of the sport
for many,
many years now.
And he's gotten hit in the head of gang of times.
There's no,
there's no way around it.
There was just an article I posted on Twitter that came out a couple of days ago
that these neuroscientists
we're examining um,
brain injury and violent behavior and like how they're connected and how damaged
to certain areas of the brain has irreparable consequences on the decision
making ability.
The person who gets hit,
I think that's part of it,
but also,
you know,
he's been wild since high wild college,
which is the why.
So dude,
that's why he's a fucking,
one of the reasons why you is because he's a wild motherfucker and I loved that
part.
Connor's a little while too.
He's wild,
wild like you lit call masterminds of this game.
They're all little wild man to be 80 sport though.
Look at,
look at Cam Newton prior looking at some of the greatest fighters.
Wait,
if Francis Ghana,
Colin's the world championship and spreads those super power genes throughout
this great nation of ours.
Okay,
we won't need steroids.
Go and goes.
You're having a champion of the world.
Take a little bump here of this guy's Francis kids.
Part of that.
Maybe he doesn't want the devil's Dandruff.
See all fuck steep aimia the sitch he's gotta get,
he's got to stop sleep bay from double or single leg and him taking him to the
ground and riding them.
So you guys be careful cause I'm saying Steve Bay is gonna wrestle him to the
ground.
I love hiring sincere.
Brian Count comes out brand council.
I don't know what the tire him out and then he's going to stand them up in the
third,
fourth round and all that stress is going to go away.
Well it's entirely possible as Steve Bay winds,
this Dbas the world heavyweight champions,
tpa beaten junior dos Santos by knockout.
He beat a Orlowski by knockout.
He beat Overeem by knocking that.
He's,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He won the title with a one punch falling away.
Right hand on the button.
He's a bad motherfucker.
No doubt about it.
But there's,
there's physical undeniable characteristics that in Ghana who possesses that
make him the most terrifying guy in the sport.
But we haven't.
The only,
the only shot that them seeing what Steve Bay when this fight though is
stylistically he could be the Achilles heel to Francis.
Meaning he doesn't entertain the standup.
He just puts that fucking forehead in the middle of his chest as I,
dude,
we're riding this out till the third,
fourth round.
Let's see what you can do here.
It's totally possible.
But Alster when he clinched up with them,
Allister is fucking huge and to clenched up with within Ghana and it was like
trying to bear hug a wall.
You see his face,
he liked red state and then when he gets flipped around and he's like,
Oh shit,
that's not snowflake.
That's not snowflake.
And then just get the ceiling on the co five four rounds,
three rounds.
No,
no.
I think the most he's ever been as to,
he got taken out in his first fight against the Curtis blades.
You shouldn't hang your head on that because Curtis blades with a Juco,
national champion Juco,
national chancellor.
Fucking good recipe.
But she's an excellent athlete too and he keeps getting better and better.
Curtis Blades,
a real dark horse in the sport.
I really think that 10 now,
if he keeps improving and keeps working at the radius,
he's a big guy.
He hits hard,
fucking aggressive and smart standups has got,
hopefully it's working with Christian Alan out there and tell her I'll,
his standup's kind of is.
It's US getting better at getting better.
He's getting at it.
But the thing is he's got a lot to work with.
Like he's,
yeah,
he's got a lot to work with and he's a young guy.
Look at the Juco national champs.
He was like,
well,
so is he looks a 74,
but how old is he?
John is Juco national champions.
Anthony Rumble Johnson June.
That's June.
Yeah.
Um,
well this is a lot of guys.
He Won.
He was [inaudible] stairs.
Uh,
I think so.
I'm played baseball.
There's a lot of guys were phenomenal athletes.
It never wind up going to a big college just because they don't have the
athletic or maybe we go financial.
Curtis blades has a,
he has a lot of potential.
Dude,
he has a lot of potential and he's only 26.
I think in Ghana it was what,
33 32 33 how old's France?
Not a young chicken,
but he had some rough years fighting on the streets and camera room.
Yeah.
31 31 so in Ghana is 31 so think about Curtis plays in five years.
Think about it.
He keeps getting better.
Five years ago we didn't even know who I am.
Gone.
I was two years ago.
He makes his UFC debut.
Two years later,
everybody's lying on their back and he's fighting for the title and I called him
to check Congo with braids and I want to apologize.
He doesn't appraise anymore.
Now he's got fired.
It's all jives for that.
Now he's going to start highlighted tips.
Nobody says a word about it and not a,
not a word dude.
I saw him in the first few weeks he had been through since I retired.
I went to that UFC that we at in Vegas and there I was around the fighters and
all that and there was one hot dog left,
went to grab the hot dog and he reached for the hot dog.
He fucking deboned me on a hot day.
Like even out of the Bro.
It's fucking huge.
He's scared.
Nicest guy though.
He's a very nice guy.
Very nice guy.
So I think that,
you know,
Steve Bay is,
you have to say that Steve Bay is the most experience.
Steve Bay has real wins over worldclass competition other than Allister and our
Lawsky who are the two guys that in Gando fought.
So he's gotten more experienced,
haven't been Verdomme,
haven't beating,
having beaten,
you know,
top flight guys,
junior dos Santos by chaos arena style to though he's got a chance.
Yeah.
I mean if he does have to makers have him as it as a disadvantage and I Steve
Bay.
Yeah.
He's an underdog.
I watched that.
That upper cut that he hit with a v Overeem,
Overeem him,
please don't,
I watched her teeth full.
Like I washed it in full speed.
Full speed.
So fast it like in real time,
it's so fast.
It's so much faster than you realize.
Depending on the angle you look at it.
What was,
oh my God,
I
watch it.
Couldn't get hit by him.
So he was trying to be wild in over him.
Just wet,
wet.
Oh yeah.
Mom,
the greatest strikers and the heavyweight division all the time.
Fuck it.
But Watch how fast it goes and we have it.
Yeah,
let's go find the video.
Crazy fast.
Like a weird shootout with over him.
Just be like all the experience.
Be like,
how's the one way France can win the first round?
Fuck it.
Let's just throw from her hip.
See what happens.
I know like why didn't you like kick his legs on the outside?
It's watch how fast this is.
What?
See Look,
look,
go to Allister is doing,
he's just trying to be like real awkward.
You said this was at the gala.
He said that.
Yeah.
What was the game plan?
Not this.
Oh,
such a hard left hook to God knock out.
You know what that's like?
That's like a bone crusher.
Smith Shovel Hook.
And when bone crusher Smith used to have that ridiculous lefthand and it was
like a half hug,
half upper cut.
That was just a shovel man.
Terrifying.
And then when you find out his dad was a legendary street fighter in Cameroon,
you like,
oh,
okay.
That was legendary.
Oh.
And then he was homeless five years ago,
five years ago.
Just did that stuff.
Oh,
you mean the movie Lionheart yeah,
that's fucking him.
And all he does is train man.
All he does his training practically lives at the UFC performance institute.
Really?
He's there every day.
He's dfcs bank.
Do you have cs performance institute is the most state of the art motherfucking
place you've ever seen your life is terms of recovery in terms of strength and
conditioning equipment.
I mean it is a fucking spectacular and he just lives there.
He's there every day.
They moved him there.
Yeah,
they moved him from France to Vegas.
His trainers there.
Well he,
Vinnie Magallanes I know is working with them in terms of his Jujitsu,
but his original trainer that found him in Paris is with him here.
I forget the gentleman's name,
but this is the UFC performance institute.
It's fucking phenomenal.
Is My thing with this Joe crazy.
So let's say,
so France,
they're doing his camp left.
Steve Bates,
I came in,
I want those.
I'm gonna do my camp there too.
It's a good point.
And Steve Bay as a champ,
but so what they do,
luckily,
you know it's not an issue because Steve Bay is in Cleveland and he has his same
coaches that he's always had and a real tight knit team that's working on a
farm.
I'm saying at some point,
let's say,
where's that girl a full makeup on.
What's she's throwing punches.
Easy,
hottest girl ever enter the octagon.
She fought you think so dude,
that girl is,
I got nothing for it,
but I don't know about that man.
You think she's hotter than that?
Rachel,
how do you see her name?
Asta Vic girl that just fought for the,
uh,
the ultimate,
let me say the ultimate fighter TV show with that.
You're talking about the two old biddies I'm talking about.
Yeah,
the girl from Hawaii.
Oh,
dark,
dark hair.
See this down long.
She's sustained.
One bounced on rooting for just to see if you can find her.
We were one of the shitty viewers for.
She's way more,
well,
I don't want say the girls ugly girls.
Definitely not ugly.
She's very pretty.
But first of all,
why she wearing makeup?
I she's fighting.
Yeah.
Well as well as was a commercial I scare of both models and that was a
commercial engineer.
That commercial,
they show some sort of Santa Monica lab,
say bunch of Melvin millennials that have a hard time putting their backpack in
the overhead compartment.
I thought that was,
that was surveillance gyms around.
Yeah.
See,
shut your fucking mouth.
Look at,
that's what I'm talking about.
That kind of body flush.
Jesus dude.
Hey,
I can't watch this.
I'm going to pass out.
They keep this going Jamie.
But then she could fight too.
I mean,
I don't want to be disrespect.
She can fight.
She's legit.
She's gorgeous.
Yeah.
And you know by all accounts,
very nice person.
So there's a lot of pretty girls back then.
There's
a lot of pretty girls that are finding their way into the UFC and they find that
like that's an asset.
You know what's really interesting to me from one of the best looking ones of
all puts zero emphasis on that.
And that's rose.
Nama Eunice.
I know rose is of course she's gorgeous.
She's pretty,
she's pretty.
And she puts no emphasis on that.
Shaves her fucking head.
I know.
There's nothing fake about that.
She's just,
there's nothing fake about that girl.
Yeah,
we met her,
I think our,
at least I did.
You'd known her before I met her.
I think that thing we did,
was it a spike thing?
I remember UFC thing.
It was at and she was in a dress shoes.
The Pat Barry.
Yeah.
And she,
but she had long hair back then.
I mean she was stunning,
like astonishing looking and I didn't know she was at the time.
And uh,
I mean,
so she,
yeah,
she's,
if she walked into a bar back then like that even now,
but I mean back then you would have been like,
I mean,
she turns out as a supermodel failure.
She really doesn't,
she doesn't,
she's a model and she doesn't put any emphasis on that at all.
All of our emphasis is on our fighting and zero trash-talking.
When she shaved her head,
the fight,
she stated her head when she was fighting Paige vanzant.
She went,
oh,
you're things beauty.
She's like,
my hair was just getting in the way.
Fuck it.
Then beat the brakes off of.
Yeah,
that's what she needs to look like.
She's tough.
Like that's like workout here.
She looks better with her head.
Shaved I
corner with the right red shirt on there.
Jamie upper right hand corner right there.
I mean shut the fuck up.
That's a beautiful girl.
That's a model that is about as hot is a woman's face gets w contract for God's
sake.
Meanwhile,
how the fuck did no one see her coming hot mean it's,
it's kinda crazy how because she was so feminine.
I think she doesn't like her body.
No.
Let me think about how much emphasis they put on promoting Paige vanzant how
much emphasis they put on a lot of other girls that are really pretty too,
but that's,
that's a marketing thing.
Look,
you got to look at like what this company is now.
Right?
This company started off a passion project by two fucking crazy billionaire
dudes.
Well,
first of all,
Horian Gracie,
right?
Art Davies,
the original guys,
uh,
you know Meyrowitz those guys who started it off,
they get it going.
Then they sell it as a passion project to,
to Super Billionaires who love the sport,
who train.
They were fucking like happy as pie and they're like,
wait,
we own the UFC.
Dana talked him into it.
Yeah,
didn't talk to me.
They're having a good old time.
They literally were what me and Eddie Bravo used to pray for.
We s when we were watching the fights back when nobody gave a shit about the UFC
thing we always said was,
wouldn't it be amazing if some billionaires just through a shitload of money at
it and made it famous?
Like we know it's an an incredible sport to watch.
We know how exciting it is.
Wouldn't it be great if someone had just publicize this thing and then the
Fertittas come along literally like they just,
they figured it out themselves.
They're like,
this thing is like,
we just need to spend money.
They spent,
they were $40 million in the hole when the first ultimate fighter was Erin.
Oh.
So they put that much money into it,
produce the ultimate fighter.
Lorenzo's a genius.
And then the show takes off the shot.
And this is by the way,
after they had called Dana White and told him to bail,
they like sell this thing,
we're losing too much money.
We were,
you know,
x amount of millions of dollars in the hole.
I'm not going to lose my family's business all because of this one project that
we have.
Fuck this.
And then he calls him up the next day and he goes,
I changed from,
he slept on it because he's a fucking genius I think.
I think Lorenzo's the most,
you know,
there's one a one B,
but he's right up there as most important people and he's so calm history.
He was the,
he was an important like balancing act to Dana Dana.
So volatile and crazy emotional guy and he's a faggot and this and all the
craziness of the day.
And especially in the early days used to be.
And then he goes from that to super calm,
really reasonable,
incredibly articulate,
like laid back Lorenzo,
I think.
I think he's missed now.
Now.
Now that things are going on.
Like you would never seen the Floyd Mayweather,
Conor fight if Lorenza was there because he that he would've never let that
happen.
He really wasn't into that stuff.
He really wasn't man.
Oh,
you're crazy.
I don't think I like,
he didn't like spectacle.
No,
but why would you pass on that thing?
I wanted to see that.
Didn't you want to see that?
Cellie?
I wanted to see it.
But Lorenzo I think looked at the bigger picture because I think now that we
look back on Floyd and and Connor and then where the UFC at now,
I don't know if was the best decision.
It's a great decision.
I think it was an amazing decision.
First of all,
it's an amazing decision for the overall evolution of combat sports.
It's incredibly important.
No chance.
It's incredibly important to realize that a real specialist like Floyd
Mayweather will run circles around someone who does not have the same amount of
time and knowledge.
Like Connor has great punching power,
he's got great speed.
But as far as his like boxing acumen to compare the two of them the greatest of
all time,
arguably no,
there's no,
there's no event.
Please caveat that with the fact that Floyd Mayweather didn't even fight him the
way he fights other guys.
If you'd want it not to be touched,
he could have done that.
You disagree with that towards some made him work hard and I don't think it wore
him out.
And that's great.
And those are great points.
But I think if you look at the lay of the lay of the land now,
Lorenza wouldn't have done it because now you have two divisions held up.
You have Connor with all this power.
We have no idea what he's going to fight.
He didn't ever have to fight again.
So he missed out on Connor.
If you want to sell the TV deals,
you can't guarantee Connor's gonna fight.
That's why Lorenza and is a thing there.
Go ahead.
Also also now we're in the era of the money fight where everyone wants the money
for rankings.
Don't matter.
Divisions don't matter.
Titles don't matter,
so we've lost all that kind of the,
the the fundamental that we've laid out.
No title shots and all.
I disagree.
I think now everyone wants to famous fight.
I'll do want the famous fighters.
Here's the money.
Hold on a second.
This is not,
we haven't lost all the rankings.
We just lost a ranking sometimes.
Sometimes they don't matter.
Listen,
this is a lot of it is because the $4 billion price tag of that company,
that's a big part of it.
Well a lot of us cause the fighters,
I don't want your money because the people that own the fight,
the,
the company now or an entertainment business were like,
where's the money?
The money's in these big spectacle things.
That's where the money is.
We're here to make some money.
We're here to put on great fights.
Like,
you can't tell me that fucking Detroit card was one of the wildest fight cards
you've ever seen in your life and put it on,
put on great fucking fights.
They're putting on great cards.
And on top of that,
they're also having chaos.
They're having Conor McGregor box,
Floyd Mayweather.
But I think for the evolution of combat sports,
that fight is important.
How do they,
I don't think it lended itself to the evolution of combat sports in that there
was such different sports so that I,
I think everybody would knew that ultimately we need to see it.
Yes.
Like James,
Tony [inaudible],
Tony or Randy couture fight is not fair because James Tony halfassed that he
barely trained,
he didn't train any grappling.
We saw him doing his training with some karate guy and he was like,
we did this stuff to,
even with the milky.
Yeah.
But,
but here's the thing with James Tony did was try to just go in there and get
paid.
He got taken down with a low ankle pick.
He got to completely smashed by.
Really built as a temp.
I agree.
He's out of shape.
He was.
He's way past prime where theirs is fucking prime.
Even though he's 40 he's still so good.
His prime,
he's lost a step.
You can't say he's lost a step.
You look at him against me.
Tell me a 26 year old Floyd mailing eats that up cut coming landed on him.
If he fought that way it's a pen.
If you tried to just walk towards him like he had nothing he did,
he stood in his garage,
kind of cracked him with that one shot and I think Floyd was like,
oh okay,
okay,
you can hit me.
He's like,
we had to get going on.
Well let me,
let me just start ramping this bitch up to nine quizzing you a little bit.
I think you in May whether on Conor McGregor stuff more than anyone and I love
it cause comedy got paid.
I'm saying Lorenza from a business aspect is going,
if we give all this guy the fucking power now the ball's in his court,
man,
that's,
that's not what we're about.
That's what my thoughts and now everyone else's fault,
you get a superstar.
The only way you get a sugar ray Leonard,
uh,
Muhammad Ali don't dose th th th the cult of personality that comes around those
people,
they do have all the power.
There's no getting away.
They do.
You can't,
you can't stop that as a promotional organization.
You have to somehow or another ride with the wave and make some sort of cohesive
way,
may also want to be checked.
Got To make some side of agreement with that person.
Yeah,
I made it with Brock Lesnar.
They may deal with Ronda Rousey,
the other really the only other two superstars.
But they did it.
They didn't last because when see what keeps him,
uh,
a champion relevant and,
and in the lure is,
is the guy who keeps answering the call.
And,
and Connor did that in two different weight classes.
I mean I,
you know,
he,
he beat the impossible to be and then people,
cause he hasn't defended a bite and what he's done is that,
that's what I'm saying.
That's why I agree with your point about the evolution of the combat.
What it's done now is put so much power in his hands.
He's a,
he's got $100 million,
whatever.
It happens to me too,
cause I liked the guy,
but at the same time like it's,
you're not going to see him.
You're not going to see him fight d these monsters like Tony [inaudible] Tony
this year.
Why would you say that he,
first of all,
I don't like anybody saying this guy's not going to do this or he's not going to
do that because we really don't know.
But why wouldn't he fight Tony Ferguson if he wants to fight a guy?
I haven't seen him even training.
I don't know.
Straight nonstop.
Do you fall on its wrong Brian now,
but you're going to fight.
He hasn't come to my house.
She hasn't been training in Santa Monica and that's the right way.
Where are you going to sand tray?
What I'm saying is I didn't mentioned fighting
each other back and fight back and forth.
She goes,
Hey,
are you going to box pack yet?
He goes,
no,
my next fight is mixed martial arts.
I'm going to find inside that octagon.
Yeah.
He said to my next one is going to be a real fight.
Nobody's going to fight 20 freaks and that Tony freaks and fight.
When I,
when I look at it more and more,
I watch footage.
I think it's,
it's not that bad of a matchup or Carla used to be like,
God,
that's a tough fight.
But I think early on,
especially early rounds,
one through three with Connors accuracy and the,
and the way Tony gets hit,
it's a good fight for cares to past the third round.
It could get to parts of problem.
One Tony Finishes motherfuckers off his back.
He is nasty off his back if he can come down.
Yeah.
If he gets taken down,
it doesn't mean I'm saying if he gets hit,
if he gets hit like Nate Diaz does and goes down like Connor is not,
it's not like 100% that he's going to beat him up and ground and pound them.
Tony,
if he gets dropped,
we'll wrap you up like a fucking mummy and submit you.
So we can do though.
And Connor,
does it entertain that?
Maybe Nate?
Eh,
you know what?
I'm saying like you don't,
and they certainly can.
The difference is the differences.
If Tony Goes,
you know what?
I know you're fast apart from these first three rounds.
I,
I'm a college collegiate wrestler.
Fuck this noise.
I'm just going to ankle pick you all fucking day.
It's true.
Then third,
fourth,
fifth,
I'm start striking with you,
but Connor could catch him wet laundry.
It's a good fight.
Ridiculous speed.
Tony doesn't get tired.
I haven't seen him get tired.
He's tired.
He doesn't show it cause he's a fucking serial killer.
Oh yeah.
He is less tired than the other guy.
Your Mama,
she gets tired.
Brian last time.
Everybody gets tired and it's just here for it.
But,
but it is.
But he also is ridiculous conditioning.
You Know Amy Bravo was his fucking Jujitsu trainer and Eddie said he's never
seen anything like this guy.
He said the guy who trains for six hours a day,
the cities,
he's in big Barry's running hills,
literally lapping his training partners.
I turned around and go back and run a trail,
run up to the top of that.
That is such an advantage.
And a five round fight.
I mean,
such an advantage and a three round fight.
his ability to just not like when you're less tired than the other guy.
Oh my God.
Those camps are big bear.
He goes,
he rents a house.
He builds his own fucking training facility.
He sets up his own heavy bags.
He mats up floors,
he takes a fucking room.
He's got like a living room,
but house.
He sets down the borders,
brings in the mats and they start training.
He refines of hills,
runs those fucking hills at 6,000 feet out to
50 fives no punk men.
He's not asked Eddie Alvarez who we can now,
he's a fucking punk.
Not to say like at first I was like,
God,
this is getting kind of the way I look at him.
Like,
you know,
he does get hit first and gets hit man.
Yeah.
The problem child is Khabib,
Khabib [inaudible].
It's almost a round table because it could be verse Tony.
Hello.
A fight could,
could be versus Connor.
God,
that's tough fight for Conor,
but they can eliminate each other.
It's whoever shows up that night.
It's a fucking good fight,
man.
Takes your legs down.
We're going to know all about,
could be this weekend when he fights Edson Barboza.
We're going to see him with arguably the fastest tracker and 155 pounds.
It doesn't give a fuck about going the ground.
He's like,
no,
we're not going to ground.
I'm might be on a team that were other guys.
We'll play that game.
Right?
Anti wrestling will kick you in the fucking face.
Right,
but how do you keep them from taking you to the ground when he gets into my
work?
You avoid the clinch.
Yeah.
How do you avoid that?
With Khabib?
Hard.
That's fucking hard.
It's not,
it's not an easy fight.
Five stretch of the imagination,
but you've got to realize to be Michael Johnson.
Crack could be when they fought and had them wobbling.
It's the first time we've seen any adversity that could be you had to face
inside the octagon.
Buddy handled it with fucking four aces.
Took him to the ground.
He's got to show him.
I had no idea it could be one up to two oh five when he trains like well he gets
heavy,
he gets heavy in between five 29 due at this time.
Daniel Cormier I say as a new nutrition and he said he is been lighter getting
ready for this camp than any fight before.
He was 179 pounds.
Just a couple of weeks ago,
Josh Thompson was like,
Dude,
you've never seen anything like it cause I was talking about Connor and could
be,
and he's like,
dude,
I'm telling you man.
I seen him go with DC.
I've seem to all the guys and think about,
think about what he did.
Joe Angeles,
He bragged them [inaudible] 70 and I go,
why does it get beat?
Just go to set me up.
He sees what he's going to,
he's going to do is get the belt at 55 as soon as he get that he's going piece
and then at 70 enjoy that and enjoy that mother fucker at 70 it's like he gets
you and it breaks your legs down.
It's like,
oh,
you're a table.
I'm going to take your legs down now you're on the crown and that's it.
Well,
the leading buddy,
get them off all elite wrestlers.
Right?
Whether you're talking about Dave Schultz or whether you're talking about,
you know,
Carolyn,
all the best of the best wrestlers,
they have an ability to enforce their will,
power into God and do shit to them that they don't want don and break up.
They see it.
They were you like a technique with will,
with physical conditioning,
with everything.
Bdcs the same way.
All the best guys have everything.
They have all the components,
and that's one of the things.
Number Command off does.
Then you add the fact that he's from Dagestan.
You add the fact that he grew up in one of the hardest places in the fucking
world.
That's right.
And everyone around him as hard as nails,
where I think the national sport might be wrestling,
might be murder.
Yeah.
Get a varsity in murder in high school.
It's a crazy place,
which we discussed is him verse Barboza.
If it's like a video game,
you look at their attributes Barboza strikings like this,
but just wrestling's like,
yeah,
we like,
it could
be his wrestling's like this,
but striking.
So you're intrigued by this.
Fuck yeah.
Fuck is the most intriguing fight that it could be was ever fought by fog.
Never.
Two reasons.
One,
the two fights where he had so much difficulty making weight that his body was
shutting down.
It happened in the Michael Johnson fight.
Then it happened again.
The Toby,
Tony Ferguson.
Five th the point they pulled them off the car,
so they were saying his liver was shutting down like this is serious,
serious shit.
He has not made one 55 cents.
Right.
He hasn't fought since,
so there's so much pressure on him to do this correctly,
but who knows if he can.
When your body does not want to do that anymore,
you run into serious problems is one of the things that happens to older
athletes when they've been cutting extreme amounts of weight over and over
again.
They get to a point where their bodies take every time you cut 30 pounds of
water from your body,
your body goes into like a state of shock.
You do some damage.
The question is how much damage are you doing?
Think how long he's been doing it to Josh Johnson brought to that point.
He goes,
dude,
he's been cutting weight since he was a kid.
Like he's been in these wrestling terms,
the Samba terms since he was a kid.
So He's older now.
He's been cutting weight for a fucking f.
And here's a real question.
Here's a real question,
and fought for the title.
If he wins the title,
how the fuck is he going to defend it in California?
He's not going to,
wow.
Yeah,
because California has new strict laws.
Oh no,
he's not watching any foster.
The guy runs the California State Athletic Commission is one of the best guys in
the sport.
He's so proactive.
He's so ahead of it.
He's adding weight classes.
He's doing so much to make this safe.
And he was a,
he's a martial artist,
lifelong martial artist himself,
and he competed.
So here's a guy who sees what the problems are and he says,
okay,
we're going to make sure you don't weigh 15 pounds more when you get into the
octa the night of the fight.
Yeah.
The other percentage,
right.
Is it a percentage of weight that you can't gain?
No,
no,
it's,
it's a little mound sites,
I think at 55 can't come in and heavier than,
it's like 15.5 or something like that,
so like 70 which could be concurring bigger.
Bebes just going to get the top of them dip out public place in Tiba,
glycine,
Tiba would fight at 55 and he literally looked like he was 200 pounds in a
fight.
I heard,
I heard that Darren tell,
and I'm sure you'll hear this,
but I already,
when he stepped into the octagon against cowboy and he was 201 pounds.
Yes,
that's what I heard too.
Enjoy beating during tiller it.
Enjoy it.
No,
no one wants to fight him.
He suffered much warranty for,
he even said he fight.
My pay goes,
listen,
I don't give a fuck about rankings belt.
I'll fight right now.
He wants to put on a show,
he wants to light people on fire and no one wants to get in there with them.
They saw that cowboy fine.
They're like,
oh shoot.
Then you learn a story like,
oh my God,
he's a nightmare.
Wonderful,
wonderful.
It was like,
let's do this.
Then when the boys dad,
he was like,
no,
but Wonderboy did not say let's do that.
Let me be honest with you.
I wonder.
Boy had hurt.
Thumbs said.
He told me about in the ring after the fight,
his thumbs in the cage after the fight.
He said his thumbs pretty fucked up cause he was talking about it in between
rounds with its corner and I said,
what were you saying about your hands?
He goes,
yeah man,
I did something to my thumbs like I hit,
you know he's throwing these crazy fucking punches on a guy like Jorge Mas
withal who's no joke,
right?
Hell No.
He's catching elbows.
He's catching foreheads and he fucked
us thumbs up and he might need surgery like he doesn't know has no,
I don't know.
But for sure he was in a position where he had some serious injuries that they
were saying like we got in Dana white even tweeted it or something that we
didn't,
no days out the fight.
Right.
Yeah.
I even said thank you Jesus.
I screenshot it feeling like,
Holy Shit,
it's going down.
That's a great fight.
Great fight.
If it happened,
boy or boy who fought Errol Spence.
Um,
I was just with uh,
a fight to wildcard west.
Why am I forgetting I'm getting old?
Oh,
Chris,
Chris Mayer was showing me like,
he's a boxer quality box had been around forever and fought,
fought or I'll Spence but got beat.
But um,
you know,
a high level boxer and he was showing me,
he was just showing me,
like I said,
why is Errol Spence so good?
Because he,
I know he's great,
but he looks like basic,
like he does like jab one,
two and he,
so for my eye as not a very sophisticated guy,
I can't see what's making them so good.
Right,
right.
And he was showing me,
it was really a yesterday just showing me how,
like he was able to measure his jab.
So Chris would throw a jab and he goes,
Watch and I throw a jab and he goes and he would move back just like his ability
to move back just,
just enough.
So some guys move back just a little bit too much and then went back a little
bit and then they throw.
So their,
their measurement of distance is just a little off and you have time to
compensate his ability to move back the precise amount so that you don't have
time to react because he comes back,
boom,
it hits you again.
So every time you throw he would make it.
So his ability to sort of be just had a reach was better than anybody.
He had fought.
Well,
no one's better.
So that shit didn't Loma Chenko.
Correct.
But also to that point,
Billy Joe Saunders,
who was like,
what?
And then beat the brakes off of,
did you see Billy Joe Saunders?
He's amazing.
He might be able to be triple g.
He's ridiculous.
Fucking jabs were my thing of the past.
Right.
He would just plop that side in there,
pop and then it'd be left.
Right.
Do,
here we go.
This was a world title fight.
Hopefully if mrs was a huge,
uh,
swinging like right hand,
he goes like this into the stands.
Like he's no misses it.
Yeah.
On the brain's looks Billy Joe looks like as if who you're trying to hit is he
[inaudible] Saunders from Wales.
He said he's a gypsy gypsy,
but he's from,
he's from the last say Gypsy Trafford now traveler.
You gotta be careful.
[inaudible] I called a fury of Gypsy.
A legit like traveler came to the show and was like traveler,
quick Collins.
Gypsies.
Yeah.
They don't like gypsy,
but people say it all the time.
Sorry,
I keep saying it on HBO.
Meaning bad,
cisgender privilege piece of shit.
Fucking monster.
I hope fury comes back.
He's on my feet and stuff.
You don't know.
Look him up,
man.
He's doxing eats that guy.
David Lemieux fight on HBO was a Goddamn Work of art.
It was,
God didn't work.
And now his campaign for triple g and they they,
Billy Joe Saunders.
Lemieux I mean Billy Joe Saunders Verse Canelo,
he's so much bigger.
Canela there's no one wants to fight Billy Joe Saunders
right now.
But him trying to get them to your name.
Got To get a bigger names that Canelo money that they're fucking corona cash
dude.
He's going to get if triple g and Canela don't figure it out.
Billy Joe Saunders getting one of them.
I hope they have to change any brand.
Billy Joe Saunders hot.
I think people know who he is though.
You know who he is.
I know who he is and I think the world was introduced to them at that last HBO
card though.
But this is just a word I do because I saw him fight triple g fight in Montreal.
He's huge and they were fighting in Montreal.
That's true.
But see Billy Joe,
this is his first fight in America.
All of his fights had been in Europe.
Yeah.
So this is like,
but he's been watched a lot because he's so his flashy,
like as neat as neat kind of like really.
Well,
he says,
Christ,
he's smart.
He has a mouth on him and you know what,
I'm the guy you can root for Jim Lampley and Roy Jones Jr had a little
disagreement and the commentary,
oh Jim Lampley was like,
well,
if he's this far ahead,
why does he not trying to knock them out?
Roy Jones was like,
why would he do you see what he's doing?
He's,
he's boxed in his face off.
He's like,
well you have the added humiliation that you do to your opponent when you knock
them out.
Like stay in your Lane Jim lamp.
Stand in your fucking fuck.
It was embarrassing.
So you just said that to Roy Jones Jr you're talking about one of the greatest
knockout artists in the history of the fucking sport was telling him why someone
should,
you don't just knock someone out.
You have to put yourself in danger to knock someone out and you could wind up
losing against the fucking power puncher like Limu,
your life and box and you lose that fight.
Everything shot,
the Canelo,
triple g fights,
gone fumes that place fighting a beautiful pattern for him to alter that pattern
to get a specific result that's not smart.
And it's not boxing.
That's not what you're supposed to do.
Silly.
Yeah.
Here's his highlight reel and you see,
see him move around him and he's so interesting with his right jab to he throws
punches and then he's like,
whoops,
not here anymore,
dude.
I got up to the Lemieux fight.
If you can get,
that was one of the best fights because Lemieux was a legit world contender.
But the class,
the thing with Billy Joe Saunders,
if his highlights,
they do them justice somewhat,
but he always steps up to the level of competition.
So you might watch them against a guy like,
hey,
it looks all right.
But then when he Chris Eubank Junior,
you look at him,
he gets Lemieux like holy fuck this guy's world plot.
Yeah.
Here's look Saunders against Eubanks jr he will fight to whoever is levels that.
That's why I think he,
and he's big too for the weight class.
So a triple g or Canelo you got to fight.
He's big and he's so fucking smart,
man,
that the big thing is how smart he is.
I mean,
his ring Iq and his ability to not get hit is so exceptional.
Steps just back and look how he changes it up.
She goes to the head,
he goes to the body,
he,
he's like,
he's an artist,
man,
a real artist.
It's really fun watching him.
Beautiful lefthand,
and he has a personality.
Funny Spanish shit talks,
mad shit.
He told Amelia some extra pants from his son.
They can work.
Just let me short.
Just kept talking shit.
And he's also best friends with fury still.
They're like perfect.
Baffin and rob and they're fucking man.
Yeah.
I was surprised that they referred to him as a gypsy on the HBO broadcast.
You're not supposed to think it was Jim Lampley to,
he's an older fellow.
I thought Gypsy is a cool word,
but I think so too.
If you go over to London,
they told me not to say that her Roma Roma is considered Roma is considered
derogatory.
Right.
So they were always just no aroma.
Donald Cerrone versus Yancey Madeiros UFC Austin.
That's a good one.
70 for Serone because Yancey is not a giant one 70 you know,
it's not like a,
that fight of the year.
Some people think that was a crazy fight against cowboy early vera whole
Austin Yancy.
Crazy.
What a fucking performance by Yancy February 18th.
That's close.
That's weird.
They announce it.
You really,
that's really close.
Real close for Yancey from that last fight.
The fight was a barn burner and that was only a month ago.
That's weird.
And not much time to promote either for Austin.
Yeah,
well I don't think you need it for cowboy in Austin.
That mother fucker will sell out quick and it's a fight night.
So it's not paper.
It's a good headline of,
for sure.
Great headline for fight night for Yancey mean he took a lot of hard shots and
that,
I don't know if that's given him enough time to recover.
It doesn't make a lot of sense,
but if you're a dancer,
you're jumping at the opportunity.
Oh,
you hear a fucking,
uh,
Jimmy Rivera's off with John Linacre.
Yeah.
Luna Lineker got hurt.
And then do you see,
uh,
Jimmy Rivera,
who to me is my dark horse and that division man fucking monster.
And then,
uh,
he was kind of,
he's trying to get Murrayas right?
He goes,
you,
if you'd even,
you said you do that five pounds to give you five pounds,
it's team said no.
I said No.
And then he goes,
I'll give you 10 pounds.
I just want to fight.
It might not be in,
she still went know Marlin might not be in shape.
He can add them in jail.
Let's fucking do it.
Well,
Martin just really recently,
spectacular knockouts didn't get touched against aljamain sterling.
And he's,
you know,
he's in that position where he's climbing the ladder to and to take a short
notice fight mark.
Henry's very wise in that regard.
And they're like,
look,
you talk to any coaches in the world.
I agree.
You can beat this guy,
but do you beat this guy this way?
Maybe,
but do you beat this guy when you have a long training camp?
Much better odds,
and that's the way to do it.
To really show who you really are.
I agree 100% I wouldn't have done it if,
if I'm mark or I'm telling my fight or not to do.
It's a pro sport,
man.
It's a pro sport.
You have to weigh these short term opportunities like Michael Bisping got when
the,
when he stepped up to fight Luke Rockhold.
You've got to weigh those.
Yeah,
look,
Bisping it fucking paid off and it paid off in spades,
right?
He chaos.
Rockhold it becomes a middleweight champion.
The worlds of fills a lifetime dream all on 11 days.
Notice to the fucking man has cast iron bowling balls hanging from his dick like
you can't.
He's the best deny that about my thing.
Then,
but then the same thing,
that same mentality as to bites him in the ass and he goes and fights Calvin
gassed alum just a few days after fighting a fucking crazy.
You fight with George Saint Pierre and he doesn't look good.
He looked horrible.
Then look at Machida.
He just got starched and now he's headlining and where the fuck they're did
Gagas Stan or starts,
you've got starts and then any tested positive blue Machida's last fight.
Machida tested positive for his last,
his last fight Machita Machita was suspended for something for Derek Brunson.
Yeah.
Before then he had two years off and then he finds two off I think.
Pretty sure two years crazy.
They fight.
Derek Brunson got starched,
right.
And then like,
hey,
we need a main event for where the fuck it is polling or whatever.
And then he originally said no.
And then I heard he was talked into it.
And then who's he fighting?
A Cheetah.
Um,
uh,
God.
Who's he fighting?
Jamie cannot be fast enough here.
There's no way he could do both things.
We need to hire another dude.
Come on man.
These to,
while he's doing that,
he make the fastest one hand a typer in the world.
He's pretty good.
On one hand working on the fucking Tri Caster,
one hand work in the team.
He was a high school basketball player.
PRY would've gotten t two t three.
It's Anders.
What Anders?
That sound right.
You want to see something disturbing?
There's a,
this evidence of Jamie's basketball playing online.
Uh,
Anders.
Who's Anders?
Which Anders sounds sounds church.
The gentleman's name.
Eric.
Eric Anderson to Brazil.
But he's just got starched and they say this one.
Well he could sell a lot of tickets in Brazil.
No,
I get that.
I get all of this.
Got legitimate three point skills.
I watched your a that video of you just hitting threes.
Jamie's man,
he didn't need to watch this after this.
I was like,
hmm,
Jamie,
my pen,
the spectrum watching this.
I was watching.
I'm like,
he might be like,
Oh rain man with this.
It was so impressed.
I was like come and be like in a hypnotic state.
He's been using the zone.
It's called the zone.
Yeah Dude.
Let's call it the zone.
The zone we are talking about.
You could get Jamie to do that all day.
Well you have so much room.
Let's put up a basketball court half.
That's not really from me,
his whole,
but watch these shots.
Seriously Swish.
I gotta Watch it here.
Comes into the ball.
Watch this.
There it is.
Look like a young Jj Redick so do understand how hard this is to do for a guy
who is a essentially we one mess one just a slight mess.
Look at that Swish.
I mean get the fuck Outta here.
Jamie.
Are you read a rain man?
How are you able to do this and plan is holding this but seriously tag rain
drops and drops as white chocolate.
Hashtag various uh,
that is hilarious.
Jamie's got lit real scale.
Well that those guys that are like super calm and measured and level,
we're always a scary as guys that play pool with because guys like Jamie were
always the guys that liked,
they didn't get too hard and they didn't get low.
They just like they,
and then they figured out how to get into that zone and they'd be tariffs on.
Yeah,
I bet he's not.
I mean I saw that the three points,
those shoots,
the shots you're making.
I was like,
okay,
Jamie's got that weird year.
I got that weird mental gear.
You get a click the taps into the zone.
Who I did a movie with,
a guy like Josh,
the pool player.
We met,
um,
the girl,
the Belo toward the Texas Tornado by you getting Villareal.
Yeah,
she's bad ass.
She's a bad ass.
She's bad ass pool player.
She'll make you feel very uncomfortable with your manhood.
But something about losing to a chicken pool.
Really embed some about it,
man pools a man's game.
Oh Man.
Fuck in pool.
Really?
Say that.
But if you can
give you,
because it's about four,
it's,
this is what it's about.
It's about keeping your nerves together under pressure.
So when a woman is better keeping her nerves gather under pressure and guys
bobble shots and miss nine balls and you're like [inaudible] some people,
they're just built for games.
Like I did a movie with the guy who was just like,
he'd play,
I played chess with him and he was,
I used to play with my dad is,
and he's beating me so quickly and I was like,
what are you,
why are you so good?
He goes,
oh,
just,
you know,
I'm just playing.
I go,
all right,
I'll have you read books on chess.
He goes,
of course I went,
oh well it's his thing
and I played pool.
He beat everybody at pulled.
Then we play paint might be everything.
There's some things in the game guys.
Guys just good at everything he's,
he's got,
he's got game theory like he noticed what Mack Ping Pong.
I pride myself on my pink button.
I'm not good but I think I am and I'll talk a big game.
He noticed that my fucking that my backhand over here,
it's a little suspect.
So of course he just saw whole,
am I getting those people that can see a hole there strategically?
Sounds like you played Rozzie k fucking hole in his game,
but that get that.
I was like this play a lot of games.
Does he yell it?
If I saw a whole new game,
I'm not going to do that cause I want to play the game.
What we had laid makes the voice of our,
hold on,
wait a minute.
You wouldn't try to win.
I don't know.
Depending on,
I don't give a fuck about winning.
I don't give a fuck about beating you.
Find out the guys get a shitty half guard.
You tell him you don't go towards his half guard all the time when I street
fight.
Yes.
Honestly,
when I straight out,
I'm not going into his half guts.
Piss on your hips.
At least limit,
bring it out.
Let me go.
And I taught street fight and might come back.
Stay out of your medium sized street fighting.
When I come back,
don't fucking shut the fuck.
Don't talk about street fighting with me,
dude.
I take it very serious.
So Watson with Wayne and your friends and then when I come back,
shut the fucking,
I'm a boxer and I,
and I rethink,
you get hit too much in the head.
As an older guy who does power lifting,
did you see that new thing where they said that they train AI to play chess?
There's a new AI program and um,
not only did it beat some world chess master,
I just,
I just tweeted it,
see if you could pull that shit up.
But uh,
by the way,
it is from the Daily Mail,
which you got to go.
Hmm.
There might be exaggerating a little bit.
Yeah.
But it said that the,
that this chess computer had invented a series of moves that no one had ever
seen before.
So it's scary.
It's being creative.
It did a move.
It did like a pattern that no one had seen before.
So it's figuring out how to play on the job.
This is whole movement out.
People are writing books on my,
on how to deal with the second smart machine agent in four hours.
A robot taught itself chest and beat a grand master with moves.
Never devised the games.
1500 year history.
And the implications are terrifying.
Yeah,
for sure.
And so what that the more terrifying thing besides is the fact that massive,
massive sections of our job markets are going away.
Yeah.
Look at what a,
what do we do?
Oxford academic AI could go rogue and become too complex for engineers.
Oh my God.
That is it.
Hey,
what are your thoughts on net neutrality?
Because I would talking to people online today about net neutrality.
Yeah.
I posted something about it that it seems to me to be one of those ideological
camp issues where if you are leaning right,
you think that net neutrality is a bad thing that the market should decide.
If you're leaning left,
you think that there's some regulation that the government should step in and be
important because you want to keep people from information.
You don't want to a big corporation to be able to step in and say someone can or
can't,
uh,
have their program on 18 t or Verizon or,
I think that from what I've read,
there are six major service providers.
Maybe,
maybe a couple more that that already smelled a little bit like a monopoly,
but what I think is that if you,
first of all,
nobody really knows yet,
but I think that the bigger issue becomes if these companies provide you service
in your area,
they could decide to break it into say to bandwidth,
say could decide you want regular,
you want regular service or do you want premium?
If you want premium,
we're going to pay a little more good.
That's one thing.
They could bring it up.
If that's the case,
we'll let the market decide.
Maybe that maybe that creates an opening for another service provider to come in
and say,
we don't do that one price covers everything.
It's one of the guys on my Instagram or my Twitter rather had a really good
point.
He said the real issue that people aren't talking about is the monopolies that
these companies have in small areas.
Yes.
Like if you're in a certain town,
like you can only get this kind of company or you know,
Verizon or,
that's what I'm saying,
when you have a company that owns a certain town and then you know,
in certain areas is the only way you can get coverage.
Do you have to do with this one company,
then then it becomes a real issue.
And not only does it become an issue,
but the other issue is that now the real question is if you are a service
provider and you provide,
uh,
people in this area,
that service,
if the other service has,
if you use platforms that the other service provides and they compete directly
with this,
with this service block that would this service have an incentive to,
uh,
slow block your access to it or whatever.
And that would be an issue.
But my feeling is that we'll find out very quickly and as long as consumers have
the ability to go over to another provider,
as long as consumers have the ability to go,
I don't like the way you do business,
I want,
but they don't got a lot of areas becomes the
terrorists have a license,
they have a license and a certain,
yeah.
Certain district consumer backlash is how you fight that.
If there's enough consumer backlash and people go,
are you just keep the net neutrality in place and prevent it,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
it's just I'm going to have some experts on to talk about it soon in the future.
I'm going over all the data and information,
but I just wanted to get people's temperature and it's so funny how people,
uh,
get so aggressive and shitty with you when you just talk about this issue
because a few people that have had a mute,
I was like,
good luck dude.
Your opinion means shit to me because you just have to be insulting when
someone's just asking a question.
Right.
You know this,
this whole thing is interesting because there's smart people on both sides of it
and they have compelling arguments on both sides of it and I don't,
I don't have an opinion 100% I leaned more towards Paul.
A lot of people don't yet know how this this is going to play out because you
know,
you may say though,
you lean towards what I lean towards the idea that you have to have some
oversight,
that you have to have someone who's looking out who makes sure that these
companies can't fuck you over and can't prevent you from having access to
certain information.
Certain sites I lean towards that most.
But the answer that,
the other question is though that does the market decide that was going to say
the other oversight could be,
I always leaned toward the idea that the marketplace would be your oversight.
Let people make their choice,
but they have to have a choice.
Unless you were talking about there are very few service providers might.
My question is,
is there incentive for other people to come into the service providing space?
Can they make money?
Uh,
what are the barriers to entry and as far as the right.
And secondly,
secondly,
um,
is it in these service providers interest ultimately to make extra cash for such
bad press?
I,
you may see nothing happened as a result,
but I liked the idea that the marketplace that,
that consumers have a choice and when consumers have a choice,
they're going to go with what works the best for group B.
I do too.
But I do believe that it's entirely possible that large corporations could have
monopoly real influence over the way our culture has access to information.
I think I agree that should be stopped.
But I also think that these fucking government organizations almost all suck.
They're all filled with unmotivated people who suck at their job and the
bureaucracy and the fucking red tape gets deeper and thicker.
I think almost every government organization that does any task is flawed.
And so the idea that we should have government take care of these issues.
I have a problem with that too.
Missy both sides of it.
I see this side too.
There's another dark side of the marketplace though I,
you know,
I think the news nowadays,
makes a lot of money on clickbait and,
and so you,
you now have companies,
whether it's the Huffington Post or CNN or whatever who are less interested,
it seems,
and objective reporting of the news and way more interested in generating
clicks.
Did you seal fucking Newsweek,
title the,
that they put out about Trump and the Nazis like stealing Christmas?
Did you see that?
There you go.
That's a classic.
See if you can find it.
What is that?
I'm already intrigued.
You know the news,
the world is such a polygamy infotainment,
right?
That's a tragedy.
Newsweek,
which will,
you would always say they have to compete.
There are met.
They have to compete.
That's what it is.
You have to can be,
but you'd always think they're measured.
They're intelligent.
This is Newsweek disrespected when,
when Chris Rock the DEP,
when Chris was working on a bit how Trump and the Nazi stole Christmas to
promote white nationalism.
Hey,
fucking slow down.
Yeah.
This is just his hair.
You're going to get Caitlyn Jenner elected president.
If you keep this shit up.
Exactly.
Like you have to understand what's happening here.
People are gonna go nuts.
The media's disapproval rating the opposite according to some halls,
the media,
his approval rating is in the single digits and I think they deserve it.
I really do.
I um,
am not nearly as cynical as a lot of people,
but as I get older and I see how her responsible,
a lot of the news is how much money there is to be made by just,
just hinting or sort of,
you know,
associating somebodies name with something kind of volatile short
story.
A lot of their environment,
like they're dealing with what gets a response.
And when it gets clicks,
so all good questions.
Societies are the ones who are telling them to do this.
They're not just making this shit up.
That's right.
They're like,
well,
if we,
if we say Trump,
the Nazi stole Christmas,
how many clicks are we going to get?
See,
but this is what they're doing is they're being more exclusive.
Hold on.
They're being disingenuous here in this article.
Scroll up a little bit because here's one of the things it says.
It says,
Donald Trump wants America to thank,
he reinvented Christmas.
We can say merry Christmas again.
He has said on numerous occasions,
both during the campaign and president and presidency,
Christmases back better than ever before.
He told supporters month before the Christmas season,
fuck he is doing what a guy who's very persuasive does to try to get people in
his camp.
He's a falcon.
Politicians got a sense of humor,
but it's not even true.
But the what,
what,
what he's doing here is not even true because he in the past did a lot of tweets
about happy holidays.
Happy.
I like people pulled them up that he used to say happy holidays all the time,
like really recently was tweeting happy holidays and then the idea that Obama
never said merry Christmas is 100% horseshit.
There's a whole video of Obama saying merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas is over and over again.
Nothing wrong with it.
This idea is he's trying to sell people on the idea that you will,
your Christian values have been suppressed by this mediocre left wing government
and he stepping in here to make America great again.
It's all a hustle,
but it's not white nationalists and Nazis like you can't say Nazis.
The problem is when you say that you leave the word Nazi loses its fucking
meaning.
Yeah.
They're irresponsible journalists.
They're not journalists.
They're irresponsible.
Yeah.
What he's doing is he's being a fucking politician.
He's being a weasel.
He's trying to pretend that Christmas was never,
we never,
we never had Christmas before.
We're going to have Christmas now and all the dopes,
all the yokels,
but
you know,
this guy's out there with make America great again.
Tattoos.
You just understand this.
This is real.
Like there's people with its red hat,
tattoos that say make America great again on there's dummies in every fucking
quadrant in this earth.
But do you know,
I have to say that the,
the mainstream media,
and I'm,
I know I had never been a fan of Trump,
but the way they treat him with this kind of stuff that I constantly hear this
petty shit.
The way it drinks water and stuff.
It's made me funny.
That made me more sympathetic.
When you drink water,
drink water like this.
I got a strange guy,
12 guys.
It's fucking,
when you drink 12 diet cokes might be true or I don't believe it.
You know,
I don't know what to believe anymore.
That's the other problem.
There's another bunch of it cause he quotes a series of quotes from him from
back in the day saying,
why would you drink that coke to drink diet coke?
People drink diet coke or all saw fat diet coke makes you fat.
It's been proven.
There's a whole series of tweets.
Like he might've just forgot he made those tweets while he strapped.
Just doesn't give a fuck in great shape.
Yeah.
But I think that,
you know,
first of all,
he as a president,
here's a weird one,
there was a terror attack that was thwarted by the FBI in San Francisco.
You didn't hear a Goddamn peep about it because he's against the FBI because of
this,
all this investigation shit.
So the president in the United States didn't,
it didn't like congratulate the FBI,
didn't tell the American people that the FBI had done a great job.
I know,
I know about the terrorist attack.
I read boarded a legitimate terrorists attacked and this is all this whole make
America great again.
Stuff,
right?
You want to stop the terrorists.
He is a political point.
He avoided this terrible and he arrests man suspected applauding isis inspired
Christmas terror attack in San Francisco and everyone at times it was a marine
who would,
you know,
started going crazy.
Yeah.
Well it's just very handy.
It's very crazy arguments.
And how about he started,
they give,
they come,
he started to like,
like isis posts on Facebook and then he reached out to isis and went,
hey,
look in to complete this mission.
How do I get ahold of the guns and bullets?
Nicest like homeboy,
if you have to ask for the gear,
might not be for you.
Like what the fuck?
They're dumb.
Meet us on the dock where the asshole get out of here,
man.
Lag on your truck as you pull up.
Make it super obvious.
Every time.
I've been pier 39 and I've been there every time I go to San Francisco,
I always think that I'm always like,
I don't think like that.
A lot of people though in making this comment on why did the president not
discuss this like,
well this is something that like when you address the nation,
you have to talk about it.
And even if he's in some sort of a squabble with one aspect of the FBI,
you have to recognize that they did their job here.
This is why they're great job.
Yeah,
and this is why they're important.
Like the literally protected American lives and he's not mentioning it bullshit
that they do when they're saying things like
how Trump stole Christmas with white nationalists and Nazis,
that petty,
that kind of petty shit and forces his petty.
Yup.
It's in a way of real news.
[inaudible] and they go at it.
They go at each other back and forth and nothing gets done.
So in these to grow the fuck up and it should be the president,
but he woos weak.
She needs to grow the fuck up too.
You can't say things like that.
That's silly.
We should be able to rely on the mainstream news,
and I know I'm going to get a lot emails about the main Eddie Bravo who's
calling you right now,
but we should be a little,
we should rely on them to at least report the facts,
at least objective facts.
That was the whole point of journalism.
They were the fourth estate they keep,
they keep power in line,
they hold,
they speak truth to power.
That's the whole idea.
In a democracy,
you need a free press,
you need,
but now with money ratings,
it has corrupted.
While there's also many grants,
the the fucking Internet man,
the Internet came along and pretty much anybody can be a new source now.
Anybody can be a Hashtag.
Journalists,
there's a lot of fluctuation the game up,
you know,
change the game up.
Credentials to get,
well,
I spread rumors.
A PDF pages.
I was saying this the other day,
I was trying to remember writing something about this,
but like the idea that you in social media,
if you,
we all have moments where we do some crazy shit where we say stuff out loud
that's like politically incorrect and we say,
well,
we just behave in a way that could make you crazy,
right?
Yeah.
Like my dog ran into my knee the other day.
I was like,
ah,
fuck it hurt.
And I instinctively kicked out of,
I'm like,
I was just like fucking and I kick and I missed her.
But dude,
it looked like I tried to kick my fucking dog and the ribs because by the way,
in that mid split second I was trying to kick my dog who I love very much in the
restaurant.
She hit my knee was like,
ah,
my actions.
Anything wrong with giving your dog a little knee taps?
Correct.
If somebody caught that on camera,
so I'm a little shove,
somebody caught that on camera.
Now on a dog in the ribs,
this,
I'm just saying somebody it caught on the camera,
it would have been Brian count and if I was,
if I was famous,
they'd be like,
say I was a politician or whatever.
I'm fun.
I'm done.
I'm the dog cat.
True,
right.
That's a comedic example.
Shit.
Yeah,
but I'm saying that nowadays,
and I was thinking about this nowadays,
anything that you do,
if you're having a moment,
if you're having a moan or you make a mistake,
describe a moment.
Dopey.
I thought he got to be careful with,
oh,
I'll tell you,
you're making a mistake.
I don't know.
It could be,
give me an example.
It could be you got caught at a strip club you were making out with a girl
behind a dumpster,
but you're married,
whatever it might be.
There are a lot of examples where everybody's fuckups like my buddy,
my buddy saying like Kevin Hart situation,
it's fine.
Hold on.
Well,
my,
my buddy,
my buddy who owns buildings,
he gets sued all the time.
And what he does is he'll just hire a private investigator and he h he just
follows the dude and he'll just follow the poor over sooner.
Yeah.
And,
and I go,
why did he do that?
He goes,
well,
because everybody he's ever followed,
he goes,
everybody is always fucking up in one aspect of their life.
Well,
especially someone with sleazy who tries these like illegitimate lawsuits.
Yes.
He always finds
evidence that they're just,
they're doing something.
I got a girlfriend,
I've got a boyfriend.
What?
It's always something,
right?
You're fine.
So let's say in a hypothetical situation,
you were cheating on ref came out.
Here's the larger fine.
The larger point is this.
I was thinking about like how I was taking Gandhi,
Martin Luther King,
Hemingway,
Picasso and Einstein,
all dirt bags,
all known,
known,
philanderers known to cheat on their wives just known there.
They're poor.
Well,
I mean,
and just real real ladies,
men and and beyond.
Well,
how about Kennedy?
Uh,
you know,
everybody wants to keep talking about how Bill Clinton got caught with Monica
Lewinsky to,
there was a woman who came out,
it was like one of the aides and the White House who's,
she was abused.
She was 19 can be made her suck his Dick sucker from gay.
Fuck everybody.
And so what I'm saying is that in the day,
in the days of social media now we would have dilated on that and we haven't
looked at that.
He couldn't have acted like that.
What we want to focus on,
because with those men,
let's just take those men,
they could have been discredited and cut out at the knees depending on when
that,
that activity was exposed.
Okay,
man,
he's talking about technology could have undermined everything they're working,
but hold on.
Isn't it possible that we need to have a more realistic understanding of what a
human being?
Yes.
And then seeing all these flaws in a person and then getting past that is maybe
the way to go the way the Europeans do.
But our problem is that we're dealing with this old model where everybody was
like some fucking Cary grant dude in a movie.
And w you know,
the good guys wore white hats.
The bad guys wear black hats.
And it's not realistic.
It's not realistic.
That's not Merrill came with our products,
but isn't it?
Isn't it an American?
Because it hasn't been exposed and we don't have a new realization of what human
beings are.
And so isn't all of this excruciating detailed information that comes out about
anybody that's seeking power isn't ultimately like a good thing to see.
Like,
oh,
he's like me.
I know I'm fuck up.
He's like me.
Oh that guys like me too.
So instead of thinking that there's some person,
some Dalai Lama guy who was going to come save us,
the one guy on the planet doesn't have any vices.
Yeah.
Instead of that,
maybe we should have a more honest interpretation of what it means to be human
and passionate and understanding that sometimes we're,
we're,
you know,
Jordan Peterson said something fucking amazing to me.
He goes,
he goes,
we're ruled by different gods.
Depending on the moment,
the time of day,
we're ruled by the God of sex,
the God of a jealousy,
that God of anger,
the god of resentment.
It just depends on the moment,
which is his argument for an overreaching God.
But I want my president to be better than me.
You know what I'm saying?
I don't want him to see fancy.
Yeah.
Held to the higher standards are going to be better than you anyway.
There's just because they have the same flaws that you have,
doesn't mean they're not better at you than running the government running the
golf.
If he has a drug addiction,
he's fucking hookers,
not sharp.
And I don't want to run in my country.
And you'll be held can be the mayor of Toronto.
Like Rob Ford did a great job while I was mayor of Toronto Smoking crack.
Clinton wasn't bad either.
Exactly.
I just think we need,
we need a more nuance point of view of what human are and I think we've lost it.
I think we're very Americans,
but I think it's the think people are being held accountable more.
There'll be like,
there's actual like bad dudes who are like,
God,
it's out.
Yes,
yes.
[inaudible] and bad.
There's good and bad to this,
but I'm just,
I just hope that we come back around and the fact that human beings are
complicated,
that we're all fucking up that,
that it just because I fucked them in this atmospheric doesn't mean I'm a bad
person all the way through it.
Trevor Noah said something that that was interesting.
He said,
I want,
I don't understand about Americans is how you can't be both things.
Why do you have to be one thing or another?
You've got to have a black hat or white hat.
Can you be,
is it possible to sympathize with the black lives matter?
And also be pro cop.
Can you,
can you have both hospital and picks teams?
We've had to pick teams teams in a way.
Well it can't be calming to pick teams for sure.
And so it's an instinct that we have.
I think we're getting better and understanding what a human being is.
And I think to equate Harvey Weinstein with finding flaws and politicians is
very different.
I agree.
Because what he's doing,
what he was doing was essentially he was not just that,
he was,
he was like,
that was part of how we engineered his business.
He engineered his business to like feed his sexual harassing and sexual assault
appetites a piece of shit that's going on,
another contract that's going on.
I think in other corporations,
just not an entertainment.
So that,
I think the way he did it,
the girls had to fuck them to get parts.
Yeah.
I think he's an outlier.
I think he's,
I don't think so.
I think he's an outlier.
I think when it comes power and there's print and there's pretty girls,
I think men are going to abuse that power.
Right.
But Duane levels.
Some guys,
if you think Harvey Weinstein in that position of power is the only guy to do
that to that level.
Your credit may be our arts women are also drawn to power.
Right?
So I like how you guys try each other be like you're fucking 15 year old kids in
Brooklyn.
You have to work
to do,
because we're a couple of cuties C and I agree it's scary but I think it's a
witch hunt only for witches,
man.
I've,
it doesn't bother them.
No,
you can't say these guys get turned down.
You can't say that because of witch hunt is that the witch hunt is also like
based on hearsay and accusation and not proof.
So you,
you have to have due process for some.
Yes.
For some you have to have due process.
That's all.
W We all know that we live now at a time when just accusations can ruin your
entire career.
Well,
I mean I think part of Appleby whose career has it ruined?
That wasn't true.
I don't nursing Keillor.
Garrison Keillor is a good example.
Garrison Keillor's the best example,
and he's a guy like his entire career has been known as this,
like Super Nice Guy Consoles.
A woman hugs her,
his hand goes down,
her shirt on her back,
she,
she pulls back,
he apologized,
he sends her a letter apologizing and she accepts it.
They,
they stay friends and then she goes public,
whether it,
when all this meat to stuff comes out,
just feels compiled.
It's,
yeah,
she'd done,
didn't get,
just get,
just get fired.
They changed the name of his thing.
I'll Franken Franken admitted he did some shit that he shouldn't have done and
grab some butts out.
Yeah.
I'll have to almost a better point.
I how I think he's a farmer.
He's a bad guy either.
Yeah.
It's a good example for a while and then he couldn't,
and all the Democrats now or have in the,
in in Minnesota are having second thoughts.
He shouldn't retire.
Hey,
you fucking guys.
You'd mobbed up on Twitter.
Like a little proportion.
We need to have,
as we though you're,
you're talking about such a large number of some national marred up because it's
naturally in there.
They're fucking behavior pattern.
There needs to be a national narrative on where the line is too.
A lot of people don't know whether like I knew where the line is,
you know where the line is to me,
like if you don't want something and I'm humiliating you are embarrassing you
and,
and if I did that because I'm an idiot then then I got to make amends and figure
out what I did wrong.
You're 100% right,
but we have to understand what you're saying when you're saying the line.
The line includes free speech and free speech for 320 million people is going to
leave an exorbitant amount of human beings that feel like they should gang up on
everybody.
Anytime something goes sideways and that's what you see and that's what you
feel.
And that had been telling media companies react to that because they don't want
blow back.
They don't want boycotts.
They step in and fire pieces of the,
we shouldn't get fired.
But I think in the workplace it's scary.
Even for me,
there was a,
the a female cup the other night where in the lead up and you know I'm into
fashion and what was too gay with it,
but she had this dope coat on.
I thought about,
I said something about a cutlet.
I thought,
ah fuck was that too?
Like it was like two Ford with her about a coat.
Like I'm scared of it.
You gotta be careful how it's,
there's a male in the room.
And I was like,
dude,
where'd you get that coat from?
We're talking about coats.
And I saw hers and then she was about to go onstage.
I was like,
I love your coat.
That coat is dope.
And I grabbed her arm.
I was like,
oh she can,
she gonna like blast up like fucked up though.
You can.
And I thought,
oh well it depends cause your intentions,
your intentions are only like,
you really do love fashion and you see a really nice coat.
You're like,
Ooh,
that is nice.
Like you really like the way I would look at a nice car.
Wait.
What about,
what about if a woman's beautiful and I go,
you are.
You are fucking Europe.
Can't do that.
Why not?
Because the way you do it,
the way you do it,
you,
you started grabbing your
crotch.
Touch them.
She wears pants.
You take the shape of the letter c and you started giant cashier.
That's weird.
Why do you think that's weird?
Cause it's my sister.
I'd want to punch in the face
about it in the workplace too.
Like you can't if the,
if the girl was a pretty dress,
I saw a comic tweet out,
can't cantor girl we're addressed without being fucking complimented on it.
I'm like fuck man.
Without being complimented.
What do you mean like can't we just dress up and you can't say a word like
you'll see guys saying hey,
nice tie.
Like can't women come into the office and not get remarks?
Like fuck that's the world we're living in man.
You can't say man you look great today.
I said,
we look good just to,
they're confusing this you what you're saying is can't a woman come into the
office and get remarks,
get positive remarks and it be a good kit.
No pause.
Like Kik,
Kik,
demand,
not say anything about a woman the way she looks in the office place.
Can't she just be another,
a woman was asking.
Yeah,
warming goes can't,
can you guys just not common way?
Yes.
Oh,
a woman.
Be a man.
You want to compliment somebody.
There's,
there's also the reality,
and this is something that I've been talking about in my act,
a law.
There's a reality of the way women are allowed to dress both on television and
in real life in office situations where they expose enormous swats of skin,
which men are not.
If men in the office were wearing skirts and you could see their toes and they
had sleeveless shirts and this is common,
this is commonplace and there's nothing wrong with it and is nothing
inappropriate about it.
And I'm not,
I'm not commenting on it like criticizing it,
but the reality of the way women are allowed to dress.
Like if you watch Megan Kelly on television,
she's,
especially during the Fox News days when she's the Ice Princess,
she wore these very small dresses that looked like she was going out for a hot
night on the town.
Jamie,
bring that up for a sec.
It's not a bad thing man.
There's,
there's visionaries that just show women on Fox News,
criss crossing and uncrossing their legs and then dangling there shoes off
there.
Check out the weather girls in Latin America there's weather than La son
everywhere.
So girls,
the girls that dress like that should be allowed address any fucking way they
want.
But there is a reality of the way they're dressing that is way more sexually
suggestive than anything that a man is allowed to where there's not a sexual
equality when it comes to wardrobe,
when it comes to wardrobe and an office,
if every woman dress like Barbara Walters in the 1980s more fucking pants suit
and you know,
had like one of those big collars on and shit like dress like Ellen,
like every woman was like Ellen when she hosts her shit.
This is why all of that should be in Berkus.
But that is,
but that outfit,
that Ellen outfit is basic like a female version of what men were.
When men are on television,
they wear a suit jacket.
They were and I shirt,
they wear pants cause that isn't there also a truth to how men naturally are
drawn to women in certain outfits.
I mean like men are more visual [inaudible] talking about just how men,
men,
men get the fuck outta here.
Oh is that the face of a woman who's giving you these as a serious journalist?
Yeah,
she's so,
and that was back when she was like way hotter.
She have no problem with that.
She's,
she's probably either,
what is that?
Go in the upper right hand corner.
Upper right hand corner.
That series out there.
[inaudible] her at all.
She's stupid hot,
right?
Ridiculous.
Short hair,
which I imagine now imagine now disagree with Don Lemon wearing that same
outfit.
Well,
I wouldn't look in that actually.
I have good legs there.
Okay.
You don't know dude.
You've seen me in high heels.
Don Lemon's has been,
you don't have good legs.
Ooh,
yes I do.
Okay,
well you have shit.
Yeah,
I psoriasis flared up again.
Fuck off.
It flared up again.
Short drive.
I did.
I know I,
but I think my flu caused my psoriasis from shore to have it all the time.
I just got to the game.
We have to,
we have to make sure that we let everybody know what we're saying here.
I'm not saying that women should be sexually harassed because they dress sec.
So now I'm saying if you wear something that looks nice in the office,
I think guys should be like,
damn,
you look really good today.
It's a problem because that was,
the girl responds to that.
Then the guy's like,
Ooh,
she wants to Dick.
I see she has to beat heads full about how she walks to the water cooler by
herself and you've got to come up to her and she's on her way to the bathroom
and ask her weird questions.
It's a Mama,
but don't a lot of people get married in the workplace?
Don't they have romances in the workplace,
don't they?
Not Anymore.
Or Eagle.
Maybe it should be,
but I don't know.
That's where a lot of like that's where you meet people.
I will have a bunch of people who are really unhappy that's going to make men
and women unhappy.
Puritanical.
I know a lot of people that,
especially in like the TV business that like the writer would like hook up with
one of the girls who was in production and then they want to be in married and
having kids.
It's a great story.
And I also know a lot where the writer would hook up with one of the girls in
production and then they would break up and it would be a fucking disaster on
the sat and one of them would wind up leaving.
Angela's take that responsibility.
Okay.
You know what we're all asking for them.
Figuring on eight,
we want to a higher authority,
a corporate,
nameless,
faceless bureaucracy to to lay down these laws on high in stone.
And there are certain things you can't do.
No relationships whatsoever.
I don't care if you're two human beings,
awesome.
The workplace is going to be fucking great American.
Let me throw a fucking happy,
let me throw a scenario at tasting to the band.
Individuals responsibility for managing their own,
their own relationships,
their own romance now and colleges.
When fucking colleges,
my nephews got to sit there and every step of the way sexually he's got to go,
is this okay?
Is this okay?
He's got to get consent every time you gotta relax.
Fuck that.
Fuck that state.
Everybody is big brother.
It's tyrannical and it's not gonna make anybody happy or safer.
It's all bullshit.
You know what people that you know why you walk a girl to a car at night?
Not because men not cause a rape culture.
Not because men are dangerous because there are psychos out there cause there
are psychotics cause 1% both.
I think both.
What do you mean?
There's a lot of guys you got to watch out for.
If you walk course there Auckland it's going to buy or sell.
It takes the one guy in a van.
Right?
But I'm saying psychos.
It's sometimes just a guy with a couple of drinks in him as an asshole.
Listen man,
all my friends who are drunk,
we've talked about this,
you know rapists,
rapists in jail,
rape is in jail,
have to be protected from the other inmates.
Men who are regular guys like I was done like those long hold on.
No child rapists,
I have to be protected.
There's a lot of guys that are in jail.
He pretty,
so Neil got arrested once,
falsely accused of rape,
and one of the things that he said was that when he went to jail,
he was worried and guys would be like,
no,
that's a skin beef.
They would call it a skin beef.
I was like,
that's not like no one thinks you're a rapist is one thing.
If you get accused of being like some serial rapist breaking a window,
then you're fine.
But a guy who will,
girl,
they have a dispute in the girl,
uh,
claims the guy raped her,
which no one wants to admit happens and it happens way less.
I think way more women don't report rape way more than women report false rape.
I agree 100% way more women are in Cabarrus disturbed sick and they feel
dehumanized.
They don't even want to discuss it.
They would rather not be outed as someone who got raped and let this person get
away with it.
That's a common thing with women.
That's,
I think some of this Hashtag [inaudible] is good,
but also some women lie.
That happens too.
That's a bummer.
But you can't.
You can't.
But they're humans.
They're humans.
We can't tailor everything towards those few negative apple.
No you don't.
But you don't tailor anything towards the idea that those apples are nonexistent
and impossible.
Correct.
But I'm going back to the office space.
You're going to always deal with false accusations.
You're going to deal with people that don't report things.
You're going to deal with all these things in the,
in the wide spectrum of humanity.
I just don't think that this zero tolerance,
nobody's allowed to date anybody because we don't want to.
And that's where we're at.
That's what happens.
I don't agree.
We talked about it on our show and I never even thought about too.
We were at the comedy store and when I told that girl,
Nice Coda,
Oh fuck did I see creek?
Great.
Cause he's young.
You know she's 21 amazing comic.
Pissed,
pissed.
Get the fuck Outta here.
You guys are very wrestling each other nephew.
One more fucking loose.
His nephew,
I don't know.
He's going to some school like is can't talk.
You don't go pee.
I'll be right back.
Jesus Christ pan.
He gets on you two are like an old married couple.
It's hilarious.
Yeah,
I want to kill him some days,
but I think we're talking too much about sexual harassment.
I agree.
And I think people,
people will shut it down.
You know what the problem is with sexual harassment too is it's everywhere.
So shows like this,
they don't want to fucking hit for it here either.
We're trying to work it out.
I think that's one of the important things about talking about it,
but the problem has,
men are talking about it like we don't know Jack Shit about it.
Like I said,
I don't really deal with deal with it and we don't,
but here's the thing,
like no one's coming at us with it.
Like I've only had gay guys hit on me aggressively a couple of times ever in my
life and it was day tried sucking my Dick.
I felt uncomfortable.
Andy Dick,
I'm just kidding by the way.
I've tried,
but he's awesome.
I had a comic once,
the Montreal comedy festival like late at night when we're all hanging around
the bar,
get super aggressive with me.
Yay.
Yeah,
super way back in the day.
This is like,
I want to say like late nineties real uncomfortable moment where I'd tell him to
get the fuck away from me due to it could have been some problems.
No,
it wasn't like a physically threatening thing.
I literally told them I would stomp a fucking hole in his chest if he touched me
again.
Didn't work.
It didn't turn on.
No,
it worked.
Yeah.
No,
I was serious.
I was like,
you gotta stop punching blows up when he was drunk and I wasn't.
It was one of those weird moments where someone is like being sexually
aggressive.
They think it's funny and then then they tried to take it to the next level,
show you how crazy they are.
At some point that I was like,
did you not touch me like this?
And then I realized like,
Oh,
this is what it's like when you're a woman except the woman can't kill the guy.
Now I'm dealing with a doughy drunk comedian than I could kill.
Yeah.
If he tried anything,
he just whoop his ass.
Where women don't have worries,
they don't have that option.
At all and it's not funny.
They weren't,
you know,
with a woman.
It's not a funny situation with me.
It's like it was funny.
It was never like I was nervous,
but it was like,
God,
this is gross.
Well,
I think you look at it a different too because you have two daughters.
I do now that I'm saying now it's like,
fuck man,
you do that.
He just having children,
you,
you look at people so differently because children are so vulnerable and when
you have a little kid and you see that little kid trying to make your way
through the world,
you think about them being victimized by some sort of an evil Predator and it's
fucking awful.
It's a terrible feeling.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a weird thing that we have to reconcile the fact that some people do prey
on other peoples.
What vulnerabilities and weaknesses and do,
boy,
yeah,
I'm looking for a new nanny and you hear all these horrible stories about
nannies and the molests kids,
so it's the less kids being kids.
There's some horrible videos of of nannies like lifting kids up and throwing him
against their crib and you can't watch them.
They're so infuriating pieces.
One kid,
it was all fucked up and bruised and the parents put this fucking camera and
they caught the lady picking the kid up by his arms and literally throwing them
across the room and you watch it.
You just like,
oh my God,
tough for me not to go to prison.
If I came home and saw that it would be really slow.
So to have more self control,
a lot of people it'd be soap,
tough to choke.
You know what they say?
They gave the gave rise to the helicopter parent phenomenon and one of the
things they talk about like how how students are so entitled and they became
sort of like this idea that they can say anything they want and you know,
that's sort of the whole movement of my personal serenity has everything.
One of the,
one of the theories would be that in the 80s,
when kids started disappearing and you started reading about it,
the end up on the back of my opponents,
all of us as parents,
as human beings,
like there's nothing worse,
right?
You can't think of anything worse.
And that created this.
Every parent your biggest fear right now you go,
I'm not letting my kid take his bike down to the neighbors cause it might only
be 600 yards,
but,
uh,
John Wayne Gacy might be waiting till my dad didn't let me know.
I'll come to always happened actually.
But it was,
you know,
now people say,
remember when we used to be able to play out there?
It's always happened,
but we,
we started learning about it.
People started establishing patterns about it.
Then we hadn't like certain serial killers like John Wayne Gacy and,
and uh,
uh,
ted Bundy and stuff like that.
And we do.dodge bullets twice in my own life.
So dodged a bullet once when I was about eight years old.
And again,
when I was about 13 dodge a bullet.
You mean for guys who are trying to fuck me?
What?
Yeah,
yeah.
A guy tried to take me out of a library when I was a little kid,
that library and starts yelling out.
He was gonna show me these books in his car and the library and started yelling
out,
Joseph,
you get away from him.
That guy just got out of jail and I'm fucking crying.
And I run to her and the guy runs out of there.
And then another time when I was 13 some guy like literally tried to get closer
and closer to me and my friends.
He would jog around this lake that we would fish at,
sit down and talk to us,
seem like a super nice guy.
And then it got creepier and weirder until one day he showed up drunk.
He told me he loved me and that know love could be a,
you can't have love without sex.
And I was like,
why?
And I was 13 and I was,
I was skinny kid and I was hiding,
you know,
we were in this area of this pond where it's like,
yeah,
he's a man,
a grow man,
a big man too.
And he wants,
and there's,
you know,
I'm waiting for a jogger to combine and catch this guy fucking me in the ass and
the bushes.
Like what do I do so not to do.
I told him get the fuck away from me.
I put my hand in my pocket where had a knife.
I held onto the network as if I could do,
I never 13 year old tries to cut.
You cut that Dick though.
Maybe he didn't grab your arms first.
I wasn't strong.
I was super volt.
But my point is I got lucky and dodge two bullets in my life and they weren't
bad bullets.
It wasn't like some Guy Corps formed me and threw me in a van fuck and he asked
for a month.
That's scary.
But it's,
it's not worst case scenario,
but it was enough to know what those things are real and they're out there.
There's a lot of my buddy,
my buddy got a,
from the age of nine to 12,
this guy was just this master manipulator and he ended up like getting
essentially rate from nine to 12 and he was their neighbor.
He was like,
he lived,
he was like,
uh,
probably 25,
whatever.
And he lived and he did work around the place and he would,
he was really good at was he got my friend to,
uh,
like he created a sympathetic character.
So my friend felt like he was like,
I had to,
I was having sex with them cause I felt like I was taking care of him otherwise
he would die if I didn't like he was.
And so yes,
we put all the stuff on him.
And then what happened was he went through all that as mother.
Like they found out,
his mother said,
you did nothing wrong,
but they didn't know they fucking,
this is the 70s,
early eighties.
They go through the whole thing.
The Guy I think went to jail,
but it was later,
it was later that that trauma began to manifest itself like later on.
And he was never really,
he's never,
oh,
he's gotta be feeling gross,
dirty and you hate yourself.
Like he,
when he is he gay now,
but he's not gay.
But he was never able to,
I don't want to say too much cause you know,
he's,
I haven't talked to him all the time,
but he was,
I was close to him.
You might've,
no,
I think I've told you a little bit about,
um,
uh,
he,
he would paint was a great painter.
I have some of his paintings in my home and he was such a great special guy,
but he would know,
but he would paint the same thing over and over again.
And he never ever painted anything different.
Variation plus cause gut.
But you know what?
I think humans need to pay attention to the worst aspects of our behavior.
And one of the things that Jordan Peterson has said that I think is incredibly
important
is what scares us the most about Nazis and murderers,
psychopaths and rapists,
is we are all human and giving the right set of circumstances with the right set
of input and the right set of genetics and the right set of environments and the
right set of life experiences and the right set of abuse in the household
growing up.
You could be that person too and enjoy it.
Yeah,
and when you talk to neuroscientists and,
and,
and people that are actually studying how the human brain develops.
And one of the things that Robert Sapolsky said when I had him on the podcast is
a really fascinating thing.
He said that I think in the future we are going to look back at the idea of
punishing someone for their actions as being so incredibly shortsighted and
foolhardy because what this person is,
when you think about the concept of determinism,
right,
the,
the concept of everything in your life has led you to be who you are right now.
And your,
your idea of free will is essentially an illusion.
Your freewill is based on so many different factors that you have no control
over and they influence you to such a great,
such a great deal.
The idea that this person is in this terrible situation that does this terrible
crime is just acting out of evil intentions is,
is it's a foolish way of understanding how the human brain develops.
Yeah.
What's he say that,
how would you treat those people?
It's a very good question and no one's,
no one's answered that.
Back in the day when somebody had an epileptic seizure,
epileptic seizure,
uh,
you were,
you are thought to have been possessed by a demon.
If you hit somebody,
they would,
you would be held accountable to that.
But what I thought was fascinating was a world war one.
Dan Carlin talks about this as well in world war one when they didn't know what
kind of concussion the bombs and their concussion would do to a soldier over and
over and sleep deprivation living in those trenches.
And what happened was some people would just begin to go into shock.
They would get shell shocked and so you could see them,
their bodies would start to constrict and they couldn't really move.
But back in the day,
those guys would be brought out and shot for cowardice because they were being
cowards.
They weren't,
and you could see their bodies.
We're actually manifesting right to,
of like the problem with drafting and army are requiring people to sign up,
you know,
or making it some sort of a cultural mandate is there's some people that are
just not designed for,
they can't handle pressure.
No.
There's a lot of people that just can't handle fucking pressure period.
And for whatever reason,
whether it's biological,
whether it's environmental,
whether it's a combination of nature and nurture,
who knows?
But there's some people that just as of right now there,
they just can't do it.
They just cannot.
They can't handle pressure.
Also also,
there's also this,
there's injury.
There's also a more constant sleep deprivation injury that nobody can handle.
And the shock of impacts near you.
You know,
there's,
there's a lot that happens to people and the,
you know,
obviously the psychological trauma of it all and knowing that at any,
any step you could step on a landmine.
Any step,
you catch a bullet in the head and he's tab.
Yeah,
the Jordan said something else that was interesting.
He's helped people with PTSD when
they come back from a war and they were from Iowa and they had a very sort of
linear notion of was first of all of the military.
I want to be,
I want to be a man.
I wanna,
I wanna I want to do the right thing.
Duty,
honor,
loyalty,
these linear concepts,
of course you get into war and all of that gets shattered.
Sometimes it might even get mocked just because there's the fog of war.
There's so many things you do and some of these guys end up doing things that
are to them or because of the circumstances may be inexplicably cruel or just
they did something that they can't live down and he would always kind of help
them see that human beings being the bipolar ape that we are are capable of
incredible kindness and and beautiful construction and of course on the other
side of that,
you have in you the ability to do unspeakable violence and terrible destruction
for its own sake and oh,
by the way,
in the moment to enjoy it.
That's being a human being.
We're fucking complicated men,
et cetera.
That's also how we got here.
Yes.
The only way you get from the wild Ayp swinging for the fuck threw the fucking
trees in the jungle to 2017 with your Tesla driving you down the street without
you even touching the steering wheel.
The only way you get to that is through aggression.
Yeah,
I mean it sounds crazy,
but you get to that through aggression and competition because if you don't have
those,
that ability to survive,
you're not going to get past the Jaguars.
You're not going to get past the,
the invading tribes,
you're not going to get.
So you don't need that today.
I'm not saying you need it today,
but the only reason why we got out of those terrible situations is because we
have the ability to become that monster that defends itself or that monster that
attacks for its own interests.
That's literally what facilitated us developing.
Yeah.
And also the fact that development requires a certain amount of destruction in,
in terms of like I did this podcast with him,
I'm going to drop soon on mixed marital arts.
And W he,
he said something cause somebody who wrote this article,
this woman and professor wrote this article about how certain speeches violent.
Because when you say something that I disagree with or that hurts my
sensibilities,
it puts me in a state of stress and that would be violence cause I,
and so Jordan said,
fine,
let's extrapolate for a second.
Yes,
it's true.
That words can pierce your heart.
I mean,
he said,
I'd rather get punched in the face.
You got to hear him say it,
but,
but he said essentially the problem is it it what,
what about six months down the line,
if I am trying to get help,
you grow and become a better person and I see a fundamental flaw in your
behavior,
in your character,
and I tell you if you have bad breath and you can't get a date,
and I go,
dude,
your breath could melt paint at first.
It's going to be fucking embarrassing to you,
but you're gonna thank me six months down the line when you did something about
it.
More importantly,
if you say to somebody,
do you want to be,
I hope I see you trying to be this,
whether it,
it might a great comic,
you don't,
right?
You're not disciplined,
whatever it might be,
you don't want to hear them about an issue,
the truth,
and sometimes you have a set of beliefs,
a sort of built your house around
this set of like sort of an ideology.
You think you have the truth as somebody comes along with a different idea,
a different point of view that shatters those walls and man,
you don't like it.
You want to go back to your safe space,
but good luck growing.
You don't get closer to the truth by fucking saying you're,
you're causing violence.
I think the real problem with this is that these people are not trying to grow.
The people that are trying to change the definitions of words to suit their own
intentions.
They don't want to have the option and it's not by chance.
The the same people that support Marxists ideologies,
they don't want competition.
They want a lack of competition.
I think competition is bad.
There's a lot of that out there because they're not good at it because they
don't want to face that ultimate objective view of who they really are and the
actual capabilities.
They'd rather get a bunch of fucking weird social justice Brownie points for a
bunch of weird things and you know,
there's a lot of that.
There's a lot of that you're going to and you could see those patterns and the
way those people talk.
They have very specific ways of talking.
You can point out very specific things that they say,
things that they talk about their,
they're going to be the first to talk about white privilege.
They're going to be the first to talk about trans rights and all these
different,
there's a wet and there's a way of talking,
an actual pattern that the way they communicate your words are violence.
There's,
there's literally a pattern that they've adopted,
a predetermined pattern or behavior of thinking the ideology and in the way they
communicate.
So they all know that they're on the same team.
It's called owning your impact,
your verbal impact,
and there's,
there's a,
there's a pattern to the way the noises come out of their mouth.
It's fascinating because there's so,
there's so uniform,
it's so common to hear these people talk the same way.
When Jordan Peterson got in this debate on television with this,
it looks like a man and I say it in the same way that they in them or pronouns.
I don't mean to be negative.
I don't know if this is a man or a woman because she's clearly,
he's clearly Uber feminine,
but has a beard and says there is no biological difference in gender.
He sort of Medicine University of Toronto.
I saw that.
He goes,
I'd be happy to unpack that for you.
And it's like,
oh,
x,
y chromosomes.
If you could find that,
see if you could just find that guy saying to Jordan Peterson,
he was no biological basis for gender.
They were trying to force some under penalty of law and fine or whatever,
and jail,
uh,
to use,
to not use someone's preferred Pronoun,
which I would do just because I don't want to hurt somebody's feelings,
but they're trying to pass and it's law.
So if you didn't use Xer or whatever,
you would be a gender Pronoun tries in Toronto.
Yes.
It'd be tried for,
um,
you'd be tried for hate speech.
And that's where we had,
you know,
with that Communists,
they always,
comics was of true religion in the Soviet Union and they had essentially
clergymen people who were sort of,
uh,
you know,
at the purest form of a priest.
The idea that somebody would go around and check with the soldiers to make sure
that their piety,
that their allegiance to the communist cause was intact.
And they'd ask you questions or other cultures having these problems where these
[inaudible] coming up and all that stuff.
I mean,
it's happening pro down at us happening in America.
I'm sure it's probably happening in different ways.
It happened in like Europe and Brazil and in the 20th century it was called
Fascism.
It was called communism.
Human beings love religion.
We're all religious.
And if you,
and there's,
there are manmade religion and other religions that are,
you know,
at least purported to be from on high,
at least with on high religions,
they're rather fixed.
It seems that manmade religions tend to be more ideologies.
Um,
and the difference between those,
by the way,
his philosophy,
something that's trying to get to the truth with logic and reason and debate
etiologies.
There's no room for debate.
It goes back to what you were saying.
We have the answers,
ladies and gentlemen,
that is equality in all costs.
Yeah.
I'd be happy to impact that for you.
Yes,
yes.
To have that video.
Now we'll see if we could find that.
Jimmy will find it.
I can't stand the guy but,
but it was a bizarre conversation because it's like,
okay,
I see what you're doing.
You're trying to reinvent reality and there's a bunch of people that support
you.
There's a bunch of other people that are delusional and there also right there
with you trying to reinvent reality.
Is there a,
is there a huge movement?
Like is this a big thing?
There's enough that people were talking about it.
The thing about losing morale too though.
Yeah,
of course they are.
Course there's not enough people.
There's not enough people are going to support it.
There's so many real Morgan to reject it.
It'd be like,
get the fuck out.
And not only that,
this is not like a behavior thing.
This is science.
You're talking about chromosomes.
You talking about gender dysphoria,
you're talking about all sorts of different issues that are like,
these are recognized actual issues that human beings have.
Well,
what are these issues though?
Are you saying there's no,
there's no scientific basis.
You're saying you can't differentiate between a male and a woman,
a man and a female.
That is bizarre nonsense.
Of course you can make a distinction between,
you could make the distinction between male and female and then um,
he and her in a way.
Here we go.
Yeah.
This is the bald one is the one who said that it okay.
Well woman's in a women's studies department.
Yeah.
Hold on a second.
Cause he's not transgender.
The something going on.
Really
it's not correct that there is such a thing as biological sex.
And I'm a historian of medicine.
I can unpack that for you at grandma's fucking crazy.
In the interest of time I won't.
So that's a very popular misconception.
So I essentially,
in my transgender studies classes,
what we're doing is looking at actual research and identify ways that current
social issues related to trans people or things that are associated with trans,
such as free speech arguments and claims.
Uh,
hard times,
nice to speech arguments in a way that people are thinking in the way that
research has been framed,
the history there was some of the other prisoners area.
Typically I don't focus on pronouns because pronouns are actually part of a CIS
normative culture.
So what we do
is learn about it.
I'm going to stop you right there to explain it,
but we don't start from the forearm
to this guy's a good guy or girl that used to be a girl.
That's a man.
Did it used to be a woman has a better beard than me?
No,
that's a man.
That's a man on hormones.
I think that's a man on a female that's on male hormone.
No,
I disagree.
I think it's,
you know,
good to hear.
Do you know Buck Angeles?
No.
Buck angels,
a porn star that was born a woman that became a man through hormones and she was
on the podcast.
He was on the podcast.
He's a,
he now talks exactly like that guy.
Sounds just like him.
That guy right there that's born a woman born a woman.
Yup.
Yeah,
but just play a clip of him on the podcast.
This is what I want you to hear.
I want you to hear the way he sounds because he sounds literally exactly like
that guy.
Like he could be doing an impression of that guy.
Look at it is all jacked and yoke to shit.
Get along.
Goes is a couple of years ago,
I want to say a hundred thousand years ago,
200,000 years ago when we were women and a run,
two women had a fight.
Two women had to stay alive.
Women had to protect their babies and they didn't have to do it as much or often
get to him and get to him.
Exactly.
And they'll be less likely to stick around and raise their children cannot
exist,
but don't they?
Like it doesn't make sense to me.
The whole,
the whole building.
I used to be a female taking,
yeah,
let me see it before Friday.
But here's the thing.
Let me see.
Same order,
same voice.
I think that that guy is a guy who was born,
a woman who took me on hormones just like buck angel.
Maybe you might be fucking on it,
but the idea that there's no biological difference,
but I don't see a naked picture.
So that's the above.
Let me see the the girl version.
It doesn't have his license.
That's,
that's not what act.
No,
no,
no.
That's not what you would see.
See what is the word I'm trying to look for?
I that him right there.
That was before and after it said,
come on,
really this,
this,
this makes sense.
Like I feel like if the,
if the world had my,
my attitude full me wait,
but the world at your absolute perfect.
No,
no,
definitely not.
But I think the world that my attitude about this,
like even as a kid,
if I saw that somebody was very feminine or I saw that,
like say somebody was like,
I feel like,
uh,
I'm a woman,
but I want to be a man or a man with a protected that person and more important
they've been doing it.
I think I would've gone out of my way to make no big deal about it and they
would have been included.
Yeah,
but that's not,
we're not talking about you.
I talking about that sort of conversation is a nonsense conversation and this is
going on over and over and over again because those people are going to call
Eric Weinstein was on my podcast.
Winestein sorry.
Yeah,
not like Harvey Weinstein.
Eric Weinstein brother Bret Weinstein was on my podcast and he said,
here's how you know when you're in a cult,
when you hear there is no biological difference between men and women.
You're in a cult that's called [inaudible],
who's,
who's that are common
in colleges today.
Colleges today,
you're hearing it left and right and a major,
a major call,
major universities in America.
Yes,
in America,
they're,
they're teaching this and people were afraid to correct them.
Why?
They're afraid to say anything different about it.
And,
and that's exactly right.
And in fact,
if you even say gender dysmorphia was cause for you as far as,
sorry,
it was considered a mental illness for a long time.
Even to suggest that that may be us,
a subset of the population.
Maybe it's worth it.
It wouldn't.
You have a child maybe.
Well if you have a child who's thinking of themselves,
I,
there are people,
Hollywood actors that are having their children.
I,
from what I have heard,
having seen this,
what I've heard from people that I know their kids are going through,
they're getting horrible.
I think hormone blockers.
Owen Benjamin got a shit load of trouble for talking about a guy who has a three
year old.
That's how he's putting through a hormonal blockers.
And he was talking about how fucking insane that people were barring owned
Benjamin from war.
Are you kidding?
No,
I'm not.
My own bedroom and guy,
by the way,
he's just an animal.
They own child.
Let this child develop it's child abuse.
If you cracked any legit doctors who know anything about they go,
really,
we shouldn't be doing anything to your past 21 years old.
We shouldn't be doing Amy then if you want to do it to each of the text is not
even fully developed for 25 that was one thing he talked about 25 yeah,
but Dave watershed date,
there's some kids that at a very young age are very adamant about the fact they
were born in the wrong body.
And some of them,
you look at them and you go,
well,
it makes sense,
right?
So it's like who's right and who's wrong and when do you decide?
But here's when you don't decide.
Three three is crazy.
He's crazy.
Three,
he should be put in jail.
There's something wrong with our culture where we think that that's a good idea
to interfere with the hormonal system of a very complex thing like as human
beings.
Three that becomes this sort of,
this,
um,
the thing to do.
Because if it was a thing that the CDC,
what do is,
what does the kin,
Canadian broadcast network,
CBC,
they didn't want to talk about a story.
And I tweeted this a while back to this.
They didn't,
they didn't want to have a story on about transgender children because they
showed that 85% of the kids that wanted to be trans after a couple of years
changed their mind.
There was a giant percentage of these kids that went through a phase.
You know,
Ruby rose,
that famous actress,
I think she's a lesbian.
She's got,
it's really pretty.
She was in that John Wick two moving.
She said that when she was young that she had thought about being trans and
she's really happy that she didn't actually go through it with the hormones and
everything and now she realizes this is just shown she just doesn't fit in.
And a lot of people don't,
they don't fit into what society has in line for them in terms of a man or a
woman.
This binary one or zero,
this old school.
I also think that makes sense too.
I also think a lot of the,
the,
the activism came out of a good place,
which was that a lot at 40% of people
who have trans,
a Trans Morphea,
what is it?
Gender dysphoria.
You gotta get that right?
Sorry.
40% of the thing.
You don't even commit that commit suicide.
Well,
here's the thing you're not even supposed to be doing by the way.
It doesn't have anything to do with whether or not they have had surgery even
ask you that.
I was going to ask you that.
I heard that after they have the surgery.
It doesn't,
it doesn't actually change in that.
No,
it does.
But the question is,
is it,
are they depressed because they haven't been accepted but accepted as who's,
who's who they really are.
Yeah.
And how society caused them to have these irreparable scars and that's what's
led them to commit suicide ultimately.
And it wasn't fixed by the surgery.
Is that possible too?
Is it possible that we could be more accepting as a society and as a culture?
And then these people could just be whoever the fuck they want to be.
And that's all right too.
And maybe we would have a lower suicide rate if it wasn't thought of with this
great stigma.
But you're not going to fix that by having people like that go on TV and say
something that's a blatant scientific lock.
Like I sick in the head,
like I should not be educating young mind and people are coming out of those
schools.
Thousands of people every day are coming out adopting and these are called
cheese and cause my son date rebel against their parents and their parents might
be some fucking right wing square jawed knucklehead,
you know,
that has some stupid ideas about what a man is and what a woman is.
And it is.
And God says,
man shall not lawyer Dude,
studios and directors get massive heat for not having transgender actors and
stars and all that.
And there's this index.
How many lines did women save versus how many lines in men,
how many female strong characters are right?
But here's the thing you do.
Do you know about this,
uh,
cover?
Um,
with all these women,
and they were talking about inclusivity and about,
is it on time now I forget.
Vanity Fair or something like that.
It's different.
It's a different magazines.
It was all white.
I don't know.
But it's all white.
All white women.
Like how has this diversity,
like you're all white women,
you're not even playing by your own rules.
A lot of shit for it.
They should get a lot of shit for it.
Whoever the fuck let that slip through.
Like what are,
what message are you trying to send?
You said you were saying is this an anti male message because user or you're a
bunch of white women,
but you know,
now you're getting into this.
My favorite fucking favorite new discipline,
which is intersections.
Feminism don't know what it is.
It's the best.
So when,
when,
when did with the feminist movement really began with white women and I think it
started in the,
in the women's studies department,
or at least the literature department,
Yale University.
And they had,
they did some work,
man,
they,
those women were serious and,
and you can't say that the feminist movement didn't have something to say and,
and have some work to do.
Of course it did.
A smart women were like,
I don't fucking want to be,
you know,
there are some issues and disparity,
but what happens with any movement is that it's like,
well,
we're white women.
What about black women?
They,
they have it way worse than we do.
And what about,
and we can just keep extrapolating.
What about black women with allergies?
Black women with Lupus.
How about,
what about black women who come from really poor and violent areas versus black
women to come from a better area?
What about black women who are midgets?
They're d you can keep,
I know little purses,
small people.
You can just keep time.
So often top,
sorry buddy.
God.
The top at the top of the sort of power structure.
Now the inverted power structure is people that are the most oppressed.
They're the voices that have to be heard the most.
The problem with breaking this down into all these sections is you get
ultimately to,
cause when they had this huge,
Christine Summers talks about this,
they had this huge intersection hist,
feminist sort of congregation where all these women got together,
but in the group when they were meeting in the convention center,
they started breaking up.
They started breaking up,
oops.
Oh,
they were breaking up.
They're like,
well,
we have allergies,
so we're not over there,
and he,
by the way,
you're black,
you're white,
you're a feminist,
but you date you're white,
black feminists,
but you also,
you date a white woman.
Sorry,
you're a little more privileged.
You got to go over there in the midgets rovers,
so it became this.
If you get one click after another,
that's crazy that women become cliquey.
That's the craziest thing I've ever heard.
You want to know my favorite stories in regards to those.
Let me just finish this one story.
The problem with that movement is as you keep extrapolating,
you get to what's called the individual.
The founding fathers figured that out a long time ago.
Ultimately you're going to get down to the fact that you should treat everybody
as the thing,
as an individual.
I like it as an individual.
That's the whole point.
That's that.
Yes,
you can keep going,
but if you keep playing that game,
you're just going to get down to everybody's different.
Everybody has something.
Everybody is a white dude.
My buddy Dave Holly has a spine like this and he's,
he's going to die unless he gets an operation.
His life sucks.
He's about that big.
His email is no neck day.
If I say I love him,
he's fucking hilarious.
Dave Ali,
but Dave is white.
He ate privileged.
He came from home.
Mormon family,
a large family.
He wasn't.
You know,
his life has not been fucking easy.
He can't breathe so you can keep extrapolating.
That's why you treat people as individuals because you don't know anything about
them.
You actually don't know anything about what they've come through.
It could be a great looking guy,
sleeve tattoo,
nonsense conversation because what they're really trying to do is establish
power structures and they want to have power over the rest of the people.
In the group because they apparently have more things that are going against
the,
as you were going to say that my favorite story is there was a an all girls
college and this woman is running for president of Student Council and she
decides that she's a male.
She decides to change her gender and uh,
then the fucking kiss,
she didn't get an operation though.
No,
no,
no.
She just decided she was a masculine of center of centered gender queer was how
she described herself card by decided to change her name to a male's name.
Then the women in the school,
we're against
her because she is now a white man and the white man is the patriarchy and she,
it was the president of diversity or something like that.
Like some student council becomes of class madness,
diversity.
She'd go back.
I do not know.
Somebody sent me something about that.
How somebody said something about colleges had become these specialized,
they're specialized in subjects that have increasing irrelevance.
Yeah.
It's,
it's a weird thing man.
I think people automatically have this desire to stand out and be more
important.
They automatically too.
So it's like a common thing and they can do it through merit but merit.
It's difficult.
Meritocracies are hard.
You might fall short and sometimes you in along the way you see your meritocracy
like not working out for you.
You'll,
you'll claim there's some sort of a conspiracy against you and there might be
cute claims,
other people of privilege and they might eat.
You'll claim all of these reasons why you're not getting ahead and you might be
right.
You might be right in some ways because colleges are like the thorn.
A lot of comics not doing the tours anymore or when they call just
before a lot of comics were doing cause stopped way before this,
I stopped the colleges and the early two thousands for that very reason.
For that reason there were just way too sensitive and they didn't have life
experience.
The problem is I like talking to people that have bills and jobs and people that
have relationships that didn't work out so good and now they have a fucking kid,
but some lady who hates him.
That's my crowd.
I know John People,
I like talking to people that owe taxes,
spending their fucking money,
trying to figure out what they're doing in their life.
They want to talk about meritocracy is my favorite meritocracies there.
How you you find out who is real,
who really deserves it.
You don't do colleges anymore either.
Deep down I don't,
it's just not a smart thing to do because those people in those colleges are,
they're very,
very young.
You're dealing with 19 year olds,
20 year olds,
and they're in this weird ideological bubble.
You know,
there's all these fucking peel that are just jammed in together in this group
and everybody's trying to stand out and weird and unique ways and there's people
that are doing it by claiming their masculine of center gender queer and
changing their name and wow,
you're so unique.
You're so amazing.
And there's also people that are doing it because they're trying to buck that
system.
They're becoming the,
the Republicans on campus and people are calling them Nazis.
You know,
there's a lot of a fucking shoe palace should be talks about that.
And especially with someone rushed the stage.
We've suffered as much as you and he's like,
hold on,
you're a white woman to take it easy.
Now you've suffered thought like we've suffered as much as you to.
How does that invalidate this person's suffering?
If someone's on stage talking about their suffering,
yours did the,
the,
the nature of your suffering is invalid.
It's not relevant.
You,
you,
you can relate to that person.
Not Relate,
but the fact that you can stop them from talking or that you think you can stop
them from talking just cause you've suffered yourself as well.
Like what did that mean?
No,
you're there for fucking audience.
You're an audience member.
You're,
your job is to sit down and listen.
If you want to be a performer,
well you need to fucking get an act.
You need to get booked at the club.
You need to become professional.
Have people come and pay to see you,
and then you can express yourself.
You're violating the audience versus performer rules.
I also think that people who are that sensitive,
they don't really,
they haven't,
they don't.
They haven't really figured out what they believe and they don't really believe
in what they're saying.
They just belong to a group and they like being a good foot soldier.
They haven't really thought out why they haven't been challenged.
They might've thought it out,
but they've been thought about with a bunch of other people that are thinking
the same things that they think they felt it out.
It feels right.
It doesn't,
it's not thought well she's getting data on the live comedy show.
She has some serious issues going on.
She rushed the stage.
That's a good point.
Like fat,
like fat shaming.
Yeah.
There's another thing.
Fat Shaming.
Yeah,
a very similar thing.
Like you're not supposed to talk about people being overweight and I was talking
about people being fat.
You're not supposed to discuss it as being a real health issue,
that you're fat.
You're fat shaming them.
You talk about reality.
You're talking about your friend with his bad back and is fucked up spine and
has a hard time breathing and like seriously,
like from the jump,
right?
Yeah,
you can.
That's just a reality.
But there'll be more weight.
Same thing,
but it's,
it's worse because it's by decisions that they've made.
It's allowed them to get that big.
If you just decided to not eat,
that is a,
that is a possible answer.
Now we go back to determinism.
Right.
Then how much of your life is,
you're a beautiful man.
You're fine.
We have suffered more than you,
Brandon,
but if you go back to,
you know what we're talking about about determinism mean is is your life,
are you right now in the middle of conscious decision making is shaping your
destiny or are you a product of all your life experiences?
All of the input that you've received,
your genetics and some days it's a very dangerous,
scary area because I don't like taking personal responsibility away from people.
I don't like it either,
but the reality about human bodies,
and Rhonda Patrick was talking about this the other day,
morbidly obese people have differences in their sperm that is transferred onto
onto their children.
That is,
that does not exist.
When that person loses the weight speak.
It would be when a person loses the weight.
Yeah.
Though that all those genetic problems go away.
So that did reverse himself that.
Then that raises another question.
If you do have a genetic propensity for whatever it might be,
gambling,
alcoholism.
Yeah,
obesity.
It,
it doesn't mean as a human being,
you can't figure out a way to
game the system so that you don't fall victim to it,
and we have to,
we have to keep that open as a possibility so that my freewill counts for a lot.
It was Rhonda Patrick Send all the fatties in another place,
but it was run a peptic saying that obesity is a,
it's passed down.
Yes.
Oh Wow.
She was saying that the genes that are problematic amongst obese people,
those jeans,
they change when the person loses the weight.
So even if a person has gastric bypass surgery and they lose the way and they
get down to a normal way where they're not obese anymore,
their genes that they express and the way they transfer them to their children,
they will be different.
Meaning the children whose kids have it.
Yes.
Cool.
He's skinny.
I had Al Roker is fine.
I have a friend who's overweight and he has a daughter that's overweight and
it's,
and she's,
you know,
like approaching teenage years.
She's thick and now she's overweight.
She and shuts off and she drinks tons of soda and she eats tons of candy and
he's not a good friend.
He's just a guy that I know.
And um,
it's,
it's weird to watch cause it's like,
well I see where this is going.
He's not educated on nutrition.
No,
no he's not.
He's not a thinker.
He doesn't,
I don't know the guy well enough to the comp.
Obviously I would never comment on,
hey,
you got to treat your fucking kid better.
But I see the kid and I'd see the thing and I'd just like,
Jesus Christ,
this kid's fucked.
Sometimes when they're happy and they're fat though,
I appreciate it.
Cause unhappy.
So it's not a good,
it's just,
it's a,
it's one of those things where,
you know,
if you make choices and then your children see those choices and make those same
choices,
you know,
you're responsible for passing that pattern on and some sort of a way.
And sometimes people don't realize that until someone like Rhonda Patrick says
it.
And one of the things that Rhonda sent me was an email that she had gotten where
someone sent to her.
Um,
this guy that was literally listening to that,
eating some shitty food and put it down and decided there and then to make a
change in his life.
He's like,
I didn't even think that this was going to literally change my jeans that I pass
onto my children.
That's really cool.
Wow,
that's cool.
The more you learn about stuff out of your destiny,
but maybe your children's destiny.
Yeah.
Some people just don't know more.
You're,
you're not just,
you're,
you're literally hamstringing them from birth.
You,
if you're a fat fuck and you have these kids are fat shaming,
you let let it out of the gate,
you know,
and your children from,
from the jump or dealing with all your poor choices and you have to see that
that's going to punish you.
Ma'Am.
A lot of it's education.
A lot of people just didn't know that.
You know,
we used to be like high fiber,
low fat diets.
How you lose weight and people couldn't lose weight.
Then they were like,
try not eating sugar and bread and things that spike your insulin.
Some people who are obese,
are they saying it's maybe a mental weakness or is it a mental illness?
No,
they're saying,
well it's certainly everyone has the ability to do things different.
Like nothing stopping you from just cutting all the bad carbs out,
cutting all the refined sugar,
cutting all the refined carbohydrates,
eating like a very healthy diet and then working out all the time and slowly but
surely losing the weight and becoming healthy.
Nothing is physically stopping you from doing that.
Right?
So what is stopping and,
well,
there's a lot of behavior patterns that people deal,
which is a lot of depression.
There's addiction.
Like what are those mechanisms?
And these are all things that we need to address to,
you can't just say,
hey man,
pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
Cause people don't know how to do it.
How do I get it?
Yeah.
How do they get out of their own way?
They get depressed.
They feel terrible.
They feel maligned by society.
But I don't think helping them.
I don't think you can help them by saying you're fat shaming them by talking
about the fact that being fat is gross.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's just bad for you.
It's going to do it anyway.
Yeah.
The world's going to do it.
Quiet this.
This is my problem with the,
the the,
the side.
It's the right on the left actually on the fringes.
They're way more interested in punishment than they are persuasion.
You know?
I know that we can pass lots of laws.
I know we can have workplace stuff that kind of like makes everybody safer,
quote unquote.
It's just going to suppress behavior.
It's not going to change behavior.
You need to figure out a way,
if you really serious about changing behavior,
appeal to my heart and my mind and my and,
and,
and make it logical.
When you teach me how to eat,
they're the biggest tissue I always find with keeping people motivated is number
one.
They,
they just,
they can get,
you can get pumped up,
you can go to a Tony Robbins seminar and get pumped up and really make a change.
The question is how do you keep inspired day to day?
How do you stay in,
you know,
that comment about inspiration,
that inspiration.
It's like bathing.
It's effective,
but it has to be done regularly.
Yeah.
That's good.
Yes.
I think community and information,
these two are huge and you have to be around like minded people that also want
to do the same thing.
That helps when you're around fucking lazy.
Cons,
who don't want to do shit,
they're always making excuses.
It fucking trips you up.
It's real sad.
So if you have friends that are always making excuses,
you got to,
you got to push them away.
You've got to separate and you just tell him,
hey man,
this is how I feel.
I feel like you're always crying about stuff and you're always thinking,
woe is me and you,
you,
you trip us all up and if you don't get of clown,
he give him the opportunity to see how you see them and if not,
you've got to find other people that are more motivated to improve their life.
Then inflammation and in community and information.
I also include things like this podcast,
any con,
any time people are talking about these things,
uninhibited,
uninterrupted,
and uncensored.
Well,
you get to see the real thoughts that they have and then backed up by
information from people like Rhonda Patrick from scientists,
from peer reviewed studies,
things that you read.
You get a sense of like,
oh,
I'm not alone in this.
Okay.
There's a bunch of other people that are thinking about these issues as well,
like what can we do?
What can I do on a personal level to get past whatever weird shit I'm tripping
up on my life?
How?
Why do I keep smoking cigarettes?
Why do I keep lighten these fucking things up?
How come after work?
I just go for the ice cubes and start pouring scotch.
Why do I do that?
And all these people have to come to grips with this and having a community of
people like I learned a shit load when we did that sober October thing,
man,
I learned a shit load because I don't,
I don't have a drinking problem,
but knowing that I can't drink,
it's like inhibiting myself from that no smoking and then also having these 15
fucking yoga classes that we had to do 90 minute yoga classes in a month.
It was a lot of everything,
but it was also that we were doing it together,
that Burt was doing it.
Tom Is doing it,
art,
he was doing it.
I was doing it.
We're all doing it together.
We fed off of each other and at the end of it when we were all celebrating and
got through it,
I was like,
I learned a lot from this.
I learned a lot from this about the power of community will learn a lot from
this about having things that you have to do,
like there's,
you just have to do.
Those 15 guys are also accountable to the Chubb.
Exactly where if you just try it yourself,
it's going to be tough,
man.
It's tough,
but tough community and information,
those two things are gigantic.
Community is big.
It's the information and education.
There's a difference they'll have that.
Friends are telling me,
I have that friend pulled on and some of them are fucking awesome.
You know this.
If they didn't want,
if they wanted to change and they were bitching about it and they didn't do
anything about it,
then it'd be a problem.
But some people were functional as fat peep and also happy and I celebrate it.
I like that,
you know,
look,
some people are fat and they don't drink,
they don't smoke and they don't eat bad food.
They just eat too much or they eat a lot of pizza or something like that.
And then there's some people that are fat and whine and complain and they're
always depressed.
That's a problem.
And they're not happy,
good at anything.
You know,
this is the other thing,
like got to be fucking good at something,
you know,
have something that you have joy in.
Whether it's a game that you like to play or whether it's a hobby that you
pursue.
I would say a big country has the good kind of fat.
He could give a fuck and he'll knock you out.
But here's the thing with big country have been a world class fighter at 185
pounds.
He wasn't,
he wasn't heavy way.
Weird example but,
but yeah,
but think about that thing.
A big country if you like went on a crazy good diet.
I Dunno because it goes back to fun animal.
It goes back to also the idea that button Matt harness,
part of like his ability to fight,
stay calm,
you know,
perform under pressure might be the fact that he could give a fuck.
Like,
like if you get too controlling about your weight,
you might get too controlling and Matt might be a mindset that you can't divest
from in everything else.
If you get to calculated with everything you're doing and you step in that
octagon,
something goes wrong.
You're not as loose maybe or your mind or your professional or your profession
or your fucking George Saint.
Pierre,
you know what I mean?
It's who's a control that certain certain,
a lot of champions are control freaks to the nth degree.
Lance Armstrong.
Yeah.
I mean he had that shit down to a science.
You read about it and greatest of all time.
So yeah,
it's a,
it's a weird conversation,
right?
It's like where do you draw the line?
Like and what is more important?
Performance or happiness.
Right.
That's a,
that's another thing because sometimes your performance in order to reach the
real peak levels of performance,
especially to maintain it like as a champion,
you're not necessarily going to be happy.
No.
You might be happy and brief moments after you,
when would that be in everything though.
Not just,
just not with whether it all sports,
but even entertainment.
Like if you want to be the top,
top comedian,
you're not going to suffer.
You're going to have,
you're going to have to be selfish and you know,
we do not spend as much time with your family.
You're on the road,
you know,
you're,
you're doing this,
you know?
Yeah.
I think it's with anything there's going to come where if you want to be the tip
of the spear there,
there's going to be some selfishness there.
And here's the other ironic thing that if you do spend too much time away from
friends,
away from family and you won't be as good because you won't be as compelling.
It's like you have to find the balancing act.
You have to find a balancing act where or you won't be like happy.
Like one of the things that I,
the guy I always bring up is Richard Jenny who eventually committed suicide and
I think to this day he's one of the greatest comics of all time.
The guy was fucking completely miserable and he had mental issues,
obviously it mental health issues,
which led him to commit suicide.
How long ago?
2007 Tude if you never,
you're a comic.
You're trying to do stand up.
She got to watch Richard Jeni,
listen,
listen to a big steaming pile of me.
I tell everybody to get it.
It's fucking brilliant.
He is the most underrated of all time and he was miserable.
Yeah,
he's my top 20 all time greatest and he's in there and most people don't know
who George Solar,
what's going on.
Yeah.
Tortured.
He did a lot of plastic surgery.
Allegedly had peck implants at a bunch of shit done to his face.
Yeah.
A lot of shit done.
He'd want it to be Jim Carrey want to be some leading man.
But when a rough July's along the way was,
well this was the thing back in those days in the eighties and nineties
everybody wanted to be a TV star.
They all wanted to be on home improvement.
They wanted to have their own show like Roseanne.
It didn't work out for everybody and he was one of the guys that didn't work out
for it.
But what he did have that he wasn't getting recognition for what some of the
best fucking standup at his standup is so good.
I wasn't enough for him.
It wasn't enough for him.
And why?
I don't know.
I mean dude,
a lot of comics,
especially back then,
it's different now.
It's different now than it was back then.
But the community of comics is so like,
uh,
it's so tight and so welcoming now.
Like we're all used to be.
It used to be way different,
right?
Yeah.
Something happened.
Not a warm,
not a warm group.
Not just that.
Like everybody was like all for themselves.
You know,
like if you went to see a guy on the road,
they usually took some guy with them that sucked and that guy would do like 1520
minutes of Shitty standup and then this person would go out there and look like
a God.
And that was the standard move that everybody did.
Like George Carlin for the longest time,
took this guy on the road with them that didn't work any other places.
And there's a lot of those guys,
they'll,
they'll take a guy that works on the road only with them.
They literally don't even work as a professional outside of opening it for that.
And they'll do this shitty act and then this guy comes on,
it looks like it's just to make him look good,
just to make them look good.
And that was what the standard move was.
And then something happened and I don't know what it is.
I think there's a bunch of factors,
but I think one of the factors that happened was that there was more opportunity
available,
so wasn't this feeling of scarcity
because before when it was just everybody trying to get a network show,
everybody was like,
hey man,
you might be trying for the same part I'm trying for.
I'm a,
I want to be the host of the tonight show.
You want to be the host of night show,
fuck you.
It's all every man for himself.
Your slots are ways to make a living.
Then in the two thousands it opened up and the internet sort of opened up all
these different possibilities and then guys like us realized,
Hey,
I don't really get represented correctly in anything that I do that other people
write.
What I need to do is figure out how to just be myself like like people able to
have this distorted idea of who you are because you hosted fear factor or you
were on mad TV is pool boy or whatever the fuck it is.
Like,
this is how they view you and you hold on,
why did that?
But I also do this and I'm also this person.
And back then you couldn't do that.
It didn't exist before there was the internet.
And before you could actually express yourself completely uncensored.
So I think that that led people to be like much more scarcity minded,
much more famine thinking,
you know,
and famine thinking is the fucking enemy of community.
As soon as you have famine thinking,
especially being created by you,
say that because that is his amazing book.
I just finished.
You should have this guy on your podcast,
Dan Coyle.
Did you send me that as a dam?
You sent me?
It's called the culture code.
He wrote the talent code too.
He's tended highly successful groups.
Seal team six of this,
the seal team,
six,
uh,
fucking,
even jewelry thieves.
So they were like these amazing jewel thieves.
They studied them and they were these guys and they would come in,
they stole from a t in the middle of the day in Tokyo,
$105 million worth of diamonds.
I think they went to Monaco.
Same thing,
stole like $50 million worth of bedrooms and stuff and got away and speedboats
right.
I mean these guys would come in for 40 45 seconds,
come in the bash when and they were like,
holy fuck.
They couldn't figure it out.
They're like,
oh yeah.
I mean they were daring and they would treat the people in the stores roughly,
but they didn't kill anybody,
but they,
and they were strong.
They looked athletic and they were like,
all right,
this is obviously obviously probably our cons.
Tigers from the Serbian war.
They're clearly Serbian krauts special forces guys,
right?
They just,
they were just to organize.
They were like,
like literally,
they wa they move like water.
They do.
They would dress up as women.
They'd say they come in like these beautiful women.
Turns out there are men,
but they look like women.
They're like,
there's no biological difference.
And it come in and they just,
but they get away with,
let me say it again,
$105 million in diamonds at a time.
Crazy shit.
The most successful of all time.
So they're trying to think the,
that they have to constantly stymied by this idea of what the food,
the fuck with these guys.
They've got to be these,
they've got to be a military unit.
Turns out,
Nah,
they sure weren't.
They were middleclass Serbian kids who'd grown up together.
They were all friends.
Some were,
one guy was a,
he studied to be a lawyer.
Another one said it'd
be a journalist,
another one.
These are men and women by the way.
Another one,
uh,
studied,
played basketball,
kind of like first second.
I almost made it pro but didn't,
nothing that remarkable.
Middleclass kids,
they all,
however,
uh,
and there was no leader,
there was no mastermind.
They thought there's gotta be a master.
And I got to find the mastermind.
Odd.
There's always a mastermind that they bring the Jews back to.
No,
not that either.
They were just a loose confederation of friends from three different towns.
I think he would have known each other since childhood.
And they had,
they grown up in the war.
So they,
they had a taste for action and adventure and they,
but they were all close and they would get together and they would plan these,
they would plan out these whole,
you know,
uh,
heists and the way they would do it,
the way they would do it would was,
it was fascinating because there was no boss.
They would just spitball ideas and everybody was safe,
not only to come up with a good idea,
but everybody was also safe to sort of like,
um,
to,
to be wrong.
So,
so they,
they,
he,
he went and found the one guy that every seal team six seal team six is fucking,
who's the one guy?
He said,
I want the one guy that's the baddest of the fucking bad.
I want the guy cause they are,
they are such an effective group.
And um,
and you and I are friends with Andy stone and you know,
they,
we know some guys and everyone was like Dave Cooper.
Dave Cooper is the dude.
He's looking at Hixon Gracie of navy seal.
He's the guy and Oh fuck,
I'm going to find this bad ass,
this who's this?
Frances and Gatto Geno type,
you know,
right?
Shows up.
Guess what?
He's a regular white dude.
Just irregular,
very fit.
But he's a regular dude.
Prep up Dave Cooper for a secondary lever and Dave,
Dave is the kind of guy who would be like,
um,
he's like,
uh,
what do I call you?
He was like,
he's like 20 year like seal team six Dev grew commandos.
He's like,
he's like,
you can call me Dave Cooper.
Fuck face.
It's up to you.
Doctor looks regular.
That guy looks like a fucking eagle.
He has eyes.
You're a salmon.
He's going to swoop down and scoop you out.
A little fucking row should be on that addiction.
Has American man fucking Dave Cooler cause a fucking awesome or cool.
But the way he sold American,
but,
but he was said to these guys and when they would come up with ideas,
very democratic,
very like everybody.
He wants to hear from everybody.
There's no stupid question.
Has Ego doesn't get in the one house.
All that matters is I might be an idiot and wrong.
All that matters is I want results.
That's all it is.
And when you study these highly effective groups and they look like great
basketball teams,
Popovich,
you'd love this.
I didn't know that the at the spurs were the most winning in the past 20 years.
The most winningest team in the past 20 years when we winning it's American team
in past 20 years and it's the same way.
His ability to kind of like,
he's,
I'm fucking,
he's got a foam,
Duncan volcanic temper,
volcanic tit.
Does that mean who's Tim Duncan?
One of the greatest,
greatest of all time.
Mr Fundamentals,
but he
hall of fame,
but he,
as far as his team is because there's a lot to do that it's not a lot of
superstars.
It's also the way they structured the team.
Brendan,
like they've done some studies as far as like,
he has amazing players though.
No doubt.
Yeah.
But he also makes amazing players and how they work together and in fundamentals
and how they work together and how how they communicate,
and that's really the question too.
Like what makes a great team?
Is a great team just having killer individual players or is it having really
good individual players in a killer and environment and they all grow and get
better together?
They've done studies.
I'm like,
you've got to think that a guy who's in the NFL say for his first year,
as long as it doesn't get injured,
if he keeps playing and he keeps hustling and keeps learning,
he's going to be better in two years,
right?
If he doesn't get injured,
NBA is probably better because you don't get injured as much,
but you got to think that these players are going to get better at basketball,
better at competing under pressure and get better at playing together.
They're all going to get better.
These guys were talking about this before in the world.
The,
the,
the Golden State Warriors,
you know the,
they call him a super team,
but they were drafted.
They added Kevin Durant,
which makes them even better.
Who's one of the best players in the league?
Top three.
But before that they had,
they were all drafted,
came up together.
So they play as a team.
Right now they're on unstoppable.
Yeah,
so like a Cleveland or Miami put all these superstars together,
Houston or Okc,
the Golden State Warriors were draft and they came up as a team.
Now they're super cute.
Even like teams,
I don't know a whole lot about teams,
but teams that grow up to that get put together.
They depend upon some sense of community.
Yes.
When that community falls apart,
like remember when Shaq and Kobe beef and it was a real problem,
the real problem because they were playing on the same team and Shaq was doing
raps about Colby.
It was a fucking real problem that kills things because killed things mean it's
somebody has dominion just on who they are over the group.
That becomes a problem because everybody has to share ideas.
This,
the structural engineer,
you heard me talking about this,
a structural engineer and this architect,
he did this amazing study where he took CEOs,
lawyers,
uh,
business students and kindergarteners,
and he said,
okay,
here's the,
uh,
here's the task.
26 pieces of uncooked spaghetti,
a yard of tape,
a yard of string,
and a marshmallow might be one last thing.
I can't remember.
Whoever makes the tallest structure is the one that wins.
Ceos,
lawyers.
The kindergarten kindergarteners figured it out because the way they approached
the problem,
nobody had invisible ideas of authority.
Nobody had sort of this kind of,
I know more than me.
I'm not going to say my thing.
They were like,
and now,
yes,
there,
there's no,
we're all fucking idea.
And there were no,
let me do this.
And they would just fight over the idea,
but it was the best guy.
He's listening to the kindergarten.
The best idea would win.
Be like,
shut up kid.
You're fine.
No,
they were all together.
It was groups of four.
So there are four kindergartners,
but the kindergartens,
the four of them figured it out.
Yeah.
They built a 26 in structure and the second one was the CEO's.
They built a 22 inch ratios are thinking about cocaine and Pussy Bromley,
how their stocks are doing.
There's too distracted and give a fuck.
It's the question of like what makes children learn better?
You know,
I uh,
I watched kids,
obviously I have them and I watched them learn things.
And it's interesting how some kids learn things really quickly and some things
don't or some kids don't.
And how parents just really don't have the ability to learn at the same level
the kids do.
And so I'm like,
well,
what is it?
Is it a physical limitation?
Is it a clarity thing?
Is it an ego thing?
Is it your identity that holds you back?
I think it's the amount of time and energy that you put towards something and
whether or not you're willing to be obsessed by it.
Yes.
And I think that some parents and some people that are adults just do not have
the same kind of time that a nine year old has to think about things all day.
They don't have the same amount of things in their head.
They don't have the same,
they have too many bills and stresses and distractions and things pulling them
away and different angles and they don't have this sense of who they are.
The way of,
uh,
an adult does that sense of who you are can be very limiting.
You can have this decision that you have in your head.
That's what,
that's what it is.
Yeah.
That's a big part of it.
They've done a study on that.
Like there's a huge body of study on how,
what conditions are the most effective to learn it.
I mean they've done a lot of work on this and one of the main things that lends
itself to learning fast and well is just the idea that you're,
you're psychologically safe.
The idea that,
first of all,
there's no shame in making mistakes.
Right?
That's huge.
Can Be afraid to fail.
Yeah,
man.
And you will fail.
But it has to be competition to look.
It has to be,
it has to feel like shit when you do fail.
Cause if it doesn't feel like shit when you fail,
like there's,
there's always the thing on AgLearn you learn when you win,
but you learn more when you lose,
you learn a lot more than I think failing and feeling like shit is important to
re re-energize,
remotivate refocus and then to recognize this is a bad feeling.
I don't like this feeling.
I have to work harder,
truly repercussions to,
you know that's true.
But you need somebody,
if you're a young person,
you need somebody to help you navigate out of that space because don't,
and you're,
you feel like shit and then your shame,
you're told,
usually you're just not as good.
Right?
And it's,
and you're not going to be able to get as good.
What happens is people quit.
Some people though,
some people,
some people don't,
and they dig their heels in and they get stronger demands on the customer.
Depends on the person.
So you need somebody to help you realize,
hey,
hold on.
Learning is a bitch.
Learning as a motherfucker,
don't worry.
This is part of the process.
So let me help you navigate your way out.
So the biggest thing that they always do is make you realize that mistakes are
necessary,
important and just as good at this stage,
they feel like shit.
Of course they do.
They come with all kinds of weird feelings.
Let's stay in this stand,
this,
learn how to stay.
I'm comfortable in this and let's figure out a way to get the fuck out of this
because the real killers,
the real winners,
they're going to be killers in winners in any sort of scenario,
but you can develop more winners if you have a better structure,
a better learning environment,
you'll,
you'll have,
and then also the community will be better.
Yes,
it says we keep coming back to that,
but I think this is God damn gigantic and we're not just talking about community
in the sense of people that know each other like in an one on one individual
basis.
Well,
you guys have done with your podcast is creative community.
I see the community interacting with itself.
I see you guys interacting with your fans,
like you've,
you've made a community of fun,
silly people that get together when they come to see your shuts.
Cause he and our silly yeah,
for sure.
But this is,
this is also community.
This is even people that don't physically know each other,
it becomes a thing,
you know?
And I think that that that is one of the least discussed,
but most important parts of happiness and a part of and most important parts of
developing its community.
Yeah.
Giant.
Yeah,
it is.
And also like learning,
like we had a really good discussion about the podcast and it was funny how I'm
going to Piss when a combat taken up.
I fucked up.
I fucked up today.
I feel like I'm gonna throw up.
I drink so much caffeine.
You know,
last time I shit,
my pants learning is important.
I just talked about cyber and and metal deck.
I like that.
That's the first time outside work.
Hollywood,
he'd get back and bribe you.
Take it.
Fucking take your break.
I want to talk about cyber Holly.
Oh,
what were we talking about?
We were talking,
we were talking about about how,
how,
uh,
when we have an issue that we want to make the podcast better or whatever.
Oh,
and I called you and said you searched on the parts thing you do is take care of
you,
your,
you make sure my feelings are you,
like you take care of my feelings.
I do the same thing with you like we,
why we want to make sure that they'll be like,
hey,
I don't give a fuck.
When we just down,
we got some,
read some research on the podcasts I called Bryce said,
hey,
here's where we get the most listeners.
Here's where people turn it off.
Here's what we do this.
And I feel blank.
I tell Brian this all the time.
I go,
listen,
they might turn off here,
but we didn't create this thing to decide what people like and what don't like.
If you want to do fucking an hour of what you want to do,
we're doing that.
We're,
we're doing what we want to do.
If they like it,
great,
but that's how this thing got to it.
So we're going to do whatever you want to do.
That being said,
he got to quit doing that.
No,
but that being said,
you've got gotta be responsive.
No,
I just told him,
I said,
if you want to do it,
do it down.
But here's the feedback.
We're good.
Yeah.
Be Responsible.
Let's do what you want to do though.
Here's the evidence.
Yeah.
And so if you're not going to be responsible either,
but here's the evidence,
he'd done it again and just keep doing your own thing.
You'll,
you'll peep when I,
when a signal at you,
you'll peep when I signal at you otherwise.
But that's why we've,
we've never had that issue rec out.
We got,
I have to do this.
I asked you and I thought that every single time,
no matter even in fights,
we'll get it fucking tax.
Hey man,
sorry.
I'm a little out of line man,
because all it matters is what works.
I don't give a fuck about being right.
I want to learn.
Um,
I'm you sensei though.
We've established that and now the war,
I'm Rogan put,
but look at me.
Rogan's gun.
Call me road dog or I'm going to kick you in the,
you're not a fucking road.
Dot.
I knew.
Call me,
call me,
call me in a puff.
Broke you're nuts.
I had the fight.
No fight.
Listen to me right now.
How many,
I'm not calling you road dog.
Tommy wrote,
he's a road puppy dog.
Yet comfortable that he sells more tickets in you.
I was going to get to that.
Seems weird now that you ruined my Christmas with that cause he sold out the
Wilbur.
Wow.
Why are you laughing right now?
Sold it out.
Why are you uncomfortable?
You're not a good friend.
You've broken a which you put best friend.
You put a wedge between us.
Now the podcast,
you've ruined a good friend.
I want you to think about this.
This is a real issue,
but well this is white.
Wants to diminish.
You rode puppy.
She's like,
yeah bro.
I went to Dublin,
shot Australia.
Amit,
call me road dog.
You haven't earned that yet.
Call me wrote and you call me Sensei.
When I give you advice I don't like when I say,
Hey,
try this and you go,
it makes me feel comfortable with you on a force that on,
okay.
Sensei [inaudible] Sensei,
you stayed up fuck Caladis for all.
Oh listen,
I've been a comedian for almost 30 years.
I think I'm allowed to talk about that.
We're having,
and I also am a very good friend of Brennan shops.
Correct.
And I don't feel the need to diminish him.
In fact,
I pop them up at every stamp,
every chance I can.
My man,
oh my God,
they do pump them up.
Having a conversation on text the other day where I was telling him how proud I
was of him,
how he hustles and then he's got disciplined.
That's one of the things that holds a lot of comedians back.
They don't have the kind of discipline at this guy is out there doing things a
couple of years into comedy that guys had been doing comedy for 10 15 years.
Can't do.
I know.
Well let's just keep this humorous for a sec.
I'm trying.
I'm trying to mess with,
I'm going to go dark though.
You called me a road dog.
I don't,
I don't want to be called the road dog either.
So I don't know if that's a good thing to want to be called.
And you want to be called a road.
Just a fucking comedian.
Road Wolf have an inner wolf
had me.
I can't control it.
Sometimes it's a cat.
It's going to come out.
It's going to come out sometimes.
Well I didn't call myself wrote anything but then you until you called me a road
pop.
Oh he is another one.
Try to diminish you bro.
Cause trying to hold it against them but you could kill him with your hands and
that makes him uncomfortable.
He's so much funnier though.
So he wins in for an hour.
He's funnier for now.
Does it comedy as well as I do.
Look at it.
Y'all better.
I do.
I do look shop once a day and I do.
It does cross my mind.
I'm always like he could,
he could stifle my life with his hands.
Yeah,
but the,
that part is a given.
But you should be in admiration of what he's doing,
but stand up.
He's hustling.
I'll come on.
Who is his biggest supporter will tell you,
hey,
excuse me.
You're not his biggest support and might be.
I am,
but I'm 100% mother.
I'm 100%
positive.
You're not
100% positive.
You're calling them brode pop and he's a roadblock.
This is,
hey,
this is like my mom and dad fight my room.
You're a fucking coward right now.
Let me ask you this.
Do you ever open up for Brendan anywhere?
Never.
I might be.
I'm opening up for him in the future.
I've got a Gig.
He and I are going for me to actually,
I did open up for you when you did.
You're a standup special.
It's funny.
We can get related to open it up for Brendan on the sneaker.
We can get one of the biggest fucking comics to open for us.
It's pretty cool.
I'm fortunate,
man.
Rogan would actually do that for us.
Yeah.
I really need my open up for you.
It was the first time it opened for anybody in like 29 years.
It's the first time I ever went on stage without anybody going on before me.
I know like you really like that's a hard gig.
Like the opening spot is a little more difficult,
so you gotta like juice the audience up.
You've got to get them.
It's an art.
There's an art form to smoothing them into the show.
I just learned that,
so I bring someone on the road,
but she was like,
hold on,
you're just going out there cold and like,
yeah,
I just do my thing.
He's like,
no,
what the fuck?
Yeah.
Then you do it like some guys like bill Cosby to the end always just went on
stage.
Oh really?
Yeah.
He didn't have an opening act.
Bill Cosby would go on stage for like two fucking hours.
He was a hundred thousand years old.
He would go on stage for two hours with one eyeball and a hello spreads shirt
with a backlog of rape in his hand.
Somehow the fought through that I knew to deliver this family friendly humor,
one of the greatest comics of all.
It's like the most prolific and it goes to your point that you can be more than
one thing.
It can be evil and good,
you know?
I mean,
he was a great classic example.
Damn Dude.
Fuck Dude and no opening act.
Look at that hello friend.
Wow.
On stage like that.
Just with uh,
two hours.
Who knows how many rapes in his memory banks just crushing his self esteem and
sought process and activity.
Had he been been accused when he was doing standup as well?
Here's the crazy,
he,
he'd been accused.
He's blind in one eye and losing his vision in the second on how these very old,
but I think he's also pour it.
No,
he's still alive.
He's still went through the trial.
He did through one trial,
his trial and then their retrying him again.
I think it's,
I want to say it's coming up soon.
That's stress usually kills those look like Joe Paterno.
These that'll break.
Oh my God,
man.
Do you imagine a body of work though?
And then Justin matter,
but that's a TC.
It's what is the human being,
right?
What does it human being capable of and the lowest thing you can do to someone
besides murder them is rape and two drug.
All these women that you took in there,
they were like confiding in you because you're this great master of show
business.
You were Mr Hawks to blink.
You would never believe it.
You wouldn't marry somebody told you,
you'd be like shut up.
No Way.
The earth is flat before a bill Cosby.
That makes it easy.
But don't you think this is a part of what we were talking about earlier is that
the more information that gets out,
the more you understand like the Harvey Weinsteins are the bill Cosby's of the
evil people,
the world that have gotten away with it for so long because the power,
but the more this stuff comes out,
the more we'll have.
We have a more nuanced understanding of what a human being is.
Like Neal Brennan was talking about,
we were talking to the podcast,
we're talking about Louis Ck.
I love him too.
He's great.
And we were talking about like,
do you think that it's possible to be a really great comic?
Not Be fucked up in some way and I was like,
no,
never met one,
never met one.
It might be possible.
I've never seen it.
I think there's something about wanting to crush on stage and figuring out like
how to do it and having those thoughts inside you that people find so humorous,
those crazy impulsive thoughts and those,
you know,
like deeply disturbing thoughts sometimes where you're just scratching the base
layers of your psychology and looking to see what makes it bleed.
You know though,
it's hard to find that place when you're a regular person with a regular
sensibilities and you fit into this,
you know,
normal pattern me and might every now and then get a really funny guy who comes
out of that,
but most of them when you get to know them,
you find some dark shit,
hundred percent artist,
dysfunctional shit or unorthodox trying to fill some hole.
Yeah,
just almost different way of looking at the all is in the outside.
Outsiders outside of fighters as well.
It's the same thing.
I don't know any fighters at somewhere in the back of their head.
Do they not have this,
this one area where like,
oh,
you got this spot.
Most people don't have that spot.
It was like this one area of darkness.
Yes.
You know?
How many human beings do you think could get to the psychological state that
Matt Brown gets into in full combat?
I mean how many,
how many people have more that?
How many people have that level of violence in their head?
In the face of like,
like real world class fighters.
The one thing that I love about Matt Brown is every map Brown fight was a
motherfucking Matt Brown fight and he knew it.
He didn't seem to go in the cage like,
well,
good for chaos.
You see how he got into the cage during his last fight with Diego Sanchez?
He roars.
He,
they open up the cage door and he just fucking throws his backed up
and it's real.
It's not an act like this guy don it at that level and he's lost and he's one,
he said ups and downs.
Never a physically gifted guy.
Not like some insanely fast,
crazy athletics,
just explosive and Ahmad Rawhide and steel cable and it's got a place that Bob
works in accounting and you know it was his wife is fucking our personal trainer
and his kids call him a piece of shit and he takes a Xanax every night.
Rob Doesn't have that place has brain Jamie,
Jamie bring up,
bring up Salma Hayek.
He was my monster too.
Oh yeah.
She says something about Harvey Weinstein.
That's to your point.
Then she say,
so she said,
uh,
it's a one sentence,
but it says everything.
It's the first time we do that.
I want to see Matt Brown roar.
You can't supersede the seat.
I'm going to piggy back on it trying to find it.
Do we need another guy?
He retired.
Yeah,
he knows.
No though.
I talked to him in Boston.
He came to my show in Boston and we actually talked on the phone,
but he was saying,
I don't know man.
He goes,
I mean,
he goes,
I,
I was thinking of retiring,
but now I'm not sure.
It's tough if you're thinking about it to his brother when he smashed Diego
Sanchez with the craziest elbow,
you don't,
oh my God,
it was so crazy.
Here's a thought on that Topo one.
This has been something that's been going on for awhile.
Like when is it okay and when is it not okay to hit the back of the head where
it counts as a Kao,
right?
Like if you do it on the ground,
you can get severely disqualified,
right?
Dqued or points taken away depending on how much damage due to a person.
But if you do it,
stand it up,
whether it's with a head kick,
which a lot of times hits the back of the neck,
it's if it's a movement,
right?
If it's in transition and you hit the elbow,
you're good,
but on the ground it's not.
Here's my point.
Like if someone's squirming on the ground and you throw an elbow and you hit him
in the back of the head,
a lot of times they can take points away,
but isn't there a big difference between doing something on purpose and doing
something in the the heat of the chaos?
Why is it okay standing up and I think it is okay.
I think Matt Blatt Brown's Kao of Diego Sanchez is totally clean,
but I think there's a reality to that back of the head shot that happens with
neck kicks all the time,
all the time.
There's a reality to the effectiveness of that technique that we accept standing
up,
but on the ground we limit that.
I think they're thinking on the ground you have more control of the opponent.
I don't think that's real.
I don't either.
I think guys,
when we set up,
they're bucking and squirming and you're throwing shit and it takes time.
There's movement here while you're throwing.
It's very rare that someone's completely stationary while you're throwing.
They're awesome.
They're also adjusting their,
they're going on a big shrimping.
You're bucking,
you're dropping down.
There's a lot of shit happened in man.
And the idea that somehow or another,
you should be able to control it on the ground when you're actually in physical
contact with someone,
right.
You have to be physically have their body that you're trying to manipulate and
control while they're bucking around.
It's hard versus they don't have any control of your body.
You're standing up,
you're away from them.
And any shot that you landed on the back of the head somehow or another is okay.
It just shows you we have a little more ways to go with evolution of fighting.
Yeah.
I do look at some of the rules and I'm like,
what the fuck?
How do we still have these problems?
Get judging.
I'm like,
God damn helmet.
Could you wear something on the back of your headlight out?
They used to wear those in taekwondo tournament.
They used to give people these,
uh,
you wouldn't help.
There's a transition and taekwondo rules where they started getting ready for
the Olympics,
where they started making people wear actual helmets.
You wore these big foam thing,
me.
But before that you'd have to wear these things in the back of your head.
The video I have it.
There's a video of me wearing one.
The video of me,
I always liked it better cause it didn't fuck with your peripheral vision.
Right.
The idea is you get k owed because we're all,
we were fighting on basketball courts and what guys got Kol?
Who was he?
Video me fight.
Fuck yeah,
I do watch this.
This is me.
I'm the guy with the back to us.
But if you look at my head,
that thing in the back of my head is a raw red foam thing.
It's,
you know,
shitty old VHS.
But there's a Yamaka rubber band that goes across my forehead in this pad is
just to keep my head.
He just fucked that.
Get up.
Yeah.
How old are you there?
I was 19 that was at the u s in Connecticut.
Cc Connecticut on the floor.
Why'd you walk off like dead?
I knew it was a rap.
One of the other guys we shot.
Yeah.
Type one and all the other guys to be scared cause I was terrified.
Fucked up.
Yeah,
that's a good thing.
My move was always to pretend like I didn't give a fuck Kao guys and walk away.
Like it was nothing.
I never celebrate.
Never like it's just another day in the office because it scared the shit out of
me.
So I was tried to be like one of the guys that scared the shit out of me.
What I do.
Yeah.
And then it was what I do.
But I was like this is weird.
I'm like a fraud but I'm not.
I think those guys are like that.
Most buyers are like that.
But those,
those head things were a standard and then they changed it to pat at floor.
They changed the floor.
They used to let you fight.
Why Fun on a hockey rink.
I found him,
the bay state games on concrete,
there was a plastic,
a thin plastic sheet that was over concrete and when the dude's head hit the
mat,
it cut him open cause like I owed him and when I hit him in the wheel kick,
his head bounced off the ground and his eyebrow opened up from contacting the
concrete.
It was so disturbing.
It was like that easily could have been me.
I easily could've got head kicked and my head bounces off the fucking concrete.
That was like practice.
When you go to practice and tackle known,
you knew you were going to spar somebody who's going to get kicked in the head
if they weren't careful when somebody would do the chicken,
like I said,
they would always be a guy once a month would get hit and just it was what you
guys were that had get her.
Now my tier helps.
It definitely helps.
Like it'll protect your head a little bit.
It's definitely better than nothing but getting kicked out because they're
pretty sweet though.
Here's Matt Brown.
When he steps in to fight Diego Sanchez,
he roars the head coach.
Now they're in Denver.
No,
he's definitely one of the top coaches over there.
And didn't they just open up a place here?
Hit,
did they somewhere around self harm?
I think they opened up a place in Burbank.
He's such a fucking animal.
This is what one of my all time favorite.
He just cause I gotta check my Dick.
Cause like,
cause you have a cup on.
He goes yes and taps his own dick.
They get a check his fingernails and watch us steps up to the cage.
Thinks this is his last fight ever walks in
Doug
[inaudible] man,
that roar is a warrior.
So for a guy,
the guy's got this awesome.
Yeah,
he died for um,
a bit overdoing or drug overdose and they brought them back.
Yeah.
But it's like for a guy like that,
that style is just so,
it's so hard.
That's such a hard style.
So crazy.
That's not like a mighty mouse guy.
That's not a,
you know,
just a guy who just grind very skillful,
no doubt about it.
Great timing.
Thing was,
is that,
and we tie was ever,
it's clinch was very good.
His muay Thai is very good,
but his Jujitsu is very good dude.
It's just super underrated.
Really get hit with that is toughness was world plus she's striking in his
ground.
You wouldn't,
you wouldn't say it was world class.
I just feel like fighting.
That's no disrespect.
I'm saying,
you know,
his ground game was at like a Verducci is striking.
Was it like a wonder boy?
He's good at everything.
So do you think specialists besides and toughness?
Yeah,
I'm not throwing shade at Brendan.
Do you think that if you took,
if fighting
was as a profitable,
say as baseball,
basketball,
football,
we'd obviously have very different athletes in the game.
Oh yeah.
But I just wonder like,
I don't know.
Yeah,
I,
I wonder if,
um,
if athleticism plays as big a part in the,
in fighting and it's in the umbrella of fighting as it does in say,
basketball football.
So if I,
you're either making the NFL or the NBA,
you know,
there's a lot to the game of course.
But I feel like athletics and plays a bigger factor.
Like some guys it can be not as athletic and a lot of ways like George Saint
Pierre still be good and fun.
It's still fucking,
wait a minute,
hold on.
What'd you say?
Not Athletic,
George.
George Saint Peter's not that bad.
No,
it's a great athlete.
But now the judge is a bad example.
You want to say a guy like he's a bad example.
Actually,
Nick Diaz,
who was just amazing,
like it's never been knocked out.
And Josh Thomson knocked him out.
Yeah,
yeah.
He had kicked him style.
It was all before the Hoffeld dos Anjos fight.
He lost the dose on Joel's after that.
And then after that he's the only one Michael Johnson.
And then after that he comments the x factor with fighting.
Where were guys who are not as fast,
not as strong man is what they can't tell him,
say not as all that other stuff.
Somehow are able to close that distance.
Let me rephrase that.
Nate got stopped by Josh Thompson.
Never went unconscious.
He went to kid rock killed by Nick [inaudible].
Nick.
Oh No,
Nick's never been.
No,
no,
no.
Nick got stopped early on in his career by that guy who did tough.
Who wound up Jeremy?
Jeremy Stephens?
No,
Jeremy Jones.
Is that his name?
He was a young guy that was really talented and nick and him both fought when
they were both like 18 or 19 and nick got stopped by him.
He TK,
TK,
no,
never loads and he's flat line and he's,
he's fought the best of the best,
the best,
but that guy was super talented.
Yeah,
that guy was super talented but then went to jail,
went to jail for some shit.
I think fighting requires a different skillset but when you get a guy who has
that warrior spirit who's athletic,
yeah.
Then you have problems like the Francis and gun.
Right or you know or like have it all in mighty mouse,
Calvin gas,
Conor McGregor.
Yet you get these guys who were,
could probably play other sports like Conor McGregor in there as an athlete in
terms like God really fuck disability to perform under pressure's undeniable and
that that is a lot of what I feel that this is a mess.
It's movements.
Fantastic.
It was body to lot of what athleticism is,
is effective use of that body.
Like you can't deny that a guy who was a world class fighter is also a great
athlete.
There's just no room for that anymore.
Everybody who's at the top of the food chain is a great athlete.
Obviously Francis is an outlier because he's such an obviously amazing athlete.
I think Thomas is an outlier to the,
we can go backwards and reaction time,
but he's a fucking outlier outline.
Think about also Woodley's ability to hurt Wonderboy in the two fights that he
had put Wonderboy and more trouble than he's ever been.
That we've seen them in sight except for Matt Brown who stopped him cause he
stopped when we did beat him in a decision.
I think he'd beat him on decision,
but beat the shit out of them for three rounds.
Let's look at a guy like Darren till the Kelp Bagan athletic until ethic.
He's a big boy.
I'm sure.
Yeah,
there's a lot of guys,
but there's two different weight classes but I,
different weight classes,
but I think he's about 25.
Good.
Luke.
Luke can fight it to a five if you want it to.
Yeah,
but um,
I think the day and age you're always going to have those guys in.
This isn't a knock,
but those Leonard Garcia is with Matt browns.
You're going to have those guys.
But the evolution of the UFC and mixed martial arts,
those guys are going to slowly fades away.
You can get better athletes and just being tough.
Is it going to get you in the top 10 anymore?
I think you're going to get guys who,
they have the fighter's mentality,
but they're the super athletes and that's the evolution of the sport both cause
you get like a Roy MacDonald,
really good athlete,
a fucking monster at everything and he,
you know,
he has,
he can do both.
What do you think of that Lima fight that's coming up that's not qualified?
20th Yup.
That's great.
We're going to be in Boston.
That's the same night as the a in Ghana.
Fight a fight.
They're going head to head and head to head.
I think Shalan rampage is on that to your dvrs.
Ready folks?
Can we talk a little bit about home sidebar,
Battle of the greatest woman fighter of all time?
I think everyone's up but is,
but is that the case?
Right?
Because Meesha beats sidebar or Meesha beat Holly never fought Cyborg,
but the way she beat Holly was so fucking spectacular.
How do you not always rank Meesha above Holly?
I know Misha,
it retired and Holly is still super active and likely should have been 145 pound
champion.
Especially if you take away the deductions,
right enemy,
she should have gotten some bullshit for too late shots.
And then even on top of that,
you still see like Holly dropped her with a head kick and then dropped him with
a left hand as well.
How he was also beating Misha in that fight before she was.
But those two rounds where she got dominated to here's my one round mounted and
couldn't do shit about it.
And then the last 15 seconds is a fine.
Misha pulls out the ultimate,
takes her down,
takes her back and it chokes her to sleep for the best for sure.
But if we're going to play that game,
then Holly,
Merck,
the girl who Meesha could never even hold a candle.
Ronda Rousey.
That's true.
But don't you think that Misha kept getting better and that the Meesha who
fought,
I think the Meesha that fought against Holly Holm was very much an improved
version of the Meesha that fought against Rhonda.
But that me shut,
right?
She,
her whole thing is grappling.
Yeah.
So it try implementing that game plan that gets Rhonda grappling.
Enjoy that.
[inaudible] stand up as one of the reasons why she was good.
She got better than she did in the early Rhonda.
Rhonda.
She did so did Rhonda.
Yeah,
she might.
She might take step back.
But here's my problem event.
You got to look at Amanda Nunez,
Amanda Nunez,
Pete the shit out of the both of them.
And the way she did it was like,
yeah,
points her cry.
The way she throws like those warm of Bang Bang on.
She's yes,
she's a mandating as is.
Yikes.
And I wish you got more promotional.
Push just hammers at.
She's,
if Holly Holm,
we're able to pull off this upset.
She's number one for me.
Beating Ronda and her prime beaten Cyborg in a private Cyborg is fucking scary,
man.
She be lies.
Cyborg is always be lined.
Everybody,
she just comes straight in and puts so much pressure on you.
Last fight,
Tanya,
if she went,
you know what,
here's my [inaudible] just going to murder this girl.
Watch them stick behind the Jab.
I'm gonna figure some things out.
It doesn't show Holly has a way better chance because if she does that with
Holly where she says I'm,
cause I think she's got,
she's,
she's been training.
I mean I think it's almost like she's been training with somebody different.
So take your time.
Step back.
Best Bucklin coaching.
That's actually,
that actually favors Holly I think.
Then her old style,
which is to come in close Batali that if she booked comes at Holly lights'll
like Rhonda did.
Yeah,
he kicked in the face.
That's different.
There was no with with Cyborg is she?
She's so strong.
She's,
you know,
covers off.
She's calculate.
Here's the other x factor.
If cyber goes,
uh,
Holly kind of sucks on the ground.
I'm a black belt on the ground.
I also can grapple like a motherfucker.
I'm not just going to stand and stretch.
Give you,
I'm going to take you there.
And she's a naturally larger woman.
She's way bigger.
So she gets against the get paid an hour tees issues been trying on pick Tito
Ortiz up.
Yeah.
Is She black now?
She's like,
yeah,
and she's competed as a brown belt.
I know she did very well and some high level competition.
She's a big woman.
Her and Debbie Garcia.
Go add it.
Grappling.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
and if she decides any partner,
she decides to go on me should tape footage.
Yes.
And see how easy Nisha Choke Talia Cardone.
That's in her back pocket and she goes,
all right,
I'm the feet.
Let's get a little tricky.
I'm going to grapple shirt.
She has a hard time making 45 right?
Yes,
she does.
Yeah.
She would be better off if there's a 155 pound woman's weight class.
She didn't have to cut so much weight.
Yeah.
I mean she's leaned out.
She looks leaner now that she did when she was fighting in Strikeforce.
You know,
I think when she fought like Gina Carano,
she was fucking gigantic.
She's much smaller now.
It's such a good fight though.
But she's still,
she's still a destroyer.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like,
I think for a lot of fighters I feel like she's finally got to it where she,
she deserves this.
But she definitely deserves this big high profile fight.
But so does Holly,
you know,
they both do.
This is a really interesting fight because like clearly Holly's dangerous,
right?
She head kicks,
Rhonda knocks her out,
she head kicks Batchko hey on knocked her out.
She had kicked Germane to random,
he was a multiple time world Moitai champion head kicks her drops her and a lot
of people thought she should have got that decision.
At the very least it was super fucking close and Jermaine's one of the best
strikers in the world.
She's a,
she's a nasty strikes.
So then if Holly and Cyborg just strike who gets the edge?
Well it see that.
Here's the thing,
like you can't sleep on Holly,
like she's probably got a disadvantage when it comes to punching power.
And probably a significant mean we won't,
we really know.
Cause Holly has dropped people and she does have sharp punches and she's an 18
time world women's boxing champion.
I mean she's,
there's a lot of craziness to what Holly was able to do as a,
as a striker with her hands.
Holly's more decorated.
It's our street striking cyber hits.
She hits so fucking hard and she's so aggressive.
Did you,
did you see a Cyborg,
uh,
going against the gold medalist in the female box on the ward?
I think Clarissa shields that is,
that is her name.
Yeah.
Did you see him?
You send me that footage.
It's amazing you sit that Manet.
I mean,
Claressa shields is no joke.
No,
she's up Beth buses.
You bring that up.
It's crazy.
It's fun to watch too because you realize,
okay,
well she can hang in the pocket.
She takes a tremendous shot.
If you really want to be impressed by Cyborg,
I say you look at her one Moitai loss to Juliana.
I didn't cars.
Yeah,
she's in Bellator kickboxing now.
Zarina Bart is a monster.
She's this really tall woman from Holland who's got outstanding technique and
she was haunted.
Nobody was fucking with her.
She couldn't get a fight for years.
So she's given her some coaching here.
So,
so cyborg decided to fight that Moy Tai Monster and it went to a decision.
Cyborg landed some good shots.
Yeah.
Not only did it go to a decision to,
I'm working on a new tattoos on her legs.
No,
that's tape.
That's like uh,
uh,
performance tape on the top and oh wow.
How weird.
It's all criss crossing.
Yeah,
it's a shitty video.
Huh?
Um,
it's awful video.
But you cyborg got dropped a bunch of times,
kept getting up,
you know,
came after her and was there for the fucking final bells to swing and trying to
take her out.
Thai girl had had her hands full,
going to walk in the park.
It was not a walk in the pauses specialist.
And she's so good during the bar.
Watch her fight.
She's so good.
So here's a cyborg sparring with look how good this girl is,
but look,
sideboard and that she's hanging in there.
Yeah.
She goes to the head of the doing work though.
She is,
she's so good man.
But the,
these girls are going at it.
This is not like a light sparring session.
This is almost like a fight,
you know?
And she's got to be careful because Cyborg has big fucking power.
So she's treating this like this is a dangerous fight for her.
Look,
she's landing these shots,
but she's realizing like that stuff that's coming her way,
she can't take one of those on the point of the chin.
No,
she's getting tagged.
Look at this sidewalk tagged a couple times,
but she's clearly like the more polished professional boxer.
I'm a Cyborg.
It's doing work.
Does she?
Is she is doing,
you're not like a left hook to the body.
It's,
Ooh,
that's step in left hook to the body.
Oh that's pretty,
she's so good.
It's so important for a girl like her to get that kind of sparring it into hell.
Yeah.
I mean who the fuck wants to spar with Cyborg?
Oh one came about cyber stalking about Nolan would spar with her.
So this girl was like,
I'll do it.
Wow.
Let her kick Ya.
I gotta say that I got arrested.
That muy Thai fight with that was it close?
It was a,
it was a clear unanimous decision,
but it was dangerous at every turn.
Yeah.
And also that woman doesn't,
that's her thing.
Have more respect for cyber.
You have to watch it.
She wasn't gonna win,
but she fucking did work.
She got head kicked with a stomp.
She got like front push kick to the face like right on the chin or the next snap
back.
She falls down,
she gets up and you still chasing after she's a warrior man.
She's a fucking warrior.
But so's Holly.
Holly just comes off like cleaner and like,
you know,
she comes off like more polished and she's very pretty and it's very,
she's very calm and very kind and nice to hear her talk.
I think we're a female.
Fighting's add that,
you know,
it's such a high level now with these two that whoever wins this is the best of
all time.
I think it's the forefront of the feminist movement.
Boom,
boom,
boom.
No pressure ladies.
No worries.
Um,
it's,
it's a very important fight for the sport,
that's for sure.
You know,
because no one really out there,
who in my mind is compelling,
is willing to step in and challenge cyborg other than Holly will they still
gonna fight like Andre Arlovski,
frank mayor back in the day,
there's no one or Tim Silvia Beltour who's who would,
who would do work and it's a good point.
Good question.
Email.
I don't think they're at the same level yet in the female division,
but there's some real good talent there.
It's,
there's some good female talent in MMA period,
right?
Rose yachting,
Nama,
Jameson Yawning and jack that,
that,
that rematch is going to be sick.
Yeah,
that's an interesting rematch.
You gotta throw up.
I'm getting close.
Really?
Yeah.
I didn't eat all day and I drink all this caffeine really swallow and spit and
so then I bought a garbage can.
I know you got to get this little sick.
I just go throw it.
Throw up like a Chai Mike.
Man.
I might purge.
Just go deer stick.
Yeah,
that a no,
that doesn't help,
right?
Don't you want pork chops and a cigar?
I'm feeling,
I'm feeling nauseous.
Have a couple of pork chops and smoke a cigar.
He will be fine.
How about sausage sub would extra mustard gas.
I got the call my breath.
Hmm.
Um,
despite is important man,
it's important for the sport,
right?
It's important to figure out what,
what style you need to beat Cyborg.
Like Tanya have injured,
just fought a wild sort of brawling style and that like very limited success.
But it was like one of those things where Cyborg just keeps advancing and in
every exchange,
every time she's so much more firepower.
But Evan jurists,
you know,
she was trying to win that fight.
As tough as they go.
Yeah.
She was trying to win that fight.
This is a different fight cause Holly is very dangerous and she has a weird
style.
She'll fight karate style.
She throws sidekicks,
a lot of front leg sidekicks.
She throws those,
those oblique kicks to the inner thigh.
And here's the thing,
Holly might be going to go to the bathroom,
go to the bathroom.
Yeah,
you've finished this weird.
This is weird.
It's going to start eating in the morning.
He's trying to fast.
He's doing some fascinating married.
He's really gonna throw up.
He's going to throw up man.
I wanted to get that on camera.
No,
that's not right.
That's not right.
It did it did that shut the whole loop playing on a loop.
Yeah.
No people right now,
bro.
What the fuck did you let them puke?
He'll do that.
He'll just not eat like we'll do podcasts.
He's like,
I haven't eat.
You haven't eaten yet.
I don't want to smell it.
I don't want him to throw up in that garbage can eat carbs can,
yeah.
That's not the move.
And it's a bunch of stuff in that can too.
It's like all bile to try blah.
You know what I ate last night today?
I made elk tar tar.
Really?
Uh,
so good.
Fuck you make a good.
So good.
Make a good game meat.
Yeah,
I get good at it.
Now.
Need a little,
um,
need a little game meat from,
I've got a shit ton.
I need to,
yeah,
I got some here for you.
Eight and maybe,
I mean,
I love that you give me the hammer.
Can I get some I gave you,
I'll give you a heart,
dude.
That is the best part is delicious.
I gave you one of the Elkhart's.
I know this isn't,
no,
I'm never,
ever given anyone a Elkhart the fuck out of it.
You can have some stakes,
bro.
You just can't have all of them greedy bitch.
You gotta go out and kill your own food.
Yeah.
But you won't invite me.
Ah,
that's not the tram of 60 pound,
but what I want to do is,
yeah,
well let's do that.
But you're only doing archery,
right?
Pretty.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
So I got to get good with our trade before I can come.
That's a boy.
That's a hard one.
That's a weird learn on the job.
One shooting arrows at animals.
You've got to be completely obsessed with doing that.
Yeah.
You've got a um,
or not,
you know,
honestly,
the reality is rifle is more,
it's more affective.
Like you,
we'll shoot more things with a rifle.
You don't have to get as close.
They're not going to move while you're shooting a rifle and you bring up yeah.
For sure.
Yeah.
If you're in an area that allows both things.
It depends on where you're going.
Cause I know I have to get an elk.
Yeah.
Seeing what else they have specific seasons or you're allowed to.
Um,
most of the time during the Rut you have to use archery equipment in most
places.
Some places have different,
there's like some,
some different,
let you use all weapons and some,
they have some special tags,
but like during the rot,
when they're breeding,
the idea is that it's easy to find them.
They're all,
they're all howling and making those Elk Lake Wales and they're distracted by
pussy and to get close enough to shoot him with a bow and Arrow way more
difficult cause you could just purchase yourself on a fucking,
you know,
a nice tree stump and let that site just settle perfectly on it.
If you have a rifle and just,
but boom and they're dead,
they're dead.
As soon as you pull the trigger or as a bow and Arrow,
you really should be getting inside of 40 yards if you can.
Hard.
Right.
It's very hard.
Smell.
Smell you like crazy.
They see your movement.
They're constantly tuned in and turned on and you have to fight off the fact
that there's like if a bull elk,
you're trying to shoot a bull elk,
you might have 30 cows that are around that bull elk.
You gotta trick them to.
Oh Shit.
Yeah.
You got 30 sets of eyes,
60 eyeballs looking at your way and they bark.
You throw up a little green under the gills boys.
You really puke.
Yeah,
I did.
Did you want some water or something?
No,
I'm good now,
man.
Damn son.
Ah,
that's weird.
Withdrawals from the heroin do.
What do you wish it was?
The head.
The Pale.
I know I do.
I need to hear us a little messy.
I know.
I looked in the math that you don't,
you look like shit man.
How much caffeine did you drink?
Well,
I had a,
uh,
a latte with an extra shot on the way here,
that three cups this morning.
But then I drank this thing who never stopped drinking.
He drank the caveman and then you drank that.
Other than that I can't get the French press and I haven't eaten today cause I
fast in the morning.
That's a lot of caffeine.
Does you go crazy for Christmas?
No,
no I didn't.
I shouldn't cheat on Christmas.
What are you saying?
Are you saying that he's like a,
he's got a weight issue.
He,
he tends to um,
been,
no I don't.
I've been super strict.
I haven't cheated since a thanksgiving.
Secretly.
Sometimes we'll go crazy on not when I'm striking like this Quito kid is back
bitch.
Wow.
Kio Kid is back.
I'm back.
I didn't mean to cut you bitch.
I'm sorry.
How the males,
the pizza and you tried pescatarian for a while.
How did that go?
Nah,
Quito is the only thing that works for me.
It's not for everyone but Kido works for me.
But is it work for you in terms of the way you feel or way?
I feel,
yeah,
the way I feel.
It's easier to stick to,
but the way I feel when I'm on it,
I don't want to cheat.
I don't want carbs.
I don't want that food anymore.
So I'm good.
I go between Kido and low carb.
Yeah.
And then occasionally I'll fuck off and have like a Pastrami sub.
I call that Quito Ish.
I do a thing where I go through whole foods and Erewhon and if I'll look at
people and I try to,
I try to spot the vegans.
Ah.
And I,
this is so me and they live glasses.
Boy,
when I see,
uh,
somebody super pale and drawn out and they just look sunken in,
I'll look in their cart and that's it.
Right now they've got oats and some seaweed and it's just all vegan stuff.
And while I was like,
you could use a little protein.
Wow.
This really is just some people who are just doing it.
Yeah.
That's really what it
is.
You can do it right,
but it's just like Quito,
like it requires a lot of thinking and planning.
Like in order to,
I've,
I've seen people argued online,
so stu,
but nobody ever gets to ketosis.
Bullshit.
Of course they do.
Stupid.
It's measurable.
People do it and they find benefit to it.
Some people don't find benefit to it though.
It's,
but it's important to point out,
it's not hard to get into a state of ketosis.
You just have to do what's required.
Yeah,
it can be done.
It's not difficult to get to.
And the idea that nobody gets there is just so wrong.
People get there all the time.
It's a matter of whether or not getting there.
It will be good for you.
I'll have people email me or on social media like,
dude,
Kiddo is stupid man.
You can't,
you can't do that for a long time.
It's not for me.
I'm like,
man,
I don't give a fuck it just from Pennside.
Dom D'agostino has been on it forever and he's been on it forever.
But Rhonda Patrick was on the other day and she was pointing out how with some
people it's not the right diet for your boss.
For me it probably doesn't.
I,
I'd stopped.
Uh,
I read that book,
the plant paradox and I,
I've told this before,
but I stopped eating bread and those whole wheat things and all the things he
talks about.
He,
he,
he's more of about plant based Guy,
but it did cure my plaque psoriasis up until yesterday cause I started eating
right again.
But it cures Siva pitch,
cured my plaque psoriasis and got rid of it.
It's that and be all,
but it's just,
it works for me depending on what you eat,
fuck what diet you do.
That's what is what works.
Yeah.
I'm eating real low carb or Kido.
Yes.
That's all it is.
It's either I'm Quito or every now and then I'll,
I'll definitely,
I'll feel it when I get off of it.
What do you mean?
That shovels?
Yeah,
a lot of vegetables but low carbon terms of no refined bullshit,
no flour.
And when I get into those states,
I know when I'm have,
when I have too much fruit because then I'll start craving it.
I'll start like craving carbs,
whereas I can tell,
I mean I have tested myself a few times,
but it's annoying to stick that fucking thing in your hand and extract the blood
and put it on the tab.
But you can feel when you're in that state of Ketosis,
like I'll monitor my diet real steady for five,
six days and sometimes it'll be like a little dip because I've done it so many
times.
It's not as noticeable.
It'd be a little dip and your energy during your workouts.
But then when I come on the other side of it,
then as soon as I feel like no hunger pangs during the day at all,
like I'm good.
And then I went,
oh,
okay,
I'm in,
I feel.
And then Gigi,
can you eat sweet potatoes?
You can but you can't eat too much.
Like sweet potato has a lot of fiber in it.
It's one of the reasons why it's one of the better potatoes for you to eat.
It's got a lot of vitamins and yams and sweet potatoes are fantastic for you.
Yeah,
but it's like how much of your are you taking it?
And how much actual sugar does your body,
you have to process.
It was just a small portion of it.
I'm sure it's fine if your overall meals are filled with like really healthy
food,
Avocados,
healthy fats,
you know,
good solid protein with no bullshit and no wheat.
Like
just keep the fuck away from wheat,
keep the fuck away from pasta or don't you know every now and then have it.
But if you could just get your most of your diet free of that Shit,
you'll just feel better.
It just feel better because you ate too many mashed potatoes or sweet potatoes
and got to,
you got to out of Ketosis.
As long as you're not eating a bullshit.
I don't even think that's bad.
I mean,
maybe your body will have more of an insulin response,
but I mean you're having all that fiber with your sugar.
If you're eating a yam or a mashed potato or a sweet potato,
it's not,
it's not like eating candy.
A lot of it's depends on your activity level,
your show.
Yeah.
That's a big one factor.
That's a big one as post workout.
Like how many people work out like you did when you were fighting?
How many fucking human beings know what it's like to put in those hard two a
days and just be almost no one fried four weeks into camp?
Realize you've got two to go and speak to it,
man.
Speak to,
there's nothing.
Where's you're nauseous.
Speak to them in the my coach Tony Jeffrey to you,
he gets it.
He was an Olympic boxer and bucks a professional.
He'd go,
yeah,
you're three weeks in you.
You have four more weeks of this Brendan,
let's get to work this fucking me.
Oh my God.
That's why a guy like you has to like keep an eye on is an appetite after you
get out of fighting.
Yes,
because you're not broken down like that all day anymore where you could just
fuck and shovel it in people.
Let her have fun.
Any,
anytime you're doing anything that's super difficult and you're working out
twice in a day,
man,
you're going to be hungry all the time and your body gets into that space
because even back then I wish I was more knowledgeable on diet and stuff like
that.
I hired some nutritionist but it never really clicked with anyone.
But I have more knowledge now on
Oh Jesus Christ and all syrup almost through.
I just threw up in my mouth.
It's all good though.
Back to the Taquito Diet.
So,
um,
I have more knowledge now.
You say Taquito Diet.
Diet.
I'm fun.
I'm struggle city.
I just wrote in my mouth,
my breath smells like fucking throw up anyways.
Um,
I wish I had more knowledge back then when I was fighting on diet and stuff
cause I did it.
I've talked to people,
I try to figure it out and like,
you're burning so many calories,
eat whatever you want.
I'm like,
God,
I don't think that's the right answer.
When I played at University of Colorado and I would ask nutrition.
I'm like,
man,
I feel like this yogurt you've given us some gated,
it has so much fucking sugar that she goes,
you're fine.
You're going to burn it off.
I'm like,
I,
this doesn't seem right to me,
man.
Yes.
I look at everyone's bodies.
We look like shit that that is true,
but you,
you definitely have different requirements than a person who doesn't do the kind
of working out that well.
Your body will burn a certain amount of sugar and a certain amount,
especially when it comes to fruits or anything complex hundred percent but I get
it burn more than know it.
You're burning those calories.
You can put good fuel in and still get calories.
You don't have to get it from cheeseburgers and candy.
You can get it through high quality foods.
Even still bored.
I'm saying getting at is in terms of like overall performance,
if you want to do it perfectly,
I don't know if Kido is the way to go for like a fighter.
I think the the strains and requirements in your body in terms of like the
amount of fuel your body needs to burn.
There's an argument that especially for a lot of people,
not for everybody,
but for a lot of people having more carbohydrates in your diet then is required
to stay in a state of Ketosis or did I talk to,
I want to say Lance Palmer.
I silence if I'm off on this.
Lance told me one of the fighters have had on my show goes man,
for the last three or the three weeks before my fight,
he has to make weight.
He goes,
I go Kido and I make you wait easily.
I've never felt better.
Yeah,
Brian Caraway said that to Brian Caraway or talked to him,
so I did that for me.
Might be Lance Palmer might be,
well,
you look,
everybody's body responds differently.
That's another problem.
Everybody's,
her body responds,
responds differently.
[inaudible] people ask me that too.
This is what I do,
man.
I don't know if it's free.
This say for me when I'm on the road,
I can find Keto meals,
meals.
When I go to a steakhouse,
it's easy.
It's super easy for me.
Medicine.
I mean,
medicine is that way now.
Sure.
That's why they,
they give you pointed targeted therapy.
They've got to see what your genome is.
I always bring up you and your mom when you talk about Brazil nuts.
Okay.
Your mom can't eat Brazil nuts.
You could brush your skin with them.
It was crazy.
And she would break out.
Yeah.
That's fucking your mommy's called those death.
I forget Brazil nuts is those.
She always calling out of all the things to be allergic to the wackiest nut of
them.
All the shittiest tasting stupid.
Not like when you get one of those things of mixed nuts,
you get those Brazil nuts,
nuts.
Throw that big slop.
Toes.
Yeah.
Am I?
Yeah,
they do.
Oh,
that's what she calls us.
Just so we call it something else.
Slot toes.
Right.
They look like slot though.
Maybe I just made that up now if it is what it looks like,
I'm sick,
but Brazil,
Brazil nuts.
Like I,
I heard that they're good.
They good for sports and for your liver or some bullshit.
But I do get all brides decides to start chopping them up six,
seven at a time,
putting him in Mashiach.
That's all good problem is I inherited a little of the old,
uh,
allergic stuff.
Now when you are allergic and you keep eating something,
you'll develop more and more of a reaction with less.
So I would notice that all of a sudden,
periodically I'd like,
my throat would be sore.
It just be swollen and sore.
And I was like,
what the fuck is going?
I'm not sick but my throat.
And then,
then,
uh,
my entire mouth,
what one point swelled up and like,
it looked like my roof of my mouth had been burned and I,
and my dentist goes,
did you burn the entire roof of your mouth?
I went,
no.
And he goes,
your mouth,
it looks like it's been burned.
Like somebody stuck a thing.
And I go,
yeah,
it's,
it's killing me.
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
He goes,
you're allergic to something.
I said,
no,
I'm not allergic.
He goes,
are you eating a nut that you might be alerted to?
When I say ah,
and so I was developing very quickly as a while ago.
That's insane.
Yeah.
Have you ever heard of the lone star tick and that it gives people red meat
allergy?
I have.
I listened to a radio lab and I'll figure it out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's some,
some fucking town.
Yeah.
The tick is becoming less and less rare.
That's what's really a tick borne.
Diseases are fucking horrifying.
There are so many people out there that are suffering from chronic,
you know,
they don't care.
They don't catch it quick enough.
They don't get the antibiotics and their system quick enough.
And I know somebody who has that.
My friend Shandra,
her dad got a a shot for Lyme disease.
They used to give you a vaccination and he caught Lyme disease from the
vaccination.
They don't do that vaccination.
Fuck man.
There's no way to cure it,
right?
Well,
they're just massive amounts of tetracycline and,
but everybody's result is different.
Some people catch it too late and it's like chronic.
Jimmy Burke had a tuberculosis.
We called him watching me.
She don't know about that.
When did he have that?
[inaudible] has got it.
They thought for six months he or I was about three months.
They thought he had the disease that killed Bernie Mac and they thought he had
that,
had that or lung cancer.
And I'm with Jimmy,
he's walking around with a machine that's training as lungs.
Okay.
They couldn't figure it out.
What does it hook up through his mouth?
Uh,
I think the thing to his chest says,
10 years ago I was walking around in the hospital and uh,
and that was what he was looking at.
So I fly to New York because my fucking brother,
right?
I fly them in New York.
I'm like,
dude,
I go,
you know,
you have other,
have the,
the thing that turns your lungs to sand or two or lung cancer.
And he goes,
that's what they're telling me about.
And we're talking and he's hanging out with him.
And I go,
how the fuck are you not in crisis right now?
And he goes,
dude,
I made,
I made peace with my death so fucking long ago that if I'm going to go like
this,
everybody's laughing and my funeral better be a fucking party.
Anyway,
long story short,
they come in and they've,
they've of course guests,
guests who falls in love with him.
All the doctors cause this Jimmy Burke,
alright.
All the fucking doctors and they fall over them.
And when they found out that he had tuberculosis on the outside of Islam,
it wasn't on the inside,
which was really weird.
He had on the outside,
got it from probably from his grandfather who he hadn't been exposed to when he
was three,
four years old.
Whoa.
When honest.
Yeah.
When he was,
when he was done at do for tuberculosis.
So with tuberculosis,
they give you nine months of antibiotics and what that did to Jimmy of who,
what that did to Jimmy is itchy asshole.
No,
not just that.
It made him colorblind.
So he can't see certain colors.
Oh yeah,
the antibiotic.
Yeah.
Nobody healthier by the way.
But he went through some shit.
The way he handled that was amazing.
This.
He's still colorblind.
Oh yeah,
it it from antibiotic.
Yes sir.
It changed his,
changed his body a little bit too.
He wasn't as muscular.
I think he lost some weight bro.
You ever take antibiotics?
Make you asshole?
Which like the ring of your athletes,
you know?
Oh,
I want to take off.
It doesn't make the ring of my asshole itch.
It's one of the,
it's one of the side effects not to brick TB like that,
that that fucking not nine months where he was,
dude,
he was on the staff.
I've got staff once and I remember,
I remember that,
but I got it once and I took the antibiotics and we went out to dinner.
You and me and Patty Jenkins and you couldn't drink and not only could I not
drink,
my head felt like I had like a led helmet sitting on my head.
I was like,
I can't believe how shitty I feel.
I feel so weak and so shitty and I just gotten on him.
I was only on him for a couple of days and I remember thinking like,
wow,
how could anybody fight on that?
How about guys fight with them?
They're crazy.
It drains you so bad.
I didn't train obviously because I had staff.
I didn't want to give it to anybody,
but I did try to use some weights and do some working out.
It was useless.
I'll try to hit the bag.
Use Lists.
That's what's crazy.
When you find those slides like yeah,
he won that fight and he was on the antibiotic choice.
Yeah.
Fuck fucking Kevin Lee,
when he fought,
when he fought against Tony Ferguson and I looked at his chest the moment he
walked into the cage and they're like,
that it staff or you can see it's Boucher.
DDF staff.
He was on antibiotics.
No way,
cause I didn't come here to tap.
That's sluggish.
She's like,
Oh,
I was on antibiotics the whole time.
That's insane.
You could see Shasha on antibiotics.
Holy.
She could see the Kevin Lee had a staff,
hundred percent extra.
He had his,
he had a giant Welt on his chest and I pointed it out to Daniel.
I pointed out like it wasn't look like staffing supplier is.
Someone in in Daniel's ears were saying,
do not talk about it,
do not talk about it.
And he's like,
yeah,
that looks like staff to me.
Right when you said it,
I was like,
Oh shit.
I hope Joe's right man.
Oh No,
I'm right.
Oh,
there's no way that could be anything.
It was swollen like something either happened,
like maybe he got burnt callbacks,
states check can,
I haven't heard anything.
You think you'd be taking a break?
You know the drawing board is coach comen.
How's Robert Falls?
Yeah,
it was his coach.
That's a bummer.
Robert Falls is a great guy.
I didn't know he committed suicide up yet.
I knew that he died.
I was,
wait,
I heard that there had been a rumor about that,
but it wasn't about her suicide.
This brother committed suicide as well.
Uh,
yes.
Fuck.
They're poor parents.
He was a really,
really nice guy.
Very smart guy too.
Very smart guy.
That's such a bummer man.
You know,
and who knows what,
what causes someone who is so well loved and so liked.
You know,
that's,
that's a great argument for like chemical issues versus like a,
I mean you could tell some people just don't have good lives.
Everything's going bad for them.
They want to end their life cause they can't take the pain.
But then there's other people that are like him that are doing really well,
you know,
and you got to go,
man,
what is straight man to fuck it dude is a fucking issue.
And we have,
we all have this real problem when it comes to people doing things that we would
think would,
you know,
you'd consider to be something that someone who doesn't have control of
themselves does.
And we shun that.
We won't,
we don't like that it bothers us,
but there's a reality to like pain and suffering that we have to address.
And you know,
shaming someone for wanting to end their life is not sound.
You know,
until you've been faced with that kind of despair,
if you're that,
that if the juror despair level is to the point where you take your own life,
you have my utmost and everlasting sympathy.
I don't have a judgment on that.
I'd never been there.
So the idea that I'd be a core,
get it,
get it together,
usually had a rational decision for someone who's just commit suicide is the
only way out of this terrible situation is death.
That's a rational decision.
I,
I have,
I have nothing but my ultimate,
all you can do is shake your head and feel sad.
That's judgmental.
It's fucking completely horrible.
I mean,
when you stop and think about the idea of wanting to end your life,
you know,
I feel lucky,
I don't call it that,
that level of Serotonin in my brain,
but I think it,
again,
I think for a lot of people it goes back to,
you know,
what,
what's the chem,
what's the chemical reaction that's going on in your brain?
What they've done?
Is it,
uh,
you know,
it,
is it,
is it just an,
an issue with some sort of a disorder where there's like something that's not
producing the right amount of chemicals or is it a problem of your past?
Like it trauma,
inflation of dot.
A lot of different factors.
But one thing they know is that you have a set point for your serotonin.
And usually,
you know,
like certain people like me,
I probably have a serotonin level from one to 10 at usually seven to eight,
you know,
no matter what's going on,
I'm always,
I'm just lucky.
I just very rarely get depressed.
And if I do,
it's a mild sort of haze.
Some people they could,
they could invent the cure for every disease.
In the world and win the lottery and all this stuff.
They just go back to their serotonin levels being at four or whatever,
and it's just,
yeah,
I think it's a little bit more complicated than that,
but I think there's a,
yeah,
there's some people that are just never happy for whatever reason,
whatever reason,
chemically or whether it can be eight in the apprentices does always that.
Neil's always like,
as always been melancholy.
He's always been sort of in that blue region and I've always been so brilliant,
Neil Brennan,
so when you hear him talking about it,
like he was like,
yeah,
with the Chappelle stuff and he's like,
Yo man,
it was just here.
Myths,
chef,
medication.
I'm just here.
I just go through the motions.
He's a very smart guy.
Oh my God,
he's brilliant.
I think there's an also an issue with people that are really smart.
They look at the futility of it all.
It's sometimes harder for them to overcome this,
game it off.
He goes,
he goes,
he,
he'd suffer from depression.
Are you doing?
Yeah,
he wouldn't call me about where you been.
He goes,
Eh,
you know,
I got to touch the black dog.
And I'm like,
yeah,
cause you ever want to like kill somebody,
but you can't get yourself off the couch.
It's like you to depress.
You don't have to guess.
It's,
it's,
it's like some people have a real thing.
There's overwhelming,
there's no denying.
It's like,
but how much can exercise help you?
How much can dine help you?
It's,
it's a factor.
It's not the only factor,
but it's a factor.
You know?
And there's a lot of people that don't realize that and they go through life and
they have these issues.
And then there's people that have all the exercise and the Diet right.
And they still depressed,
still not the answer.
Like they have so much going for him.
And then there's head trauma.
You know,
there's always going to be a factor.
There's a Tbi and CTE and all the different things that that does to your head.
There's no doubt about that.
Chris Cornell Cause Chris Cornell had such an artistic,
um,
fully artistic,
such an he accomplished so much artistically and had a con is his art artistry
was continuing to flourish and kind of in the middle of that with children and
so much to live for antianxiety medication.
No,
he calls taking.
Yeah.
He called his wife up before he did it and he was slurring his words.
They think he was on a lot of that stuff.
How about the Lincoln Park?
He had seven kids.
That stuff that he had real depression too,
and he's essentially was young.
I was and but anti anxiety medication has various effects on people.
There's some people it's a godsend for,
but it's just like the Brazil nuts thing.
There's some people that going to have an adverse reaction to it and you have to
be prepared for whatever that reaction could be.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
Yeah.
It's all fucking bummer,
man.
The human body,
we don't have it figured out,
but God damn,
they're getting closer and closer.
It goes back to the fact that we're all very complicated.
We're all individuals.
So I have a little compassion for each other.
Have a little compassion,
would be nice.
There's a lot of people lashing out because they don't feel good.
And I'll watch this lady,
the other deck cut in front of somebody.
It was hilarious.
This guy's trying to get into this lane and this lady speeds up to try to keep
the guy from getting in the lane and the guy sees it.
So he just kind of eases over anyway and she just lays on her horn,
bam.
And then the guy pulls up like he's in this,
he's in his lane now and he pulls up and she gets in the next lane,
shoots in front of them,
turns her car in front of them and slams on the brakes.
And so he gets to the left of her and just starts going towards her and she
freaks out and turns into traffic and has to slam on the breaks.
Like you just had a crazy hissy fit over nothing cause you did that conti thing
that all of us have been guilty of doing where you don't let somebody in your
lane.
And this guy was like,
fuck you,
I'm getting in.
It's like she sped up,
she sped up to keep it from going in and I saw you watched it all play out and
you're like,
wow.
I was in Park City with my mother driving her SUV and I wasn't driving fast.
And this woman,
older woman with a very old,
like an old matronly like you used to be the principal of your school and short
hair.
And she had her golden retriever and she uh,
dressed in a preppy fashion.
Slow down.
Oh my God.
And then I go,
oh.
And I wasn't even like fast and she just goes and,
and I could hear her make that noise.
She goes like that with her and she gave me the hardest middle finger.
Oh my God.
I went,
are you kidding me?
And she goes,
I'm calling the police and reached for her phone right away.
I got,
that's what I said.
I go,
oh,
her one.
I go have a nice day.
And just kept going.
I remember getting in a road rage situation with this dude when I first moved to
La.
We're looking at each other on the highway and he takes his shirt off to show me
his tattoo.
He's screaming at me and I'm not reacting.
I'm just looking at him.
I'm like,
what is going to happen here?
why is this guy trying so hard to scare me?
He's like,
fuck you fucking pull over.
Fucking pull over.
So he takes his shirt off.
He's got all these tattoos by the ways it does not look built.
I'm like,
you're,
you're in trouble fella.
You don't really want to know how to fight sloppy.
It's highly doubt me get fooled sometimes when I'm like,
this is a guy who's trying to scare me,
which is probably,
he's probably terrified of noise.
Yeah.
And not so I'm just looking at them and the more I'm looking at him,
he just keeps screaming at me because I'm not reacting to them.
I'm just like,
like looking at him and he's screaming and I'm in my car driving and he's
looking at me and uh,
I was driving a suburban too,
which I thought was hilarious cause he goes,
you rich piece of shit.
I was like,
I'm going to suburban.
How do you know if I'm rich suburb?
Even like a rich car,
like the fuck are you talking about?
Like where's this coming from?
It was real screaming and I was thinking at this time I could make a terrible
mistake while I could tell you,
oh yeah,
I think I could just fuck this guy up.
Let me just pull this car over and teaches.
Asshole was the young guy.
Yeah.
Which yeah,
I wasn't only like 28 at the time.
I was still pretty fucking stupid,
but this guy screaming at me almost maybe realize how dumb it is.
I was like,
watch this guy taking his shirt off.
Show upside to this day though.
To this day they'd be like,
a day would go by that I would think I should just fuck that dude up.
Disaster.
A best case scenario though,
I literally think I should have just pulled over and kicked up fucking dude's
legs out from under them and choke them.
Unconscious be hilarious,
but it's so stupid.
It's hard for those thoughts 20 years later.
That's how dumb those instances where you want to go into a lane,
someone doesn't want to let you in.
They speed up and get fucking Hong Kong.
Fuck you like that tension.
It's so dumb.
You'll hold onto some of those dumb thoughts for decades.
Dude,
I have a guy,
the other day I was driving off Abot Kenny.
I looked at my phone at directions and I was at a stop sign and you know it was
my turn to go,
but I was looking down at my phone for directions and this guy behind me,
he's like a regular worker,
like in a car,
just goes nuts,
nuts,
honking horn.
I'd wave that.
I'm like my Batman and then I'm driving.
He goes around me who slams on the brakes and starts flipping off talking shit.
Oh my God,
dude,
come on God.
And I'm like,
all right.
All right,
go me.
I got it.
I got to up,
keep going.
And then he won't let me go.
I'm like,
dude,
y'all let me go man.
And he just keeps talking shit.
I'm like,
what the fuck am I going to do,
man?
I'm gonna beat up this tab,
the fuck am I going to do?
But he's playing a game that he thinks he's safe playing.
I don't know,
because we're not in Serbia.
Nobody's pulling guns out and gunning people down the street.
This,
these people,
they'll do that kind of shit.
I watched these two guys race each other and they were,
they were cutting in front of each other and slam on the breaks and doing that
thing.
It's slamming the brakes and yelling shit at each other at the window and just
watch him.
And he'd go like,
this could be nothing.
Or it could be your life.
Correct.
Like,
you could hit that guy,
he can go into traffic.
Somebody could die,
he could hit someone on the street.
Like,
you guys are speeding.
Like you're in this death race.
Like you're in some fucking mad max movie.
Well,
you're on a residential street to me,
this guy,
he's yelled at me and I'm like,
what are you gonna do,
man?
What are you going to do?
You're going to cut.
You gotta go,
you gonna fight me with the fucking to do.
And he's,
yeah,
that's a big deck.
What the fuck?
And I was like,
I took off my glasses on.
What?
You're fucking serious.
You're serious right now.
He's like,
oh it keeps going.
And then I thought,
what am I going to get out and get shot and fight this guy,
he has a gun and I was wanting to go left by coming cause he's blocked me.
So I went right.
I thought,
man,
my brother and my,
and my friends will make fun of me for going right when I show went,
but it's the right thing to do.
So right there I'm like,
what am I going to do?
Fight this fucking guy.
Think of that as being like,
you're running to a dog.
Are you supposed to like,
hey fuck you dog.
No,
you sit,
bitch.
Sit and supposed to go.
I got to go.
But the problem is it's a person.
So a person you think of is different than a dog.
Dog is not going to get the fuck away from that dog.
Yeah,
get the fuck away from that person too.
It's the ego thing to listen.
Dude,
I didn't have that 9.9% of the fucking human beings you're going to interact
with.
You could kill that should play heavy on your mind.
Know that you know I played on my mind was I went,
I bet he's going through some shit.
He probably went like a double shift.
Someone probably was texting before me and he,
he's just taking his anger out on me.
I'm just going to go right.
Fuck this man.
I don't need this.
Yeah,
but he could have been 10 you know,
and still acted like that and you should have the same reaction like,
oh God.
Like it's a child time.
He's a child.
He's a grownup baby.
When he cut me off,
the enemy's going to kick your ass.
I know.
I was like,
crap,
I want to two things,
either as a gun or he's fucking insane.
Those are the only two possibilities.
Correct.
Right.
Or he doesn't realize your gorilla sitting in your car.
You look like a normal size personal orange portion.
Fuck this warmup.
Yeah.
He probably feels like you're some preppy dickhead bel air.
Some Cutie Pie.
And be right.
Was talking about like road rage incidents,
you know,
they've figured out why people have road rage too.
And one of the reasons why to curse so often,
it's not just a separation by barriers between you and the other person.
So you don't have social cues.
It's also that your senses are jacked up because you're in the situation where
you know that you have to react potentially
at a very fast rate.
You have to be able to react instantaneously to someone changed the only slam on
the breaks.
Yeah.
Got gotta be so you're at heightened states and so then you interact with people
that you think maybe are fucking with that heightened state and he doesn't want
to lay on that horn you piece of shit to cut me off.
And you and everybody,
everybody's been guilty of it.
And everybody has to learn to negotiate those,
that weird,
uh,
extra urge of aggression that you get when you're in your car and don't,
don't get out of the car and fight.
Don't do it.
No,
don't do it.
But people want to do it,
man.
They want to do it all the time.
No bad idea.
People shoot,
people look at your head and you've got to kind of a big head.
Now you've got a friendly faith man.
What about your ears like I did,
first of all,
this bullshit haircut.
I'm in a orange Porsche.
I probably got skinny jeans on so when I get,
I get the binding.
Anyone,
he's not thinking of finding it.
It's all opposing thing.
It's all,
it's all a bluff charge.
It's all bluff charge.
That's exactly what it it all the way he cut me off though.
This guy was down.
She had,
but he's not down.
It's like a like a gorilla running up to you.
It was never planning on smashing it.
The shit worked.
I went right,
go left,
go all the way around.
He went home.
His Dick was hard as a rock.
He fucked the shit out of his wife.
I'm a fucking man.
It was a guy cut me off and I told him to fuck off or you want to fight your
mother fucker?
He said no,
and I'm going to fuck you.
And
they say they say that.
And what was that book by Malcolm Gladwell wearing wherever you're from,
um,
has to do with how you react to a fronts.
So like they did this experiment where they would have a Guy Bay,
they'd have you take two fake tests and you had to take a test in this room and
then you had to go down the hall and take a test in another room.
As you are walking down the hall together test you would get,
um,
somebody would walk by you,
bump you and go watch out ass hole and keep walking.
And the dude's from the south versus the guys from the north.
The dude's from the south,
there's Sarah Tall level,
whatever the,
all those levels.
There's Sarah told levels,
their testosterone levels,
everything was Jack to the fucking roof.
They were ready to fight dude.
Some in north,
Nah,
not at all.
They were like,
Huh,
whatever.
What a Dick.
And it had to do according to global and not really also this guy in this bit as
well.
It had to do with where you are from.
And more importantly,
where your ancestry heralded from.
If you came from a culture and honor culture as opposed to a,
what they call the dignity culture.
So if you came from a culture where honor was everything,
and those cultures are hurting cultures,
that's where you get the Chinese.
That's where you get the Afghanis.
That's where you get the North Scots,
Irish.
That's why Armenians,
Armenians,
wines will fuck you up.
Yes,
Armenians are tough shit.
Shoulder checks.
I'm Armenian in the street.
They will punch you in the,
they don't fuck around.
Our meeting yourself was scrapped and tight knit communities.
I like that.
But,
but,
but it was,
it was from honor cultures and the Scots Irish who settled where the
Appalachians,
the,
the Hatfields and McCoys
the fuck.
Yup.
When you go to Ireland,
you go to parts of the UK,
you know,
in the north where Tony's from,
good luck.
Go see what happens in a bar.
When you want to get scrappy,
you'll,
you'll find plenty of men to meet you halfway.
Whereas if you go to certain other parts of the world where they didn't come
from hurting cultures,
where they came from a culture that,
uh,
relied mostly on agriculture where it relied on cooperation,
where it see,
cause when you're a herder and somebody steals your sheep,
you will not survive the winter.
So you've got to let everybody know that if you do steal my sheep,
I'm going to kill you and every man in your fucking family because I'm a crazy
motherfucker.
So,
so you know,
it's,
it's do or die here,
right?
It's literally survival of your family.
Nisbett and,
and uh,
the Gladwell did and he just wrote a book about it.
But like some of these guys who actually did the primary research on that proof
that culture,
even though you don't know those people,
even though your generations,
you know,
removed from that in this country,
that shit has deep,
deep roots in your cultural psyche.
And,
and of course also a form of genetic memory,
genetic memory,
but also cultural memory also,
that's,
you're raised as a man to,
to protect your cubic space.
Who had to fight me.
He was with a herder.
I'm sure he was.
It was probably on Adderall and he's felt he was down.
He's bluffed charges.
Just got off a double shift.
He has a hurting,
hurting mentos.
What kind of car did he have?
It was a la county truck.
Oh,
was Mexican.
You guys want to read about that geography?
I thought,
I think by a Harold husband.
He's a phenomenal guy and bringing how truck geography,
that's lot move.
It's a way to get fired real quick.
Give a fuck.
Gotcha.
He got me,
he got me.
I had to go around the block.
It took me more time cause you don't come from that call was embarrassed.
Funny how he's such a bad ass,
but he's like,
no,
it's not that I don't my,
but you do that to my brother.
Listen,
my brother said some issues on the road,
you know,
and this stuff.
I,
my dad has two I've seen with my own eyes with me,
the stuff I have going on.
If I get out of the car,
you're,
I fight that guy.
I lose everything.
I stay on for it for sure.
All my gigs do.
Everything's gone for and for what?
But it's self defense,
but it's not,
it's not your fault.
You're forcing yourself.
And what do you think the headline reads?
Ellie worker beats up UFC fighter.
No,
I hope not.
No embarrassing.
Yeah.
I think you'd have relationships.
You fight or twists.
Man's head off,
gets arrested,
goes to prison.
This is not a good move.
It's show time as he shows.
No sign.
There's nothing funny.
A guy
beating up another guy.
No,
there's no upside to it.
And it's also you can avoid it.
You know?
It can be avoided and pause,
posturing,
bullshit and screaming comes from not being able to fight.
I agree.
If you could have a like a bar filled with Jujitsu,
black pilots,
probably the friendliest fucking bar ever.
You're the tough guys.
Don't,
it's like gun culture because I interviewed a hangout with a bunch of gun guys
there.
They're super formal and respectful because they're used to seeing bullets
flying around.
Everybody's got to mind their p's and q's when everybody's actually equal.
If you're a bunch of gun handlers and all of you,
you're going to gun competitions and shit and you shoot and plink plink,
plink plink roll in and like fucking Keanu Reeves and shit.
Those guys,
you know that's an,
there are equal to everybody in the world.
I'll have to do is this,
I mean they've,
they bounce it out to a squeeze of a trigger and seal team.
We say arms aren't walking around going,
I'm in the seals.
Watch out,
Bro.
I want to get to the front of the line.
Exactly.
Yeah.
There was a bunch of marines that came to the common story of the night.
Real nice guys.
They were there for this toys for tots thing,
hanging out with them,
talking to them afterwards,
and then there's some weird drunk guy comes up to me after the marines left and
he asked me about recon marines.
It was like,
oh,
look at that.
It just went in here sick.
That was throw up ladies and gentlemen.
That's what we trying to avoid.
That sounds amazing.
It just fluid.
We should probably end this anyway.
I'm going to,
who's going to,
yeah,
let's,
I'm going to Mexico.
He's throwing up again.
He clean cleaning that thing.
We just throw that away.
Give we get another one.
Let's throw that away.
We got another,
you're hurting.
We're not,
um,
blue.
Ooh.
I've just watched a bunch of puke coming out of Brendan jobs mouth.
Anyway,
it's all good.
Super.
Sorry about all this.
Good way to end.
It's good way then.
It's a good way to end.
Um,
Brian Callen,
you got any dates coming up?
I'm glad you asked.
January 12,
January 12th.
Don't puke through my dates.
January 12th,
13th,
14th,
ma'am,
I'm in.
I'm in fucking,
uh,
where am I holding?
On January 12th 30,
I'm in Nashville at Janie's and then at the end of the month,
uh,
Columbus funnybone January 25th,
26th,
27th,
you could see Fatca and shop at the Wilbur Theater in Boston,
but saw dash,
I'm in Portland before the 11th to the 13th.
He just threw up and I'm in Denver on the first February and then second,
third seat.
Let's go see me.
I won't be sick.
Yeah.
He won't be sick.
Not bitches sold out.
I love you.
What are you doing on Wednesday night?
Why would you want to do a set at the icehouse?
Helia okay.
Then Brennan Xapi,
the Ice House Ice House sold out too.
He fucks.
Um,
this Friday night,
I'm at the Mirage in Las Vegas with the great and powerful Ian Edwards,
and then New Year's Eve,
the day after the UFC,
two shows at the Wiltern in Los Angeles.
All right.
I apologize you guys,
I apologize.